[Music]
thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
questions
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
s
for this cozy coastal town the holiday
season isn't over
in fact the most wonderful time of the
year has really just begun come on gotta
make a move no no no no no no no no no
oh my gosh I'm speechless there
once again vikon Zay starts the new year
as the center of the chess Universe this
year as host of the 85th taught to steal
chess tournament
a magnet for the best players in the
game some recognize the Masters field of
2023 as its strongest in recent memory
of course it helps when eight-time Tata
steel chess champion Magnus Carlson is
back what a game for Magnus and now a
huge chance to make a furious run at
first place the world's number one looks
to further cement his legacy in this
event and the game's history
chasing Magnus will be amongst the best
in chess several have been crowned
Champion here before some have even
shocked the world in doing so
and don't leave out those poised to
capture their first Tata title Anish
Geary is just I mean he beat both world
number one and world number two in the
same tournament
although winter Tata steel chess is also
known as the place new stars come to
bloom
Magnus one here is a teenager this
year's event has its fair share of young
players on the rise each hoping to
follow in Carlson's footsteps why
what the Dutch refer to Tata steel as
The Wimbledon of chess for 85 years in
running this tournament continues to be
steeped in Prestige and Legacy and does
so again in this welcoming Little Dutch
town by the sea
mine Brendan it's the 85th edition of
the Tata steel chess tournament and it
starts right now
[Music]
today is the 10th round in Vikings day
I'm Grandmaster Robert Hess alongside me
is international Master Ivanka houska
yovi you've been covering the last bunch
of rounds they've been very exciting how
are you feeling today
oh I'm feeling awesome I mean the games
have been so intense and the players are
just think giving it they're all
absolutely wonderful stuff
they certainly have been in one player
in particular who's trying to make his
run at his first championship in touch
still is Anish giri we caught up with
him to talk about his mentality his
match against Wesley so and his
tournament Outlook he had some mixed
feelings hear it right now
um yeah I was watching Interview of
Magnus and I really liked when he said
that he doesn't think about tournament
Victory so that's okay if Magnus doesn't
think about tournament Victory why
should I so I'm not going to think about
it either
I my upcoming games are not exactly
winnable but uh I'll do my best what's
your history against Wesley obviously we
are two of the most solid players out
there so I assume uh We've made a lot of
draws but of course uh actually we did
have some back and forth actually
um in fact it's between me uh at various
occasions I have also beaten him as well
despite that we indeed are the most
solid players out there
so it's going to be
I'm going to be fun I really like the
the fact that we've got two games
between today's and it's kind of fun
that we have a rest day I have two
blacks and then another rest day it's
like my two blacks that are given so
much you know that they're giving me
like uh with a date of repair and a day
to rest I really appreciated that yeah I
mean okay a lot of rounds it's
remarkable here because it feels like
you've played so much and a few days ago
my second told me that they're at some
point he said that there are like seven
rounds to go and I was like what what
seven rounds to go like
there's so many rounds it's really a
special tournament it feels like we're
playing forever but we still have to
play a lot of games you know it's quite
quite fun
it is indeed a marathon and any skier is
sprinting towards the top of the
standings he beat dingley Ram with the
black pieces so Joey we heard him talk
about Wesley so being a solid player
he's shown that he can beat dingley Wren
who went kind of out of character and
just made all heck break loose
yeah I mean it was an absolutely
Sensational game I have to say Dean
Lauren looked like he started on the
front foot but Anish giri he was so
resourceful I mean he played just a
superb game and someone else playing a
superb game was actually Richard report
as he defeated Arjun aragaisi with the
black pieces do check out that game if
you can and I have to say when it comes
to tournaments it's not just about
winning it's about showing your
resilience showing every single bit of
defensive skill you possess and someone
who had that in Spades yesterday it was
nordebec Abdul sotorov as he held off
Vincent Heimer very important research
there it certainly was yoga you had a
marathon call there with Dania and
Norbeck it was a huge half point for him
because with that draw he still
maintains a lead over the field and
while the lead is shrinking a little bit
with anishikiri's win abusatara you will
see his name atop the standings through
nine rounds so in first place clear
first place is abusitar with six and a
half points Anish giri with six after
that Victory and Wesley so don't count
him out he's been a little bit under the
radar I feel like but he's in clear
third yovi yeah there's so much to play
for four games left and uh let's not
discount that there are several players
chasing including Magnus Carlson Five
Points out of nine and it's not really
how you start it's always how you finish
such a cliche so true
it certainly is especially in this field
in this event with 13 total rounds as
players get exhausted we heard Anish
gear in that interview saying I can't
believe so many rounds are left and he
also talked about Wesley so in
particular so as we look forward to
today's matchups Anish he gets the black
pieces once again he talked about how
it's great between the two rest days he
has all that time to prepare with the
black pieces Wesley not an easy opponent
for anybody in the planet he has this
really solid style he doesn't often take
too many risk but he will grind you down
if presented Advantage so that should be
a really interesting matchup today
yeah absolutely and talking about
another interesting match matchup I
can't wait for this one it is naughty
back and he will be facing off against
ding now remember ding had quite a tough
day yesterday I can't wait to see how he
gets back from this one
yeah Jordan Von Forrest and Vincent
camera two players who are struggling at
least in terms of the standings but they
have a chance to end the tournament on
the right note Jordan with the white
pieces but Yogi I'm really excited about
this matchup between Richard report and
Lavon aronian because Richard won that
great game yesterday two wins in a row
for him and Lavon he also has been kind
of under the radar he has one win and
the rest of his games were drawn yeah
and then we move on to Fabiano caruana
against Arjun aragaisy both of these
players really need to get a must win
because Arjun era guys of course he is
coming from his third loss in a row and
then we also have good cash against
pregnant and a big rivalry there who is
better out of these two Indian produce
well we'll find out today
I'm really glad I don't have to answer
that question and it was rhetorical
because I do not know a prognan that he
seems to be rising at the right moment
gucash has struggled in this field but
he has huge successes to his name
including Olympiad gold medal but last
certainly not least we have Parham
magsudu taking on Magnus Carlsen yovi
Magnus he's the favorite no matter what
tournament no matter who he's playing
but with the black pieces do you think
Arham is going to be as adventurous as
he has been to this point in the
tournament
yeah Parham is really displayed some
fighting Spirit perhaps taking it a
little bit too far and I'm using the
British understatement uh basically you
know he has over pushed himself in
certain points definitely param has
proven to himself to be such a strong
Contender and Magnus if he wants to
defeat him with the black pieces we'll
certainly have his work cut out for him
he will indeed in this tournament with
such a long time Patrol we start with a
hundred minutes for the first 40 moves
after that the pledge an additional 50
minutes for the next 20 and once they
reach moves 60 it's 15 minutes for the
rest of the game 30 second bonus from
The Game's first move and the game's
first moves will start soon we see the
players seated in their chairs we have
none other than nodier back Abu satar of
he is always ready I mean that he has
been on fire in this event you know he
and as you said it's not all about the
wins and losses he drew that game
yesterday and that might be his most
important result of all because if he'd
lost that game and each gear had tied
him in the standings all could have been
falling apart at the wrong time
yeah and we can see some messages from
our featured chat telling us who are
they are supporting and they're talking
about supporters just take a look at
that crowd you can feel the energy of
these chess enthusiasts and lovers and
we just look at them it's so wonderful
to be there in a big tournament Hall
with a hustle and bustle of the crowd
certainly and we see para maksudu he is
awaiting the world chess champion in all
three time patrols Magnus may be giving
up he may be relinquishing his classical
chess title and this is a classical
event so Magnus he's going to take on
Parham but Parham he looks ready today
and somebody who's always fashionable is
Lavon aroni actually both these players
Jovi have great fashion senses yeah they
do both on and off the board I mean I
kind of consider both of them to be very
creative and very flamboyant characters
and uh that we see Lavon getting ready
with the black pieces Richard uh coming
off uh two victories so suddenly his
star is in the ascendant and I'm
wondering whether he can actually pull
together even more victories in order to
make a late minute search to take the
top spots and uh there we see Wesley sir
against Anish giri and uh I can feel the
tension here I'm not gonna lie a niche
wants to win this tournament you know it
must be so frustrating to be five time
runner-up and never to have uh
there you go handshake and I was gonna
say you know he got as far as the
playoff against you on the van forest in
2021 and uh they're off Knight F3 on the
board
and D5 the response and just to follow
up your point it must be frustrating for
Anish giri especially because his
compatriot and friend Jordan Von Forest
kind of stole that title I put that in
air quotes it was well deserved by
Jordan but if any Dutchman were to win
this event you would have thought it was
going to be Anish Kiri but it wasn't
meant to be at least not yet and is that
uh tenguzendam right there taking photos
right by the players that is dirkian uh
taking the photo of the game between
Wesley and Nation for those who don't
know that is the editor of new and chess
magazine he is so important in the Chess
World
yeah and I see a lot of support for
Anish and he is considering what to do
after Wesley has opened with the ready
and
I have to say Wesley of course you know
he plays everything and anything but I
haven't seen him play too many times the
ready opening
no I haven't either but it is one of the
many different solid openings that
Wesley so could choose and for Wesley I
said this earlier he doesn't love taking
risks he doesn't want to be in a
situation where he has to play for a win
from move one and the good thing about a
long event is even if you are behind in
the standings you have a little bit of
time to catch up for example if he's
able to win this game against Anish giri
he not only LeapFrogs a niche but if
nordierbeck were to lose that he'd be in
a tie for first so we're only three
moves in we can't talk about victories
but there's sometimes a little victories
like catching your opponent by surprise
Yobe it doesn't seem like Anish was at
all shocked by Wesley's opening choice
at least in the first few moves he is
playing very quickly and even left his
chair
yeah he has left his chairs I always
feel in the opening when you get the
opportunity to leave your chair so early
on it's kind of like drop the mic
surprising
all is good
yeah and it all is good because we see a
position where a strong Pawn chain has
been established from F7 to D5 for a
newt whereas Wesley playing this kind of
modern style of Rusty the black pieces
is often the modern defense but because
Wesley is white we see a retire King's
Indian attack potential for him if he's
going to play D3 slide that Knight into
D2 and push this Pawn to E4 later in the
game so it's a very flexible approach
from Wesley and yo let me ask you
because Anish is so well regarded for
his opening preparation do you think
Wesley isn't afraid of it but he's just
trying to avoid it all together
yeah I think it's a good idea to avoid
anisha's opening preparation but we've
seen it throughout this tournament he's
been very well prepared he's come armed
with a lot of dangerous surprises and I
I definitely think you know maybe get
the game into your own territory we have
seen you know well once you're in your
own ground well you can tend to trick
your players and I you know what opening
I would really love to see it kind of
goes back to the olden days with Fisher
I would love to see a king's Indian
attack I mean it's so rare at top level
I would love to see Wesley just go for
it risk everything in order to Checkmate
the black king
that's sometimes what it takes is a
little slower approach but then throw
all your pieces at the enemy King and
and maybe what is causing Wesley to slow
down is the fact that instead of
bringing his Bishop out to F5 that Anish
kind of blocked his own Bishop a lot of
the French defense and perhaps Wesley
thinking preparing for that this morning
and now he's faced with a different
opening with E6 so the bishop is shut
down but black is prioritizing the
development of the other bishop and
always strike forward with C5 so these
little subtleties the nuances they play
a huge role in dictating the trajectory
of the game so you'll be Wesley is not
unfamiliar with these three moves with
this position but he's undoubtedly
thinking do I switch over to a Catalan
with D4 and then C4 is that the
direction he wants to go or as you're
advocating for will he play D3 Knight D2
castle and eventually strike four with
E4 and E5 in the king's Indian style
yeah I I was also uh thinking I mean
it's a quite an interesting scenario
actually for Wesley because
um Anish has literally repeated the same
move order that he played against ding
yesterday because
yeah anisha's had a double black and uh
they're the kind of game kind of went
this very obscure path where it became
like this almost
um had to describe it a double
fianchetto with a C4 and
was that against thing
sometimes you know sometimes you watch
so many games that oh can they all merge
together and form into one but I'm
pretty sure there was like some game
where Anish had this situation where
he's pushed the pawn to D4 you you were
correct it was yesterday's game against
Ding and I know that feeling very well
of every single game is that from this
term like commentating or is it the last
one or was it three tournaments ago but
you are correct and it was the same
start where you put his Bishop on E7
eventually it was pop up to D4 and
because oftentimes we don't repeat an
opening that we just played that may be
why Wesley is thinking because I believe
if we just take a step back for a second
that fans like he just saw a niche for
this yesterday he must have looked at
this in great detail and improved upon
it but often these top players they're
playing a bit of dodgeball it's like if
you think I'm gonna do X I'm actually
gonna do y in this game so all your
preparation was wasted in the morning so
we'll leave Wesley to it and he really
is deliberating his options it's still
early we'll see what he continues with
but Yogi we have six other games and you
know I'm looking across I see the top
left by the way and the second from the
left and the bottom there's a rook up on
E5 so no deerback abusatara against
England the top left and then Richard
report against levonne Ronin second from
left to bottom they have the same exact
start to the game
okay
that's uh yeah that's very unusual
actually yesterday almost everybody
began with d45 now we're seeing everyone
well not everyone but quite a few games
I actually switch over to E4 e5s
um shall we take a look at our
tournament leader uh Abdul sotorov and
as he faces off with the white pieces
against ding
okay and we see nmi saying copying and
laughing but there has been a slight
change between the two games we'll start
from the beginning it was a Spanish here
and after Knight F6 gases Knight takes
E4 we see what could be the Berlin if
white plays D4 but Yogi it's all the
rage these days to avoid the topical
lines and that was so from the kaspara
we don't need to get into the Berlin at
least those variations so we saw the
rookie one line which is very solid for
white it doesn't give that double-edged
nature of the end game uh but sometimes
I feel it's too solid what what's your
opinion of these rookie one lines
um symmetrical Pawn structure that's all
I'm going to say
very very difficult
[Laughter]
I'm sorry I like my simplistic terms no
I appreciate how concise you were
because I also understood what you were
saying uh simplistic term simplistic
position we just have the bishop
dropping back the Knight capturing and
we are even all the pieces are the same
except for the fact after castles Knight
C3 Fisher F6 rookie one this is the live
position not too much has happened but
the bishop on CA that's the slow piece
to develop so oftentimes white tries to
claim the slimmest of slim advantages
because you're a little bit ahead in
terms of development but Yogi I'm with
you it's a symmetrical position and that
often rubs me the wrong way
yeah I mean I I find that they're very
sophisticated
um you I mean we're talking about small
margins here we're talking about
maximizing the pieces and we're also
just talking about playing very
purposeful moves and if abdusitor can do
that as he's done plenty of times before
then I think he will put ding under a
lot of pressure because I have to say
one thing about doing in this tournament
he has seemed to struggle with the
exception of the first few games in the
opening I mean perhaps that's because
he's suddenly been trying his luck in
different openings just to get the
experience or hiding some more
Championship prep it feels like if
you're going to catch thing is going to
be in these early stages
that's true and now I'm also wondering
for noderbeck after such a long game
yesterday uh it was tense he was
defending throughout that end game
that's stressful for a player so I'm
wondering if in this game he doesn't
mind I know we don't like the d word but
to make a safe and sound draw when you
talk symmetrical structure it's not
always just handshakes but he could make
a safe move like Knight D5 and try to go
for the bishop pair and even if dingly
red won't be worse maybe noneerbeck
wants to kind of Glide towards the
Finish Line he gets a rest day tomorrow
yesterday uh was one of the biggest
workouts of his life defending the end
game in such an important tournament
standing against Vincent kymer so I'm
wondering yovian we're just speculating
at this point but if he's just taking
the safe approach because he wants to
maintain a tournament lead heading into
the final three rounds yeah I I
absolutely think that would be a very
pragmatic decision uh there are two
players playing though and I think ding
on the other hand will certainly want to
actually psychologically use that and uh
just try to encourage uh Abdus to make
those slightly negative in almost
intangible decisions so that when the
time comes Abdus could find himself
being slightly worse and then it getting
gradually worse and worse
yeah I think that England would love a
long end game trying to show off his
veteran experience and the fact that
he's a number two rated player in the
world but in this tournament it's looked
like no deer back up to sitarov was one
of the top few players in the world and
he really is at this point his rating
doesn't seem to have caught up to his
true strength but he has gained
23.2 ready points thus far for those of
you who are not familiar with chess
rating system that is a ton of points
for a player at the 2700 plus level
because nobody record new status entered
the top 20 players in the world he's
going to be pushing the top 15 top 10
but what's so interesting to me is when
this is a kind of Youth versus
experience matchup they've never played
in classical chess
yeah that's uh it's very very
interesting and I also like the fact
that yeah definitely both of them are
dealing with unknowns but I'm just going
to draw the eye back to this absolutely
staggering rating Points Plus
23.2 when you said it like literally my
mouth dropped a little bit I thought
whoa It's so difficult to gain rating
points and he's just gaining a bucket
load and uh there we can see ding has
lost 13.7 rating points so far and so he
definitely needs to win his pride is at
stake and I think he's dropped under the
2800 club and obviously this is not
something that Ding wants to do or wants
to go into the match at the world
championship match on the back of a bad
tournament
yeah you don't want to doubt yourself in
any way heading into a world
championship matchup and just to paint a
clear picture for those you may not be
familiar with the rating system if you
beat somebody with the same exact rating
that you have you gain five points so if
you think about 23.2 ready points you
essentially have beaten someone with
your rating four times in a row and then
gained a handful of points after that so
it's very difficult to win a single game
at the highest level let alone to beat
players like Magnus Carlson and the rest
of the cast that Noni Breck has taken
down so a dingley ran he's had the
opposite kind of tournament sometimes
that happens when you're hiding your
preparation in anticipation of a big
tournament or match like he is but you
know that he wants to get down the
Finish on the right path he wants to
head into the world championship with
good feelings about his recent chess but
no dearbeck he has other intentions he's
thinking right now so is he deliberating
about this move Knight D5 to B that
seems like the simplest and safest move
move just go for the pair of Bishops why
not there's symmetrical structure let's
get those little advantages that we've
been talking about and if we go Knight
to D5 there's no root where good for
this bishop on F6 to go and if that's
the case then I'll gladly take it and
just say all right two Bishops we top
level players we love that
I agree with that completely and let's
have a look at the bird's eye view
because I'm very keen to see how uh well
the world champion although he's soon
not to be the world champion is doing uh
in terms of the body language I've
learned that if there's one person you
cannot read it is Magnus because just
looking at the camera he doesn't look
like that thrilled
um but uh knowing him he's probably
hyper focused and uh considering the
position keenly and there we see there
you have it up on the screen and it is
actually
a Queen's Gambit to my eyes Queen's
Gambit declined exchange variations
just to go back to the beginning E6
Queen's game declined and then the pawn
was captured on D5 so you're 100 spot on
there and Bishop G5 Bishop E7 breaking
the pin uh that was on this Knight so
the D5 Pawn is defended enough times you
don't have to play C6 just yet and after
E3 H6 which is oh
all in these days loving to kick the
bishop away the bishop drops back and
now Bishop G4 so this I think when we
tuned in yovi we both were kind of like
Bishop G4 is that common is that the
move and uh Magnus you may have some
tricks up his sleeve but Bishop G4 as
far as I can see not been played at this
high level so it looks strange to me
because I'm already looking at Queen B3
as soon as the bishop leaves its home
Square the B7 Pawn becomes tender and
it's not just B7 but also D5 and just to
put the move on the board we are
creating a double attack B7 is left
undefended and if you move the pawn up
I've removed the guard with Bishop takes
F6 and once you take back down goes D5 I
have two pieces hitting it I can take
with my queen on D5 and go up a clear
Pawn so the big question that Parham is
asking himself is what does Magnus have
up his sleeve if he does in fact play
the move Queen to B3 right now it is a
simple straightforward double attack
Yogi how do you anticipate Magnus to
meet this move
yeah well he has to do it in a very
radical way and my first instinct is you
have to perhaps go Knight C6 to try to
get the Knight to B4 and
try to get some compensation via Knight
C2 check and maybe even trap the White
Queen if a white isn't careful
um just to put down the board that this
Knight coming out there's all these
threads of night scene two years you're
saying might trap the queen so this is
looking very adventurous
it is adventurism I can see the
evaluation bar is like no no no that is
not the way there's there has to be
something better I mean what is his
magnus's plan and I just have to Echo
your thoughts I've been playing the
Queen's Gambit the client under this
particular variation for quite a long
time and I have never ever seen this
move I've never even seen the idea I
mean I've always just kind of thought in
order to get the light Square Bishop out
you just have to solidify your Pawn
structure in the middle middle and uh
just support the pawn by playing C6 or
castling King side you know you do those
kind of things
um that light Square Bishop is not meant
to be out there so early so Magnus
breaking the rules and and kind of
curious after Queen B3 if it's not
Knight C6
is his idea
uh
well I was just gonna I don't know I was
gonna latch under what you were saying
Joey for a second because uh the top
players we've heard this from five on a
car one often that sometimes you even
play a dubious variation If It's Tricky
for your opponent to find the best move
so even though the evaluation bar set in
this continuation that white is better
uh maybe the path towards keeping that
Advantage is very hard to find with the
threat of Knight C2 check uh there's
also the opportunity instead of Knight
C6 this tricky move Knight to D7 because
the pawn on D5 is actually defended
tactically Knight takes D5 is a common
mistake that uh players make because
after Knight takes D5 you see that Queen
takes D5 the Bishops are staring at each
other and I will just win your bishop
and if you say okay I don't want to lose
my Bishop let me take yours first the
Knight actually drops back to take
isn't their Checkmate as well
did I miss the position coming to B4 oh
my gosh I was winning a piece and you
know they do say when you see Checkmate
look for better and I thought winning a
piece was better but you are correct my
I have not done my tactics this morning
that is I don't think I've seen a
Checkmate like this before
well I I know the pattern because
um my my Juniors were all teaching me
about this trick where black sacrifices
a queen in this particular variation and
it's all based on this check so I
already had it in my senses I think
well I think I could use a lesson from
the players that you're working with
there but that's a really nice line so
you can't take on D5 for two different
reasons it would appear and if you can't
take on D5 black is a head development
you moved your queen out to B3 and if
you say gobble gobble give me that pawn
that I'm after then comes Rook B8 Rook
takes B2 and even if white is a pawn to
The Good the position is quite bad
because your king is in the center none
of your kingside pieces are developed
and this probably will be too much uh to
deal with after crook takes B2 Bishop B4
and this king is not where it needs to
be so I actually think uh Magnus is
playing this very cleverly he's being a
bit cheeky and for Parham you can tell
that he's not familiar with this move by
the fact that he is deep in thought
trying to work out why Queen V3 doesn't
just win him upon I think Knight bd7 is
that solution
yeah I I like this idea
um if you were param and you were faced
with this particular novelty do you do
like a Boris sparsky where you go well
this idea should be treated with respect
I therefore I'm just going to play in a
very safe way maybe play for two results
try to get a draw and then go back to
the drawing board at home in the comfort
of your own sitting room and refute this
analysis or in this particular situation
if you were param would you go you know
what you can't play chess like that so I
therefore I'm going to play moves like
F3 kick that Bishop away and you are
going to get punished for playing such
uh very such a weird move
it's a provocative move so F3 uh would
be a nice refutation kicking the bishop
away but maybe that's what Magnus is
looking for after F3 the E3 Pawn becomes
a little bit tender A Pawn's best friend
is another Pawn we see a strong Pawn
chain as it currently sits as soon as
you push this Pawn up then E3 is
something you need to look out for uh
for pretty much the remainder of the
game until something happens to it so uh
to answer your question directly I feel
like I trust Magnus and because it's a
double edged position I might just make
the move Bishop to E2 trade off the
Bishops finish my development but
sometimes playing the safe choice is
actually more dangerous than taking it
to him saying I don't believe you let's
just evaluate the position think ignore
the opponent just look at the board and
calculate so I think there are these two
paths to go forward with and I think
sometimes you trust your opponent too
much and it really backfires whereas
Queen B3 we saw even if you're not
winning a pawn it's not a bad move
Bishop E2 you can hardly fault someone
for making that decision but you don't
want Magnus to feel super comfortable as
early as the first 10 moves because
that's when he starts to flex his
muscles he is the strongest player in
the planet and if he even has the
smallest chance to play for more he'll
do that and he often wins games like
that
yeah I I agree uh interesting situation
I have to say on a personal level I
think I would go towards that how dare
you if they move like this you're not
gonna get away with putting your light
Square Bishop out outside of this Pawn
chain and I would perhaps attack it or
play Queen B3 and say but I I admit I
would probably not be so bold if I were
facing the world champion himself and uh
okay this is a very interesting position
and certainly it's decision time for
Parham shall we have a look at the
bird's eye view and uh see what else
takes our fancy
well the game catching my eye is the one
second from the right and the bottom row
between gookesh and pragnananda because
I see that there's a Pawn on D5 things
are looking electric with the Rook on G1
staring at the black king so I'm just
gonna go ahead and pull up that game and
normally I'm very polite I'll be like Yo
which game do you want to go to uh but
when the g-pawn is gone and there's a
rook staring at a black king I don't
know what opening this is from but I
just like it from a commentator's
perspective
yeah like I have to completely agree
with you a thousand percent but I also
like to know how on Earth did the
players get here this feels random
it is random not Fisher random chess we
saw a car Nakamura win that world title
in 2022 but we started with a
symmetrical English I would not have
expected that and we see it's the Four
Knights variation white goes first White
strikes first with D4 and black just
took so all this has been played many
many times E6 to open up your dark
Square Bishop for development A3
importantly taking away the B4 square
with a pin and that way you can later
strike with move E4 and don't have to
worry about this Knight being pinned so
Mission B7 com move and then E4 so Yogi
at least from the start of this game
things look normal and then Knight F3
this Knight has moved once twice and
then make it Thrice that is going
against the opening principles we teach
our students
yeah it is certainly a case of don't try
this at home and I did like a comment
from the featured chat there we said
that their position kind of looked like
the positions I get as a 1300 and it
just goes to show anything can happen I
mean here we have top players just
breaking the rules I agree definitely
don't do this I suspect it's because
determined to keep all the pieces on the
board and make sure that there are no
trades so that's why he's uh wasting
time like kind of use wasting time in
air quotes because obviously he's not
and let's see how it continues the queen
came out to A5 of course big threat on
the board of Knight takes porn
so Bishop D2 block that and that's how
the queen got to HR because when we were
in the live position I just didn't quite
understand how the queen left from d8 to
H5 but it makes perfect sense now that
we went through the move by move of the
opening so the Queen's on H5 Rook G1 now
we typically say your Rook should be on
F1 and your king should be on G1 but I
feel like I'm watching John the Palm
that she play like this is such a nepo
type of move let's go for the attack
with G4 and that's exactly what happened
when your opponent's playing on the
flank let's strike in the center it says
prognanda there's a king on E1 if we
start trading here and I can get a rook
to E8 well your king may find itself at
the end of the line so instead we saw G4
I'm loving this and after Knight takes
only now does he take on D5 because the
Knight on F6 was so important at keeping
the pawn on D5 defended after e takes
Knight takes D5 here is where we sit
both players are going to have their
work cut out for them yovi because as I
look at this position the King on Jade
doesn't look the safest nor does the
King on E1 this bishop on E7 you're not
so threatened by Knight takes E7 because
you're not on C6 defense but maybe
there's Knight F4 and your queen is
almost trapped on H5 so I feel like
there's almost misdirection at play and
so it feels more precarious for
prognananda than it does for gukesh
yeah
it's uh I have to say I I don't know
quite what's happening here I'm a little
bit uh confused
um
because after all black hasn't done
anything wrong I mean apart from this
whole Queen dance you know coming out to
A5 and H5 they followed the rules you
know castled when white started working
on the wings black struck in the center
and
it's just such a strange position
because I can see a situation where once
the black king gets out of the eyeline
of the white rook and also I quite like
my Bishop pair so I really would like
pragnanda to preserve this dark Square
Bishop I can just see that in terms of
long-term prospects it is the white king
that isn't going to find a safe home and
I don't quite see where it's going I
mean it can Castle yes
but yeah it's not going to have much fun
there but there's so many loose pieces
as you point out the bishop only seven
the Knight on G4 it feels like it's
anyone's game
I'm gonna show a sample variation
because keeping the bishop looks very
strong so we bring up an analysis board
here uh the move Bishop C5 looks almost
winning for black because you're hitting
this Pawn on F2 but I was already
thinking what happens when the G file
opens and that's why I spotted this
tactic if I go queenie2 and you play
Bishop takes F2 check it looks like
you're just winning material but you see
the eval goes Sky High yeah
go ahead oh I was gonna say however I
was gonna quote uh
from absolutely fabulous and she does
one of my favorite favorite one lion is
however the very next day
the very next day
your queen goes away on H5 Knight F6
check that pawn oh oh it's not letting
me take because the Rook pins that pawn
after the king makes its only move
Knight takes H5 white is up a piece for
just some pawns and this is a winning
Advantage for white so I think cash has
studied this opening Yogi and the move
Bishop C5 to my eyes looks very natural
as you're saying you want to keep the
bishop pair but this Knight needs to
keep F6 uh protected after Queen E2 the
eval bar still says black is doing
pretty well maybe even slightly better
but it's what we were talking about
earlier these are the type of variations
where black makes one single mistake you
might be lost let's say you make a
careless with A6 already to move H3
kicking this Knight out the way allows
for Knight F6 check winning the queen so
this position is so tricky for prognanda
to figure out and I don't know as a king
to h8 is that the way to get out of the
way is it it's some other movement just
play Bishop C5
is yeah I Prague you know he is such a
cool customer he loves to calculate his
way out of trouble and one thing I've
noticed is also he's the king of
counter-attacks he's the king of
sharpening the position just amping up
the drama and for me I would actually
skedaddle with the King to AJ's I'll be
like hey that's too much tension for me
um but I can actually see Prague making
a move like F5 like you pointed out I
can see him accelerating the play in
such a straightforward and very direct
manner
I mean F5 has the drawback of opening up
this diagonal so then you have to look
out just to put this on the board for
just one second if a queen lands on C4
is there a double check that you have to
watch out for we talked about Knight F4
as a possibility at some point but with
this pressure on F2 in the center and
the e-file opens up it could be bad news
for the white king and queen the same
line This is fire on board I know Alexi
shirov is not playing this game but it
feels like these two have are ready for
anything that happens in this one this
is fiery it is spicy and I'm loving the
start of this game between the two
youngsters
yeah I I agree and uh incidentally can
we just see what the evaluation bar uh
thinks if black were to play it slowly
because I am actually wondering whether
position is kind of already teetering on
the brink whether it's like desperate
times called for desperate measures but
if King h8 how is it is that still a
viable option
saying that white is better and I'm
guessing it's because the queen isn't
just Knight F4 your queen we can just
eliminate squares none of these squares
available to the black queen none of
these squares or the squareots are so at
least one process of elimination that's
the only safe square but I don't really
think you want to walk into the Bishop's
line of sight maybe just Knight D3 a
backwards Night Moves often the hardest
to find protecting F2 attacking this
bishop attacking this queen over here
yikes
yeah yeah definitely so gosh Prague is
already on the back foot and uh he has
to tread with the utmost of caution here
so good to know this is the benefit of
being commentators we can actually just
freestyle and take back moves it's very
very important
it really is and I think you know
process of elimination is sometimes how
we calculate in chess a king agent is
maybe the most natural move if I were
playing a bullet game Ivanka I think I'd
play King h8 like a in a second because
I want to get out of the Brooks line of
sight but it's not just Knight F6 check
the tactics that we were showing if this
Knight were to be kicked from G4 it's
Knight F4 this backwards move puts this
queen in big trouble so how do you deal
with both the threat of a knight F6 a
fork and the night version F4 we sell
them F5 as being an option and that one
looks very interesting I'm sure that
gukesh has more prepared in this uh
position because Knight F4 back still
looks viable the queen has to retreat
and I guess you have to F7 because Queen
C4 check is such a big threat with a
double attack but
I mean look at this it says even I I
don't know what to make of it
no I I mean it's just wild and there's
no other thing for it and uh you who who
you called it F5 on the board now as
soon as you mentioned it I was like this
is prac style he's uh not gonna go
calmly into the night here instead going
to just cause as much trouble as
possible
oh that one is uh shaping up very very
nicely and uh can we go back to the
bird's eye view because
I can see already some games have uh
decided to take more peaceful course of
action shall we say
and uh the first game that kind of
caught my eye in terms of peaceful was
the game between Abdus tariff and uh
ding Loren because it does look like the
vacuum cleaner is coming out and just
vacuuming all the pieces off the board
okay so let's go back to our leaders
game just because if you know we've
commentated a lot of Chess in our days
and I feel like if we're on the same
page here Ivanka we may be thinking no
dear Becky really does want to play the
safe he does not mind an early and quick
draw as long as that gives him a half
point in the standings we are getting to
that stage of the tournament where every
half point if you're ahead you may just
want to sail through to the finish line
so let's go back to where we left off it
was right around here he took on E8 he
did bring his Knight to D5 and the
bishop escaped the knights attack so
being the red says you're not getting
the two Bishops Advantage I'm going to
keep my Bishop on the board and after
these swaps C6 very important move you
don't want to leave this Knight in the
center and then black put the pawn D5 so
when I look at this position the first
word that comes to my mind is the word
you used
symmetrical and we often think oh is
that just going to lead to a draw
ER brexit is not so fast I'm going to
play C4 and at the very least if we
pause here even after blacks move white
has more activity Ivanka so do we
believe that notary wreck is playing for
a draw or do we think maybe he's just
playing for a simple position that if
dingley run makes a mistaken he can even
push for a win
yeah I I was uh considering that
actually after I said that the vacuum
cleaner came off because uh after D5 you
know it certainly looks that way
especially the first thing you have to
calculate is what's going to happen
after Pawn takes pawn and
there is going to be a set of
liquidation and the first move would be
Queen takes D5 it's the first thing to
look at and suddenly the queen goes
looking at F7 looking at B7 take your
pick which one do I grab and uh there
it's uh
not so easy to defend both Pawns in fact
it's impossible you have to give one
away
yeah and I think the one to give up of
course is the B7 pawn and in the event
of Bishop E6 I think Queen takes B7 is
viable and probably just good let's see
yes the Eva Bar says it does work what I
was going to say is even Queen takes d8
Rook takes d8 Bishop E6 Pawn takes E6
that's what people in the biz call
playing for two results if black defends
well it's gonna be a draw white has no
losing chances whatsoever it's all about
this isolated Pawn on E6 so white can
play for a win with precisely zero risk
and I feel like this is a dream position
for many players that chances are more
likely that England would make a draw
from here but still I do think that this
style of position is what no deerback
aimed for I mean he played a symmetrical
position against the Berlin defense this
is the maximum you could really hope for
uh stemming from that
yeah I I do agree so I I definitely
would not be capturing on D5 instead you
know I think black has to focus on
development and also keeping an eye on
the
D5 pawn it is after all potentially
passed
and can just plant itself on D6 at the
right time which would be so awkward
um so that's why I'm also looking at
moves like Knight D6
I'm just saying hey why why don't you
capture on C6 and after Bishop takes
born
I have great development as well
yovia I've been listening to you but at
the corner of my eye I just saw another
game that we have to go to because oh
okay let's go there the first and last
time we look at it the second from the
left Richard report and Lavon aronian
two very fighting players uh they're
playing checkers on the chessboard but
on different boards and in fact game the
game is over they drew this is done
their game is finished already
how long did that take
all of what in less than an hour
okay
wow
that felt like five minutes I'll be
honest with you you've been making time
go so quickly
I thought wow
hey they they say time flies when you're
having fun so you know that you I'm
having a blast I'm covering this with
you but this game what what is this is
animiasis where are the pieces they're
playing checkers on two different sets
you have all these pawns on light
squares all these pawns and dark squares
and no King can make any progress thou
shall not pass
yeah
wow
um
well what can I say this is like
I don't have any know how many times
that Levon has drawn but he's seems to
be upping the tempo when it comes to
agreeing the drawers and
and you know we have to also mention
that the organizers of Tata I mean they
say that drawers are not offering
drawers are not kind of like expressly
forbidden but it is frowned upon so it's
written in their Clauses that uh they
may not get invited back next year
because it's Lavon that's not gonna
whisper it but Lavon be careful
here's the dangerous territory
here the black pieces so usually if the
player with the first moves fault if we
get down at Josh line this but I don't
think anyone is going to disinvite
Richard report he had two decisive games
in a row uh he has played ferocious
chess but in this game I'm just gonna go
through the moves very quickly because
there's not much to analyze it looked
like the Abdul sitar of dingley Run game
but instead of this Knight hopping into
D5 very quickly it went D4 we see C3
very calm solid play the Knight drops
back so the pawn can go forward and this
game really had nothing to it because
it's symmetrical completely and we just
see all of the pieces traded that's what
happened this game the Knight comes back
to G7 it's the last little finesse
needed and then after this
more trades take on F6 quit Queens are
coming off in a second here they go yeah
and I've seen this end game before
actually uh Robert
um I have to say Magnus and um
Magnus and Wesley so they use this one a
lot in the first seasons of The
Champions chess tour to get that very
important draw
yes and just one thing to show for
offense if there is something to learn
even from the quickest of draws that if
you led with the Knight you think you're
winning in exchange but you're losing
the game because Knight F6 check is a
fork so if the king moves somewhere you
just take a rook thank you very much but
I will not move my king I will sacrifice
my queen on F6 The Rook is protected by
the Knight so if your queen takes you
simply lose your queen uh you'll be down
a queen for a rook and if you take the
queen that's a back rank Checkmate
that's what you get for making no left
for your king that would be a decisive
position in Black's favor so that's why
instead we saw the queen take first and
then this is a known draw as you said
you've seen it many many times and the
rest isn't even worth looking at a
couple moves they disagree on a draw
yeah and uh well
I I do think I agree with you Richard
was the one who kind of chose the
variation he set the pace with the white
pieces and yeah uh sadly
I I don't think it's any fault of live
on aronia you know it's just a
coincidence that he's
agreed a few door draws in a row now and
uh both these guys are such awesome
Players let's respect that
for sure and it is a long grueling
tournament they get a rest day tomorrow
uh we'll likely see more Fighting Chess
in the final three rounds from these two
but right now we still have six games
remaining uh the game between goo cash
and prognanda that's second from the
right and the bottom no moves have been
made since we last left off that could
be a bad sign for goo cash who may be
leaving his preparation and the top left
we already looked at the game between
abusa tarav and we will continue to do
so throughout the day
um but you've all got the top right the
game between Wesley so and Anish Geary
that's where we started the day and the
position has changed I mean it has
turned into a Catalan so unless another
game catches your eye uh I think we
should tune back into our player in
second place
yeah I agree
that's Heather and see what happened
because I immediately can see a bishop
parked on the E4 Square which is great
news because usually this bishop is
stuck there on C8 and it's often a
problem piece and you just
can't even dream about getting it out
now here is on Bishop E4 so unless
Wesley's starts just tickling Anish
making him uncomfortable then black will
certainly not be having any problems
no the position is such that currently
white has two Bishops two blacks couple
of knights so it's a two Bishops
quote-unquote Advantage at least that's
how it's often uh pronounced but in this
position this bishop on C3 is staring
into brick walls left and right that's
into its own Pawn which is a good Pawn
of course on D4 and A5 Pawn can't be
captured so just to remind everybody or
to let them know how we got here we left
off very early and it was a Catalan it
transposed very early castles D4 takes
and queen C2 Vladimir krumnik if you're
watching this uh you know you've taught
us so many lessons in this variation
thank you sir for all the great chess
you displayed throughout your
illustrious career come back play some
more chess yovia I'm not alone in this
right we want to see Vlad play more
chess come on over time
absolutely I mean in fact I would like
to see all of that gang come out of
retirement and play some jazz I would
love to see Judith come and play some
games because she is one of the world's
best attackers now I've had the pleasure
of commentating alongside her and she
it's just insane you know she manages to
destroy
any of the top players in her type of
position she can just beat them all and
I would love to see her back in the in
the arena as would I love to see kramnik
with his cheerful optimism
yes I mean a class between those two to
this day would be an epic one so uh
that's not going to happen right now
unfortunately but I hope somebody sends
them this clip so they will come out of
their respective retirements and this
one in East Gary play A6 A4 played so
then after Queen takes C4 there's no
immediate B5 and that's why anisha's
Bishop took a different path towards D7
and there is a ton of theory uh so many
different variations including the move
Knight to E5 and then when black plays
the move Knight C6 we often get a trade
that looks like this so Black's position
looks bad but you're currently up a pawn
and when white takes back the queen
quickly goes up to D5
study your Catalan Theory it's not my
job to teach it now in all seriousness
it's a very complex Rich position uh
where white tries to play for an
advantage because of the pawn structure
but also black has this open B file as
compensation so that is not in this game
it's a queen takes E4 so you'll be this
line that we saw where white Retreats
and black actually went Bishop B4 a
niche volunteered to give his Bishop on
C3 I feel like usually I see white take
on F6 not black take on C3
yeah I must admit I'm also
familiar with those Bishop takes F6 line
you know where white just gets a great
Pawn Center and then just says okay I'm
going to live happily with that space
and slowly push you back squeeze any air
you have and uh
no but we've seen a completely different
approach
yeah this is Bishop D2 and uh I really
like Bishop B4 and I also I really do
like the way that uh Anish has handled
it's very principled you know he says
okay I understand that's all about
taking that space in the center and
instead he says I am willing to give up
the bishop pair in order to park that
Bishop there on e4 and if you want to
establish your dream of getting e2e4 in
well then you have to concede something
you have to perhaps exchange light
Square Bishops or you just have to sit
there and live with my wonderful pieces
yeah because E4 not available because of
tactics always be on the lookout for
tactics here Bishop takes C3 first if
you take with the queen that Queen was
needed in the defense of the pawn now
thank you very much I'm upon my Bishop
defense and if you take with either of
Pawn or Bishop on C3 it doesn't matter
Knight C5 this is an easy tactic to miss
the queen is loose on D3 so you can't
take this Knight and drop the queen here
and if you don't take the Knight and
move your queen anywhere you have one
two three attackers not enough Defenders
black would scoop up a pawn in this
variation and that is why this strange
looking move I admit Queen C2 was played
just getting out of Harm's Way and then
we finally see the take on C3 and
planting that Bishop on e4 before it's
too late and after Queen D1 it is Anish
giri on the clock so uh yovi this
variation it's been
quite a ride thus far but Anish plays
the Catalan with the white pieces in
fact I played him in the rapid Chess
Championship and he beat me in a really
nice game from the white side of Catalan
so he has that experience from the white
side in addition to having from the
black side and that often gives people
very good Insight in how to defend when
they're saying this is the most
challenging way for me to uh for me to
face the most challenging line then it's
like well maybe I should try something
like that myself and taking control of
the center that feels like a good way to
go against a Catalan yeah definitely a
great way to go and I have to say I
really did like that featured chat where
someone managed to make a very great use
of anisha's name and make a pun he says
I can't wait to see a niche that has to
get initiate all these trains
oh very very clever uh our chat is very
smart good good one and uh no I agree
with you you know definitely uh playing
the opening with the white pieces really
will improve the way that you handle
yourself with the black pieces it makes
you very self-aware and makes you very
aware of what your opponent wants to do
and here I I feel that Anish is playing
the opening flawlessly
yes very solid position uh for black
right now but one thing you want to
avoid is unleashing the Bishops because
Bishop's Advantage they can only be used
as such with open diagonals open space
so move like C5 which is often tempting
you really need to consider what the
drawbacks are and that's opening up this
bishop on C3 which is currently not a
good piece so I will see how this game
continues we still have six games in
session because one has already finished
the one between report and everyone has
already been drawn so as we look at the
playing Hall so many people not just the
players and the Masters and the
Challenger sections but all of the
amateur sections this is a festival
after all so we see the playing all full
of life buzzing with chess energy and
while they get to it well they calculate
we'll go on a short break because when
returned there's much more action for
players like the one you see on screen
here Magnus Carlson and the rest of the
competitors in just a few moments
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you
[Music]
foreign
thank you
[Music]
foreign
thank you
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you
[Music]
and as you see the playing Hall in
Vikings a is packed so many chess
players taking part throughout the
entire day of the playing Hall it's a
festival after all and of course many
Spectators watching the Masters duke it
out for first place we still have six
games in session uh one game has been
drawn Richard report and Levon aronian
they split the point it was very
peaceful Affair uh we looked at that and
there was not much life in that game but
the other games Yogi we have some
excitement throughout in particular
second from the right and the bottom
cash and prognanda we already looked at
that variation but I'm so glad that we
have fireworks on the board
yeah and I'm gonna borrow Daniel's
expression he says it's gonna be a barn
burner and it sure is it's wild it looks
completely crazy so I can't wait to
catch up on those developments there and
okay
where do you think we should head to not
sort of a choice
yeah we have plenty of trees we haven't
looked at the game between Fabiano
caruana and Arjun eragasi so uh why
don't we tune into that one because Fabi
he did lose that important game against
Magnus Carlson but if he can take down
Arjun maybe he'll find himself back in
the thick of things towards the top of
the standings and well we it started as
a Spanish we are currently on move 17 or
at least black 17 move was just played
and Fabi as soon as I was about to start
talking with the position he says no
I'll talk about this A5 so you'll be the
I would say the highlight of the
position for me at the moment is Black's
worst Pawn structure you have two
isolated pawns here compared to just one
for white and this E5 Pawn is a target
whereas the D3 Pawn doesn't feel quite
as weak it's protected by the bishop and
his rook and Knight are teaming up on E5
so first thought white should be the
side for choice at least in my eyes what
do you make of it are you as optimistic
about fobby's position or do you think
that Arjun is kind of steady and solid
um solid is not a word I would use to
describe this one actually because the
pawn structure is something that does
worry me and something else that worries
me is um that's something I've been
taught about this particular e45
openings is that it all hinges on the
placing of this light Square bishop and
at the minute White's Bishop is on C2 I
don't think it's going to stay there for
long it can actually re-route itself to
B3 and maybe even Park itself on C4 and
start looking up at another weak Pawn
that black has the born on A6 and if
this bishop ties down the Rook I mean I
like to do basic maths Bishop wire 3
Rook five that's a gonna be a favorable
kind of not trade-off but a favorable
kind of posing of pieces
yes and the thing about this is if or
white certain Bishop B3 it blocks I'll
meet you on that diagonal Bishop E6 and
then you go let's go to the new diagonal
Bishop A4 with a pin of this Knight so
Black's Bishop is kind of countering
whites and where the black Bishop goes
white will choose the new diagonal that
seems very likely so this bishop is
going to zigzag its way to a useful
Square uh whether it's A4 or C4 at some
point and E5 long term Target A6 just
cemented in place thanks to this move A5
and Arden says I've had enough Rook B8
it's going to take you a bit of time to
get after this Pawn A6 let me use this
open file and white can't really do the
same this Rook on A1 tied down to the
defense of the A5 Pawn so that is the
downside you were just mentioning that
let's do some simple math the Knight on
C6 is a less valuable piece than the
Rook on A1 and this Brook this useful
heavy piece is now defensive it's tied
to the upon an A5 so moves that come to
mind for me I would like to play Rook to
B1 don't see the Merit in it just yet
maybe bishop A4 maybe let's take use of
the square that we just pushed our Pawn
away from and go for a better diagonal
yeah and I think I still think my idea
of going Bishop B3 is in operation
um also one move that they always do in
as white is to push the pawn and it's
very luxurious but I think white can
take the time up just go H3 get that
safety hole for the king and again ask
the question to Black what are you gonna
do and okay so I'm taking a look from
Black's Viewpoint because you have to be
flexible like that and
I kid you not I don't see a plan
I don't see a way to improve his pieces
and that's worrying I really
yeah I really like how you frame this
because uh you're just passing the turn
to black because if it were Black's turn
and you say what move will you make
maybe at some point Bishop G4 is a
consideration what else comes to mind
I'm really not sure Rook B5 that is
another idea that you often see with the
pieces the way they are but even that
takes a lot of time and if this night
were ever to be dislodged from C6 the E5
Pawn will be loose so Fabi goes for it
right away I did like the look of H3 but
I think he spot something more concrete
and actually I would have thought this
was Fabiano's preparation you'll be
it's Arjun who has way more time on the
clock so maybe this is his preparation
or in the general ballpark of that I
don't really like the look of his
position but maybe he just knows far
more than I do about this position and
he's going to find a way out
yeah he's playing almost instantaneously
I mean look at that the bishop moving
quickly to D6 I like that move it
consolidates the position especially the
center but
okay now I would play I have to admit
now I would play my
luxurious h2h3 again
what you gonna do when I come for you no
okay that's okay lyrics
hey come on sometimes you all gotta
imagine the bad boys out here and uh H3
looks looks like it's gonna make all of
them Black's weapons feel a little bad
because you're taking away an important
square and I think it's give and take at
this point and not just pop culture and
song references that are going on uh you
know Will Smith and
company can be happy that Yogi's made a
bad boy's reference uh on air but I do
think that it's all about the
maneuvering at this at this it's not
going to be some kind of checkmating
attack it's about creating threat after
threat and it's not going to be a
Checkmate thread it's not going to be
threat of winning material but just
saying where are the pieces going how do
you stop them from going to their best
squares and that's the dynamic of this
game
yeah I agree
um sadly it's bring in the long run and
I think we're going to see the action
start to happen uh give it five or six
moves shall we revisit the bird's eye
view and see if there's been any
developments elsewhere
okay so as we look across the screen
here it looks like the bottom right game
between Jordan Von forest and Vincent
kymer is still in theory so we're not
going to go there just yet but that just
looks like a you know kind of a Spanish
that is slowly moving uh the bottom left
game between Parham and Magnus that
looks quite interesting because we left
off in the opening and second from the
right and that's just the most
mesmerizing position we have gukesh and
pragnananda but look at the eval bar
there yovi the last move from gookesh
was Rook up to G2 maybe let's go into
that game as by the way Fabiano did play
the move H3 so you are the Fabi
Whisperer for the moment here and
gookesh and probably look at that chat
that was just made there by primey
saying double question mark for gookest
what is he doing his last move Rook G2
defending F2 I understand it but this
looks so wrong from an aesthetic
perspective is King on E1 still here
black is castled developed
what are we looking at
um it's
just looks like Carnage actually for
white I mean I understand kokesh he
wants to consolidate the Ft point and
then
I was gonna say castle
and if possible try to trade off Queens
but I mean even if you Castle it's still
looking
pretty shaky so the first things first
just because of the evaluation bar I
mean is there something radical so for
instance there's Pawn takes porn there's
still Knight takes porn Bishop takes
Pawn that's an option I'm just trying to
run through all those forcing moves you
can jump in with your knight to the
Santa the D4
what other
attractive moves are there Rook E8 is
something that I would again
probably immediately be considering this
anything to build
yeah all these are options here I'm
trying to uh figure out which of these
is best what is the threat is Knight G5
actually a threat that looks kind of
scary to my eye so if we make some
random move like A6 is Knight G5 a big
problem the answer is yes clearly it's a
problem because we're getting this queen
up to the C4 square and even if you keep
your queen on the diagonal so you don't
just lose your Bishop with queen of B3 I
still think you can play the move Queen
C4 check because just with the Queens
off the board doesn't end the attack and
Knight F7 check might force you to part
with this rook and white goes up in
exchange and perhaps there's even a sort
of mate at some moment down the H line
it just looks very very bad for black in
the evaluation Bar says the same that in
Bishop C3 let's go for this Pawn instead
kind of a devastating attack
yeah no you don't want to go into this
okay so either black has to take the
time out to defend against Knight G5 or
can he ignore it and have his
counter-attack
right so how do we deal with this threat
is the big question because the real
problem is Queen C4 wins this bishop on
C5 so it's a check that also checks the
bishop I can I kind of like your first
instinct just taking on e4 because
Knight G5 looks like a problem but the
F5 Square was vacated keeping the bishop
protected the F7 square is defended
enough time so Queen C4 is just one
check and once the king slides over
you have no more checks and a night's
coming to E5 very quickly
yeah
yeah and that's
that's uh almost game over
are we gonna
I was just gonna ask you are we gonna
see like a very Swift game I I just
think that this position is going
completely wrong for gookish he's the
one who played the surprise opening and
then his Rooks on G2 is Kings in the
center
it just looks really bad
well this is the danger right you play
with fire you're going to get burnt
right and uh I this is always My
Philosophy why I don't tend to start off
the game in such a risky Sharp Way is
because once you lose you lose big time
and we saw Fabi fall file to that
against Magnus Carlson I mean he went
all guns blazing he did not look after
his Center he gave black peas activity
and then when he when he fell he fell
badly and here I feel it's more of the
same so Pawn takes porn
I mean how can you answer that because
at the minute the White's position is
just creaking and if you have the nice
answer of Queen F5 to Knight G5
then
it's like I'm stuck
I'm having the same reaction as you
this this is often how we think when
we're playing chess is like
ah it's it's just horrible okay so I
mean is the so what white should do
really is back pedal but you can't
really back pedal because again it's
black to play and the position has now
accelerated is there any other move
other than Knight G5 I mean
maybe the show that Queen E4 is a simple
blunder because rookie eight will win
the queen pin a win down the e-line so
what else comes to mind besides that G5
and if you move your knight at the edge
of the board well that's just
sad scent I mean it just looks horrible
and uh for the very least that you've
got your knight E5 ideas
and the Knight D4 comes in I mean is he
still can he survive after Queen C
oh there is a cute line there let's see
if we can just play this if you make the
mistake I'm up a pawn let's trade Queens
after it takes the King goes to h8 and
we have a knight oh wait the bishop
defense I my cute line doesn't even work
because I forgot the bishop uh covers
the square I was like oh I'll get an
exchange up but the bishop simply does
move backwards I forget about that
sometimes I know
um and Magnus Carlson against the car
Nakamura in the speeches Championship
final I forgot that a night move
backwards here I forgot the bishop could
Retreat and then black is up material so
even this line that I was just playing
hope chest for doesn't work out for
gookesh it'll be I'm not believing this
at all I think that the bluff has been
called I think that prognanda responded
perfectly with that move F5 and he
decided to strike at the center while
giving his Queen access to retreat along
the diagonal and it's just bad news for
gookash and Rook G2 this just feels
wrong and I think that prognanda is the
type of player he has beaten Magnus
Carlsen in the Champions chess tour for
a reason it's because he does not fall
victim to psychological ploys he just
plays the position he has great
understanding and tactical awareness and
I think he is about to demonstrate that
with just the simple Fe and queen F5 I
do not even see how white challenges
this setup
yeah I agree and uh I mean you talked
about like pragnanda and his skill sets
and I have to say he trains with Ramesh
and he's been training with Ramesh since
he was a very very young child and the
kind of exercises they do I mean you
just have to read ramesh's calculation
manual to see that this is just bread
and butter to pregnant under I mean
he'll be thriving in this type of
position
he calculates so quickly so fast and
often with not that much time on the
clock I mean I've had many a top Grand
Masters say the thing about these Indian
kids is that they play insanely good
chess but just one second on the clock
one most mere mortals are just panicking
away not them and I agree porn takes
porn seems to be the way forward and it
makes a lot of sense you you accelerate
the play you open up the position open
lines to hunt down the king and the only
move you need to have an answer to Is
Knight G5 as you pointed out and Quint
F5 sufficient
looks sufficient to say the least and
you say playing with seconds on their
clock there was that one game where
probably had no time remaining because
he didn't have the moves written down
correctly it was a lost position so he
could forgive himself and if you win
this game we see his five out of nine he
jumps to six out of ten that would be a
huge performance he'd be Crossing 2700
for the first time I believe so that
would be a tremendous accomplishment to
do it against his compatriot fellow
Indian teenager uh that would be a
really a lifetime achievement and it's
only the start of his impressive career
so let's go back to our bird's eye view
to see our other five games that are in
session because a player who wants to do
damage today is in the top left that
game is looking like it's closer and
closer to fizzling out looks very level
but in the top right there's plenty of
life left there and a series of Trades
between Anish giri and Wesley so so I
think we should tune into that one
because these players they're duking it
out in a Catalan we last left off a few
moves prior to the live position and
just to show what happened the move B6
was played and then Knight E5 so
swapping pieces Knight takes D7 it's
kind of an intermeso if you will and now
it's a big choice yovi for a niche does
he bring his Bishop back somewhere and
play with like the opposite colored
Bishops and maybe an attack or does he
just take on D7 and say my knight is
every bit as good as your dark Square
Bishop this is a really critical choice
for Niche to determine if he's playing
for a win or if he's happy to just be
equal and make a draw
about in principle I think you would
love to keep the light Square Bishop on
the board I mean just look at it you
park it back on B7 it's going to be a
fantastic piece uh it does require a bit
of calculation because you have to work
out what's going to happen say for
instance often Knight takes night that's
a move to calculate if it's not a
problem then
just to park the bishop back but if it
is a problem then you'll have to go in
for capturing on D7 uh does it matter I
don't think it really matters right
which way to it which way the piece gets
captured I personally would step forward
with a queen and capture the Knight just
to connect the two Rooks
um
but aside from that
I I do feel that I mean take a look at
this dark Square Bishop I mean it's not
a great piece
not at all I mean you're just staring
into its own pawn and the position would
be level but after team takes you to
just to show what that looks like on the
board uh black also has an opportunity
to clamp the light squares the inherent
limitation of a bishop is it only moves
and the color is on that sounds obvious
and it is but it's important to remind
yourself of that because this Knight
could wreak havoc on the light squares
it's not going to E4 sure at some point
you can play F3 to kick it out but the
point is that this Knight can hop around
and maybe H3 at some moment could be an
issue so you just want to look at the
color complexes and the light squares in
particular here might be an issue for
white for the rest of the game that said
still solid the pawns are well
positioned for white but that's just the
kind of imbalance it's not a material
imbalance it's just a strategic
imbalance in this one
yeah definitely and both sides will have
different objectives one will be trying
to open up the position and the other
one trying to close it but going back to
the the bishop the position with
opposite color Bishops
um can we look at that one because that
one looks
like it could have quite a bit of poison
for
Wesley because after Knight takes Knight
Queen
I'm assuming that you don't damage your
king-size Pawn structure you go here
and here it does feel like the white
king is slightly shaky and again British
understatement hopefully with time
you'll get used to this
oh I'm already accustomed to it because
uh shaky is a very kind way of putting
it if this queen could move like a
knight for a turn better watch out this
diagonal is a problem but white does
have the resource to make the move F3 at
some point I mean it doesn't look
Pleasant uh you can also play E4 and the
position is no risk for black so I'm
actually a bit surprised that Anish is
spending time right now because Queen
takes D7 yeah it's fine for black but
retreating the bishop as we're talking
about here just looks so pleasant where
this Pawn is on the light Square
blocking this great Bishop here at some
point you can even play the move F5 once
your queen moves out the way and if you
can line your queen and Bishop in a
battery there could be checkmating
threats that white will have to look out
for so I don't think Anish has anything
to worry about Yogi he's played this
started the game very well and well in
general uh this matchup between these
two we heard anisha's interview where he
was saying how you know it had some
decisive results and by the way he did
take on December the queen I'm surprised
by that uh but uh he does lead their
head-to-head Series in Viking Z and
overall it's a tight score between them
but Anish seems to do well in Vikings
against anybody
yeah he he he really seems to be riding
high and vike you know certain players
have a certain tournaments which they
consider their favorites where they just
always do well and uh vike is one of
those for a niche you know five time
runner-up and uh he did tell me once
that um one of the great things about
playing vike is that uh the organizers
of Tata steel they make a tremendous
effort with their press releases they
send it out to all the national
newspapers and as a result of that for
two weeks
the whole of the Netherlands as well as
the chess Community just go chess crazy
and Anish just seems to thrive on this
attention he really really does well
knowing that the whole of the
Netherlands is behind him and supporting
him
and he's defeated world number one
Magnus Carlson and number two dingley
Wren in this tournament a huge win over
dingley red that was a topsy-turvy game
yesterday's action was just crazy and so
if a niche can keep it going maybe he
will win his first Tata steel event he's
been the runner-up on five different
occasions but this tournament does seem
to bring out the best in him he's
gaining rating points this year he seems
to gain rating points every single year
he plays and this matchup between these
two in particular they are very solid
players they don't like to take a lot of
risk Anish was forced into that
yesterday because of the opening choice
and that G4 Push by dingly Ren but
Wesley he's not doing the same we see
the game developing we might just see
all the pieces come off and it's just
going to be liquidation and there's
nothing to complain about if you're a
niche he is playing a fantastic
tournament Yogi I am really impressed
he's being overshadowed a little bit by
Nordic which all credit to the Uzbek
teenager who is shining on the
international stage but for Anish giri I
mean the guy what more could he do
that's the question I have is what more
can he do in this event to impress the
many fans he has some of the detractors
out there some critics saying get off
Twitter play uh chess he's playing great
chess he can keep being on Twitter his
social media presence is awesome his
chess game is phenomenal and just have
the feeling that this could be his year
Yogi I mean I'm not calling it but just
the way he is playing it's sparkling
chess
yeah I mean it certainly is it's very
very impressive I really like the
preparation that he's done with the
white pieces you know he's putting the
heat on super early I mean we saw so
many games like for instance he took on
aragaisy and it seemed quite unfortunate
that he didn't win that he you know and
you ask what more can he do he do he did
defeat Magnus Carlson with the white
pieces he did defeat Ting world number
two 2800 with the black pieces yesterday
and you know here's a tremendous score I
mean it it does feel like we're asking a
bit much for him to do even better but
it would be nice to actually see him
there chase down abdusa toroff and I I
don't know I just feel that vike has
been such an intense amazing tournament
so far what would be more befitting than
have this mad scramble towards the end
for the top spot
for sure there is a home field advantage
but there's also pressure from playing
in your home country as you noted all of
the Netherlands has their eyes on this
event and while we will come back to
this game the game between
I don't think we're going to be too
surprised yovi that uh this game looks
very level from the start of this atar
of taking the Richard report path of
symmetrical position against the Berlin
and the last one played was King F1 so
that move is surprising with so many
pieces on the board of a queen H2 even
if the queen gets to H1 that's just a
single check but I know I at first
glance nervous about this right and
unfunny police saying that Abdul sitar
has been the most entertaining in the
tournament and they don't mind if a
booster draws yeah sometimes with the
playing dingly Ren you're just like
let's just let's be solid here uh but
that last move I I just at first glance
Queen H2 looks a little bit scary but
there's probably nothing there
yeah I agree I don't think there's
anything there as long as you have a
kind of control over where the king is
going
and in this particular case the king can
go to
E2 because I mean first of all you're
going to initiate some trades I think
this is his whole point after Queen H2
you initiate the trade of Bishops so
that the king can hide out on E2 if need
be and uh look who he has for company
you know it's something I actually
learned within the last two years that a
knight is a king's best friend you know
and it sounds really corny but it's true
and it's something to pay attention to
because there the king is completely
Untouchable and we see norda back there
in the camera just doing his trademark
stir you know looking at ding saying
what you got and I I actually agree with
the comments that we've had from chat
that
not about you know he played a six
was it six hours and 45 minute game and
it required every
ounce of skill and resource and there we
see the players repeat the moves this
would be the most unorthodox three move
repetition I've ever seen in my life
involving the king and a bishop
I think it's gonna happen because
dingerman just looked up at him I saw
that glance over it nobody back and he's
like are you thinking what I'm thinking
players are looking at a draw they're
going to retreat repeat excuse me with
Bishop B5 King G1 and back and forth we
go and if this game is a draw that means
that no dear Beck is going to at the
very least be tied for first place if
Anish Gary wins his game but very likely
that he will keep his distance from the
pack he will almost certainly it seems
end up with a lead after 10 Rounds what
more could you ask for if you are this
Uzbek Legend he's not just a talent he's
not just a promising junior he is
already a legend he has cemented his
place in chess history he's won a World
rapid Championship the youngest player
to ever do that he let his country it
was an upset Uzbekistan wins the
Olympiad gold medal and right now he
leads vikon Zay he is going to repeat
moves King G1 and and when will we see
the handshake the only question left
and uh
ding
taking a pause
you know I have to say one of my
favorite things is when players repeat
three times and they look at each other
and it's just that second of recognition
that the game is over there's relief all
round and
is it gonna happen
dingly red is kind of like
oh fine I'll make this draw I would love
to be combative I'd love to score
Victory but this has not been his
tournament and with the black pieces you
only have so much Choice when nobody
back wants to make a draw so this is a
great camera angle by the way by the way
loving this yeah I know we see we see it
from the pen perspective writing down
the moves and for dingley right I really
believe that he's just thinking why
couldn't I get a different type of
position today why does this have to be
a four-straw uh couldn't I get some kind
of unique position to try to outplay my
opponent and the answer is a resounding
no and he looks disappointed I think
that's more about the tournament than
about this game but in just a few
moments now I think we are going to see
handshakes and a drop
yeah he's
yeah it looks like Deng is accepting the
inevitable that this position is uh too
drawish for him to try to squeeze out a
win and uh yeah like you say you know
you could see the frown you could see
the emotion from ding this has not been
the tournament for him nothing has been
clicking
and there we go
it's going to tell in order back that
I'm going to be a bishop of C6 and draw
agreed wow drug read it is a draw let's
see if the players you know communicate
and analyze the game uh so actually we
can listen in and see if we can hear
their thoughts
well it looks like unfortunately we have
no analysis maybe there wasn't much to
analyze I rate that we have audio uh
from the playing Hall but all we heard
were pieces being put back on the board
there yovi uh these two players not
looking to go over that game
no and uh I mean so be it you know the
players are fully entitled to actually
say no and actually just
go back to their rooms just rest and
incidentally talking about analyzing
their games I mean I found out later
that Magnus Carlson and kukash they
analyzed their game yesterday for 50
minutes that's like just under an hour
all right that's just incredible
and uh it's a it's a fantastic interview
actually that Fiona does if you
understand Tony uh who does with uh good
cash and what I really absolutely adored
about that interview was how gukesh just
seemed so kind of shocked afterwards you
know he just seemed completely shattered
like he'd use up every single ounce of
mental energy to play the game then
analyze it with Magnus and I recognize
that emotion you know
yeah no emotion uh you know Tesla is
supposed to be objective they're
supposed to just think about the
position uh but as we see Magnus Carlson
on screen there you know he is fully
focused he wants Victory we heard him
say in previous interviews that while
the play hasn't been great he finally
feels like he's getting his form and so
as we see here in this game uh the
bishop was on G4 that's where we left
off not two moves have been too many
moves excuse me have been played to get
here and we see a comments named Magnus
is playing some top shelf Chess at the
moment a bishop G4 the queen did go out
but all the way to A4 with check so that
was an interesting choice by Parham
maybe he was worried about these Knight
C6 Knight B4 lines but he gives a check
and after C6 he just develops he says
why don't I bring my Bishop out and look
at this move yovi Queen C2 I think the
intention is clear that he wants G4 and
his Queen and Bishop line up on the G6
where that could net weight upon if
black is not careful
yeah and this goes back to the points
that we made earlier on if you do allow
the light Square Bishop outside the pawn
chain out in activity into into Freedom
you do need to get something in return
and I really like what param has done
you know now he's threatening G4 it's
something that the world champion has to
consider and he's now been considering
it for quite a long time and the first
thing that I would think about is okay
White's King is in the center
accelerate the play G4 is coming let's
just play C5 or Knight D7 C5 give up the
pawn just accept that it's gone and uh
let's see what happens actually C5 I
really like because if you do go G4 well
you've always got to work out what
happens on the counter attack whether
first of all ponte's pawn or whether you
go C4 yourself
it's a great question and just to finish
off this variation of how white wins the
pawn it's all the way out here on G6
that's why the queen and Bishop were on
the same diagonal so you can play Queen
takes G6 but we see the evaluation bar
not reacting so much in White's favor
and the reason why is there's a king
that's in the open and even if you get
it out of the center you're walking into
other problems on the queen side so
sometimes these positions are ones where
the player grabs a pawn and says prove
that you will find every correct move to
keep the balance but I do believe this
is a position that's easier for black to
play let's say we just make normal moves
like Knight C6 attacking the pawn the
center and if you decide to Castle Queen
side I feel like you're gonna get
yourself in huge trouble there's
pressure everywhere there's pressure
down the f file because it's going to be
pressure down the C file
um even a move like B5 giving another
Pawn is perfectly reasonable here take
me please take my Pawn on B5 because now
I have many different options including
the very straightforward Rook B8 Queen
coming out to B6 or A5 you'll be the
attack kind of plays itself in a
position like this who cares about that
pawn that was on G6
yeah I was gonna say that uh absolutely
do not go into this line it's not worth
the pawn it's not worth the trouble uh
this is the kind of way that higher
rated players beat lower rated players
just left right in the center I mean
don't go for it I mean just take a look
at the activity of Black's pieces in
that end position I mean it's too too
much and of course you've always got to
consider King a safety so if I have a
pyram I I often moves like C5 I would
just switch I would say okay
don't get greedy don't go for material
just switch to a positional kind of
viewpoint just go okay maybe Pawn takes
porn give like the isolated Queen's pawn
and then say Okay a major look made you
stare but I wasn't actually gonna go
with my king to the queen side I'm
actually just going to develop normally
put my note on E2 and then Castle
outside I I I really do love that
because uh so many players they get lost
in their previous thoughts they're
thinking I was going for this I put my
queen on C2 so I could play G4 and win
the pawn so if black put A6 for example
now we see the eval bar go up because
after G4 Bishop G6 because black isn't
striking quickly in the center white has
the time to steal that pawn and then
protect the remaining bases so if the
move C5 is played going after White's
Center instead of A6 now we think all
right we have some pressure this
Knight's coming out to C6 black is
rapidly developing and attacking putting
pressure on my weak points if I just
take on C5 and black takes back with the
bishop here already we see this is a
problem because the isolated Pawn a
Pawn's best friend is another Pawn that
previously was a Pawn on C6 keeping
everything defended but once this
happens over here after Bishop takes F6
I'm already removing the guard you do
not want to take with your g-pawn that's
out of the a question after Queen takes
thank you very much for your nice
Central Pawn white would be upon ahead
in the best way possible so Yogi I'm
with you I think that C5 looks great but
then parm just has to respond
strategically rather than tactically and
you know as we think about magnus's
standing right he has won a couple games
after a rough stretch in rounds four and
five so he is now at a plus score three
wins four draws and two losses this game
is important because if we look at his
final three games after this round he
gets the white pieces twice in a row
before finishing the tournament black
against Arjun eragisi so if he can win
this Yobe and get double whites he
really does find himself in Striking
Distance of the leaders
yeah I mean Magnus said it himself you
know he has five winnable games he's not
thinking about winning the tournaments
he's just uh just chunking the task into
small parts and uh just playing it on a
almost game by game basis almost Moment
by moment you know he's kind of one of
the common themes that we've seen in his
interviews is that he says well you know
I'm just going to start in my own way
and if you're ready for a fight game on
I feel confident about my chances and we
see the exact same approach here it just
says okay do you want to take the game
into complications and now it's up to
Parham to kind of agree or disagree and
uh yeah I agree
so many possibilities and we mustn't
forget that Magnus Carlson he's like the
king of comebacks he just levels up in
these closing rounds I mean we've seen
it so many times you know people have
written him off and then oh look at that
Magnus Carlsen has won three four games
in a row
just part of the work for him
um there was one thing that I just
spotted an idea that I just wanted to
kind of mention there is one big danger
for uh Magnus and it perhaps isn't
necessarily relevant in this position
but it's a very common idea that you
should know about and it works like this
that uh White could on occasion actually
make the move F2 F4
and the whole idea is basically to lock
the light Square Bishop out of the game
so you then you play F5 G4
you just get G4 and F5 and then you say
okay look at that piece
it's uh not having a great future is it
no not at all and white essentially
plays up a piece uh if that Bishop is
locked out that's a long-term issue that
black will have to resolve so uh it's
another great idea you see in a variety
of positions when you go for the attack
is if you can thrust those pawns forward
and black is not looking out for it uh
then that's an issue but we know based
on your earlier recommendation that as
soon as white Dilly Dally's for just
that one moment too long black is going
to quickly strike in the center uh with
a move like C5 so it's all about making
it work getting it on time
um another move that makes some sense to
me is trying to trade these Bishops with
a move like Knight to E8 that's commonly
seen in a position like this because if
we trade pieces here and go for G4 uh
once again I don't think I am deathly
afraid of this Pawn sacrifice if I'm
thinking about From magnus's perspective
because in return for the pawn I get
very quick play the king can't Castle
Queen side because it needs to keep the
F2 Pawn defense ended I feel like this
is biting off more than you can chew it
and actually I'm seeing the eval bar
saying I'm wrong
um and the evil is saying okay all of a
sudden it's favorable for white but you
need to be 100 sure if you're par Hong
because there's no going back from here
there already are threats uh with the
queen and the rook and the Knight
joining the party that black can take
over the initiative momentum so you need
to find the accurate continuation
yeah absolutely uh I agree there's
danger for both sides a very interesting
strategical battle
foreign
Magnus to figure out his position let's
quickly take a peek at the bird's eye
view it seems like in the top right
Anish Geary has traded pieces and pushed
his Pawn up to C5 that one is
sort of fizzling out not that there was
any real heat to it to begin with but it
does seem like on the top right
nishikiri Wesley so likely draw but the
other games still are fascinating we
haven't even looked at Jordan Von Forest
against visit chymer so after this short
break we are going to come back and look
at all of the remaining action but look
at how jam-packed the tournament Hall is
so many participants in this chess
Festival not just the Masters that you
see on screen in front of you but many
players of all levels taking part so
we'll leave the players to it we'll be
right back for more in the 10th round of
the Tata steel Chess Masters in Vikings
[Music]
he's gonna win the tournament
this is going to be a turnaround whoa
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
Hall bustling with quiet chess fans
because tournament Halls leave the
players full room to think to calculate
no distractions and two players that uh
excuse me two games that have already
been decided for players have drawn
their games in round 10. they are no
longer in the playing Hall that those
players are no dear back Abu sitarov and
dingley ren they made one draw and
Richard report and Levon aronian they
also finished their game they were the
quickest game to finish
yeah and there we can see the crowd it's
so wonderful to have a chess Festival
back in town and absolutely everyone
just playing and enjoying the game and
uh there we can see today's big matchups
and uh top of the table is Wesley so
against Anish giri that is such a big
lineup because we have a number two
pacing number three and uh other big
results as our other big matchups of
course is Magnus Carlson with the back
pieces trying to make Headway against
para maxulu and it fighting fighting arm
in a fighting fighting mood
yes and for sure and in the top right
I'm looking at Wesley so and Anish Geary
that position looks like we're heading
towards an end game if the Queens get
traded I'm not sure any side can make
progress and the one between gukash and
prognanda I don't know what's gonna
happen in that game is it hard to
predict moves about Prague Nanda
centralizes his Queen the second from
the right on the bottom there uh five on
a carwana and Arjuna gaisy looks like
not too much has happened in that one
looks like Fabian was kind of gone back
and forth and well we haven't looked at
Jordan Von forest and Vincent Commerce
so what do you say we do those player as
a solid and pull up their game just
because it was a Spanish it was familiar
territory but now we're in a position
where the players they're on their own
yeah they are on their own and it's a
very open position and uh once again uh
black has a reasonable position but his
Pawn structure especially the weak Pawn
on D6 catches my eye I mean that's it
will tie down the dark Square Bishop but
other than that you know he has some
free pieces I mean his Knights can hop
in he has good control of the E5 Square
and of course most obvious point in the
position is that black Rook is
threatening to capture the bishop on B2
so something needs to be done there I
would guess that white simply steps up
the bishop one square and says okay your
move you start making some progress
yes the bishop should just step up the
C3 as you're indicating and if you trade
Knights on D4 thinking let's just swap
off pieces uh the problem is this D6
bomb is clearly the weakest so that's
not what you'd like to see when you are
playing this position is an isolated
Pawn it's not going anywhere because if
you try to push it up then white can
push forward with E5 and you don't also
don't mind opening up the position
because as the position opens the bishop
on C2 gets very powerful aiming towards
the black king and the bishop on D4
already situated on the nice diagonal so
this capture happened on C6 by the way
uh Bishop takes C6 is forced I wonder
what Jordan's follow-up is it could just
be to bring the bishop up to C3
afterwards and sitting on this bad Pawn
Joey that seems to be the storyline of
this game the D6 Pawn is the worst piece
on the board
yeah I I agree and uh well also the
consequence of capturing on C6 could
also be that the bishop steps up to D4
and upon which I can almost see
something very similar to Fabiano's
approach where you just then go A5 Hawk
the bishop on B6 and then use this
Square in order to gain control over the
B line
um definitely this is very very tense
game the position is completely open
it's going to be all about who Maneuvers
puts their pieces on the best squares
and uh
I I it's going to be very critical now
for Vincent because if Vincent doesn't
manage the way manage to find a way to
neutralize the bishop pair the white has
then he will be in big trouble
and this is the live position so he
needs to figure out a plan so how do you
neutralize this strong Bishop on D4 Rook
B4 is not going to be correct while you
attack the bishop where it sits it
simply slides back and your Rook will
have to run back to where it came from
so Rook B4 is not a way to kick it out
um Rook E8 comes to mind candidate move
some move like Queen D or C7 comes to
mind I just don't feel like I have a
good grasp of this position Ivanka if
I'm being honest with myself and with
everybody it just feels hard for black
to make individual moves because I don't
see a clear plan
I mean is it possible
um that the Knight can step back to D7
you know you take a step back to go
forwards the whole idea is to actually
challenge it with Bishop F6 or to put
the Knight on E5
and uh try to jam up the center that way
yeah that looks like a very good uh plan
for black because the bishop 24 is so
strong an idea that's not out of the
question is a potential Rook lift at
some point I'm not sure I have the time
to do it but if you had not brought your
knight back to D7 then I would have
brought my Rook into the party but if I
bring my Rook up to A3 you can then
challenge the bishop with Bishop F6 and
still likely a good Rook lift to do but
I don't know if I'm accomplishing all
that much and so that
takes away the sting from that
yeah and what one of the things I like
about the Knight going to D7 is that yes
I kind of mentioned it going to Knight
E5 but it can also jump to C5 as well
once the dark Square Bishops have been
traded off
um yeah it's a tricky position for kymer
I do feel that his next few moves have
to be very insightful has to be with
purpose either play against the E4 Pawn
because as Robert's kind of indicated
that the white Rook is swinging up I
hadn't even seen this move but gay three
over to G3 and goodness me that looks
scary
um
yeah
go to do something now neutralize
neutralize
to name the game
although with the night coming to C5
your idea the night can then swing back
to E6 which would attacks and defend in
fact the East E6 squares a perfect place
for the Black Knight you'd feel much
more comfortable in terms of King safety
with the Knight over there so I like
your plan Knight D7 I think it just
gives black more options and that's what
you're lacking in the starting position
if we just put the Knight on F6 for a
second back where it came from and if
you play D5 we know that we're going to
be met with an E5 push it doesn't look
very fun
uh to open up this bishop on C2 so I
feel like uh we want to play D5 on one
hand because we have an isolated Pawn
that we want to get rid of but we know
that White's not going to take it and
then it gives quite an attack so I'm
I really like Jordan's position I feel
like he has achieved a stable advantage
and we have Vincent on screen there he's
had a tough go of it in this tournament
he almost took down the leader noted
record of yesterday but almost doesn't
quite do it he did not win that game and
he is struggling against a really tough
field the strongest Vikings a tournament
of all time
yeah I have to say I I feel like you
know we talk about people being lucky
and other people being unlucky and
Vincent has struck me as being unlucky
in this tournament is just nothing is
working well for him for instance you
know he was doing okay against Lavon he
was holding holding then he cracked and
lost exactly the same story against
Wesley so and then we kind of fast
forward to the times when he was winning
you know he played ding he had a great
position out of the opening a great
middle game was completely winning but
somehow he didn't manage to punch
through same situation when it came to
nordeback I mean what are the chances
that you find yourself in a rook
important ending where your two pawns
two connected past pawns up I mean nine
times out of ten in fact nine and a half
times out of ten it's just a
straightforward win you can even play it
with your eyes closed it's that good but
that Nordic found himself in that hard
half time out of 10 where it was a draw
yes what a hold that was and for Vincent
it's just a very strong tournament and
he is a strong player he is gaining
experience in the moment that
consolation prize you know seems like
you're just saying it right it's like oh
come on I lost my games I'm not happy
what do you who cares about experience
it was a bad experience but he is a
young player he is a super talented
player and you're going to have to go
through the top players and this is a
good first for Ray into such an Elite
field in Vikings a masters group and
they're the best has is yet to come from
him just like the other teenagers so it
would be nice for him to finish this
tournament on a good note that's really
what he's looking for at this point but
for Jordan Von Forrest a former champion
of this event the lowest rated player in
the field he's got three and a half of
nine if he can win this game he's
actually plus rating points on the
tournament and it goes from having a bad
start to potentially really good event
so we'll come back to this and just
inconclusive said the same thing time
will change for Vincent he's collecting
experiences but if we go back to our
view of the other games I want to
quickly note two things that have
happened
Yogi in the top right Anish Geary and
Wesley so seems like that game is really
petering out
yeah I have to say that and the game
that really catches my eye there's two
that look like they are just Fast and
Furious I mean para against Magnus
Carlson because the position has opened
up someone has lit that spark and
suddenly the whole position is
completely a flame
wow yes this Magnus game is oh you don't
even know what to call it is for I don't
have enough adjectives in my vocabulary
there's a king on E1 there's a queen on
E6 so if I pin the queen I win the queen
ah rookie seven doesn't work because the
Rook is actually pinned first so Knight
F3 takes advantage of the fact that the
Rook is pin let's just go back uh
because we were even analyzing this
position we saw that C5 had been played
by Magnus uh your suggestion great
choice uh parm did not take on C5 but
when G4 right away perhaps after dc5 he
was worried about this move d4 where the
queen gets active if you take and now
there's all sorts of variations to
calculate with the King still in the
center so he chooses to play G4 we see
the swap Bishop G6 takes and Magnus
plays Knight takes G4 we did not talk
about this move we didn't expect it but
what a shot it is the Bishops are
staring at each other uh so if you take
the Knight you lose the bishop and if
you take the bishop the queen takes back
with check and that's devastating
because the rook and the Knight team up
in the F2 Pawn as well
yeah
but uh it is certainly a move that
really is absolutely crazy because I
could just see that he's going to
capture it right he is going to go Pawn
takes Knight and lines have been opened
okay he's throws in check first and uh
here's the consequence of actually
taking that particular Pawn because
after Bishop takes bishop and uh we see
Haram develop the Knight to F3
and you know swings and roundabouts as
we like to say yes black didn't actually
sacrifice at porn but on the other hand
take a look at that Rook on H1 it's
working like it was never working before
and of course there are some big threats
on the board uh Knight takes Bishop in
the air and more obvious Knights E5
winning black Rook so
two threats for Magnus to deal with I
don't know what he's thinking about
because I think I would probably just
put the bishop on F6
as quickly as I could but I guess
consequences again is G5 gonna be a move
let's show that Bishops is G5 is your
suggestion because if you take with the
bishop then the E5 Square no longer
covered thank you very much for the
material The Rook is pinned and now it's
going to be lost and if you take with
the pawn I think your plan is very
straightforward let me go and Checkmate
this black king you can even throw on
Queen side casting first if you're
afraid of some check along e-file but
the Rook on H1 as you said uh you know
it's a kind of a Maniac on the floor
here and it's just open H file developed
in its starting position that is really
just a Crusher so uh maybe what magnets
to think about is one the consequence of
G5 if he is the Play Bishop of six and
also Queen E7 is a viable option because
if you take the Rook takes back with
check giving you enough time to retreat
the bishop the downside of ever putting
your queen on E7 is even if the Queens
get traded the D5 Pawn is loose so Queen
E7 it gets the Queens off but it gives
white the D5 Pawn like with a tempo
not an easy call right now for Magnus
Carlson he is ahead in the clock but
he's a hard move to make and he makes
Queen oh look at that that's
you know one of the many reasons he's
the world champion I only saw Queen E7
forcing the Queens off he says this also
gets the job done because if you trade
the bishop gets to a better Square on F6
then it would be sitting on esep
yeah absolutely you know the world
champion is a Class Act but uh even then
there's still stuff to be calculated
because there's nothing for Parham to
play other than
I'm just having a quick look at the
checks no but they are not working
and after Queen tastes yeah and then the
root goes to
and queen taste Queen
and then the bishop will obviously
capture that piece and then the thing
that
yes you've read my mind you're hovering
over the night take that pawn please
let's get some compensation for you know
this open position and this inferior
minor piece I have
I I guess the reason why black is still
keeping the game balance is Knight C6
goes after the D4 pawn and if you remove
the attacker after Rook takes now your
knight is loose this Rook is swinging
over and honestly it's a position that
see the Evo bar dropping I was going to
say that black could get the upper
handed and if you start by castling
Queen side to defend this Pawn even a
move like Rook d8 I'm attacking your
knight If It Moves you drop the pawn on
D4 directly and if you take once again
Rook takes F6 and there's a problem down
the F line This is a situation where uh
para maksudu will start up a pawn but he
will likely drop that extra pawn and
with it there are so many problems in
the position a lot of his pawns are weak
because when you push your pawns forward
they're in danger of becoming over
extended so we will see Queen trade very
likely we'll see what a Parham follows
up with but the game between Wesley so
annanese Geary you'll be we're not
surprised at all I don't think by the
fact that it looks like we are heading
towards another draw Wesley I just
pushed his Pawn up to H4 in the top
right we'll bring the game up on screen
here but this looks like a game where
two Rooks four pods per side zero
worries for either player
and uh
I was just it was a niche just like
starring down Wesley saying it's a draw
mate is he is he drinking a Yoo-hoo
is that chocolate isn't it one of those
yeah chocolate milk right it's uh like a
Kokomo right they have this special
brand in
Holland shokomo oh sorry I I my
apologies to all Dutch people
nobody else could hear the producer no
you're correcting our pronunciation
there I'm just gonna pretend it's a
Yoo-hoo because it gives me you know
flashbacks it'll be big daddy uh but no
it's a shokomel and Niche giri he's
hovering over his Pawn he doesn't want
to blunder so he's thinking is the move
H5 yes he finally plays it he wants to
make sure his Pawn is safe and sound
over there and that's the thing is you
don't want to take it for granted that
you'll make the draw he knows it Wesley
knows it this game is very even and I am
the biggest critic of draw offers I
really am against them I think positions
should be played out to a point where
they're easy to explain to an audience
so that they're not left scratching
their head being like sorry why did this
game end there's all these pieces on the
board this one is easier to uh tell the
what's going on The Rook on E5 it covers
everything the A5 Pawn the HR Pawn if
the Rook on A4 ever moves then you let
this a pawn Rumble up the board so this
Rook is perfectly placed Rook on E5 is
staying put the draw is agreed these
players split the point and each Gary at
least uh stays behind no tobacco booster
by half point and Wesley so he stays a
full point behind abusatara and he's
just got nothing going over he never had
a chance in this game to score more than
that half point
yeah it did seem like a niche actually
got some great preparation in he got the
position that I think was actually
slightly better for black and a niche
actually traded down into this very
level end game and uh this position
completely drawn I mean both sides will
just be maintaining the balance as
Robert indicated and a fair result
indeed and there we can see the players
analyzing And discussing
well continuation they could have played
I mean one thing that I was curious
about you know whether they would be
discussing a niche actually capturing
the Knight with his Queen rather than
retreating the light Square Bishop
that's definitely what they're talking
about actually I saw a point of the D7
Square I mean maybe it's my uh Vision
being bad I do wear glasses but I
thought that they're pointing to the D7
and B7 squares so that moment was
critical uh and look at this the Arbiter
is like come on guys you know what to do
please go analyze your game elsewhere
but we should uh you know after looking
at our four mini games we should pull up
the announcement very quickly uh from
this game because the critical moment
that Anish Geary if he looks back on
this tournament it says Where could I
have had more winning chances was after
white took on D7 uh the reason why white
took on D7 rather than G2 just to show
quickly is that sometimes you do not
want these double pawns and this is an
example that it's a bishop that's on the
dark squares never seeing a good
diagonal so the Knight took on D7 and
yovi we were sure that we were going to
see Bishop B7 but Anish Geary he kind of
surprised Us by Taking Back a D7 rather
than retreating all the way
and I like what brand has Simpson says
Grandpa Simpson of course Arbiter
ordering them to Dueling outside
yeah
officers have to do their job you know
they have to tell you to shh and leave
the paying Hall and uh there I agree
completely critical moment if white if
black sorry black was gonna claim to be
just that touch better it was in this
point but I have to say excellent
preparation from Anish Anish seemed to
have correctly predicted exactly how
Wesley was going to open and he
determined exactly the type of position
he needed to get
yes he had no problems whatsoever he
could have played for more by retreating
the bishop uh but he probably thought
this position also uh was dynamically
equal even though the evil Bar says
better for black it's not that you know
there the result is in the book so with
that draw agreed we still have a few
games remaining and the most interesting
one for sure is the one between gukesh
and prognanda we haven't tuned in on
that game uh for a while a lot has
changed Jovi I think we might have to
just jump right in uh because the white
king second from the right on the bottom
row there the white king is jumped out
of the center and look at the Evo bar
after probably last move it is going up
up and not quite away from him yet but
it is clear that gukesh has the upper
hand if he finds the best moves right
now
yeah I was gonna say because we left it
and actually it was a very critical
moment for good cash I mean it just
didn't look like his position was going
to survive but we saw that Prague did
not actually capture that pawn in the
middle of the board that seems to be the
critical critical moment and instead
moved his Queen to E7 just moving itself
away from the outline of fire and I
think this was just one tempo too much
because this allows kukash simply to
develop his King and just to get his
pieces into the right squares
pretty amazing he jettison's a pawn with
E5 which is engine approved by the way
the Knight takes an E5 and this is
likely why pregnant said all right this
looks good for me I'm winning upon the
center of the board but gukash he is a
man on a mission I mean he's a teenager
but he is going full steam ahead he
wants that attack he's going to bring a
bishop to C3 his Rook on G2 is going to
perfectly situated to kick his Knight
out with H3 his Bishop will try to land
on C4 all of White's pieces have squares
that they are going to go for and
Grandpa Simpson back again in the chat
this might be a statement game from
gookash he took risk out of the opening
program did not
except that pawn E4 and now that we're
here after Bishop to D6 uh and it's
White's turn the simple move H3 looks
very strong to Miles let's open up my
Rook on G2 and then bring the rest of
the pieces into the attack next
I don't think this is worth the pawn yo
this is the pawn I would like to get
back what I would do if I were black is
if I could take a pod it doesn't exist I
would put it on G3 and say here you go
you're my friend you know take this Pawn
will be even a material so if I could
give white upon I would but that's not
how chess works and The Rook on G2 will
remain on an open file going after the
black king
yeah and I I love your move it's so
simple but it looks so strong just say
clear open the line for the rook and it
will be joined by the dark Square Bishop
on moving to C3 and it will start eyeing
down the very vulnerable G7 points
okay I mean cat should we Panic if we
were Prague I mean this certainly does
look like a situation critical but say
like H3 is played where are we gonna go
with a knight
um F6 looks to me
a chance
I guess we could swap on F3 and bring
the second Knight to E5 so we have two
options all right Knight F6 or Knight
takes let's start with Knight F6 so that
looks pretty normal to me and they're
and um let's amp up the pressure and
Bishop oh my gosh C3 I I I I cheated I
cheated because I didn't expect it to be
this high this is ridiculous you ready
for this
the winning move apparently is Bishop B4
I was just looking at that just now just
only after you said oh my God and I was
like oh my spider senses are tingling I
need a fancy move she takes Bishop
so Bishop takes Bishop we're not even
taking back and we're gonna take this
Knight on E5 and the point is we
distracted the bishop away from the
Knight so that look at this if you move
your Bishop back Queen C4 check you
can't block with your Bishop because the
Knight and the queen team up in the
square what if you go King h8 well
that's going to be a big big problem
check
and I take here with another check and
that is a family fork and that is gonna
be the game
it is going to be the game when her
majesty disappears off the board no okay
you can't touch that one so
okay
94. what a move that's a sick move on
this is amazing
oh my god did I use it right kids
you did use it right and you know what
is so sickening about this position is
that it's such an easy move to overlook
so if H3 is played and probably plays
Knight F6 and let's say gookish doesn't
see Bishop before which is definitely in
his wheelhouse you know he's really
thinking deeply about this position but
if he doesn't play that movement let's
make the move Bishop C3 for example we
already see that black is not even uh
worse anymore so uh this is a really big
moment after H3 I think black does in
fact take on F3 with the Knight once the
queen takes this Knight then has to drop
back to E5 maybe nope that doesn't work
either I mean just no because the queen
will just swing over and give a check
you know she can go to D5 and oh loose
pieces drop off
Bishop
I mean just everything is this is just
beautiful geometry for white and nothing
going right for black if this bishop
moves we have Bishop B4 once again if
you want to win material and get a
little greedy we can also just go for an
attack and oh this is starting to look
unpleasant is selling it short that's
this is just not good for prognanda so
if gukesh plays H3 and finds this bishop
B4 tactic
he may win a very very nice game
yeah and uh I have to say good cash is a
very intriguing 16 year old you know
he's
didn't actually start training with
computers until very late relatively
speaking you know maybe when he was 14
years old now of course he does train
with engines and uh also he loves
in-game compositions he solves them
actually in his spare time and he
composes them as well so
yeah uh I know this because he sent some
to Jan Timon and then you and chess for
his new and chess article
that is awesome I actually had no idea
and I know some of the younger
generation are you know composers they
like to join those composition uh what
do you call them
the tournaments almost right like
they're they're awarded prizes uh and I
know Christopher you uh the young
American Grandmaster also composes
position so that's really cool to hear
yeah I know it is certainly something
that I think should be in mind in fact I
think most of the top players are
solving in-game compositions in their
spare time I mean they just do it
as a good training technique and uh
certainly a way to sharpen their
calculation practice and also their
practical end game skills
I did I honestly you just kind of blew
my mind a little bit here because I did
not know that and it almost makes me see
him in a different light it doesn't it
shouldn't it's just like a simple fact
about uh the person but I just find that
uh kind of mature Beyond his years like
you typically think of composers as
being like you know I've been around the
block a few times and now I'm creating
positions based on my experiences as a
teenager I barely had experiences and
yet he's 2700 plus creating awesome
compositions so that's cool
yeah it was quite funny that you said
that because
I I I saw an interview with him where he
talks about participating in this
tournament this is his first classical
super Grandmaster tournament and he made
a very interesting observation well for
me I I found it very fascinating he said
there are a lot of young people here and
normally I found it quite quite kind of
strange that he thought that other
people were young and he didn't consider
himself Young
the youngest one there
because he comes across so mature yeah
so quiet so mature so thoughtful
you know I'm a big fan yeah I have to
say I'm a big fan of these uh Indian
Juniors to me they're like a breath or
fresher you know there's they don't come
with any egos they come with just
they're very polite well-mannered and
they're very softly spoken very calm and
very very dangerous at the board and
they have such an incredible work ethic
it's just beautiful to watch
yeah it was great to see at the start of
the event that vishwanathan the former
world champion was there with these
youngsters uh there was a photo that I
saw on social media it's been referred
to many times but it's really nice to
see the legend the hero in his native
India he's working with these top
talents helping them uh grow and they
are very young they're in their teenage
years but Vichy was there once fighting
with the top players in the world when
he was a teenager so gukesh he has a
great chance right now if he finds that
move H3 and presses forward it's it's
not a move that is too difficult at
least from the start but that variation
we looked at earlier with Bishop B4 that
is what's difficult to play and there it
is he actually didn't play H3 instead
plays Bishop C3 the advantage it remains
that's the good news for him about that
H3 tactile sequence that was a cool one
uh but why not how could you blame him
for playing a very straightforward move
yeah it was irresistible let's face it
because your eyes naturally Converge on
G7 and of course we are taught the rule
invite everyone to the party and Bishop
C3 is doing that so how can that be
wrong
do will have to prove why it's wrong if
he's able to find a way I'm not envious
of his test so while he sits and
considers his response with all that
pressure mounting against his King we
have three other games still in progress
not much has changed in the bottom right
between Jordan Von forest and Vincent
kymer it seems that
um upon on D6 is not targeted you're
leaping forward with his Knight and the
game between Fabiano and our generic
Isis in the middle there the bottom row
to innovate kind of quiet Affair thus
far so
that game looks a lot different than the
Magnus game which we have looked at
recently so what do you think should we
go to the fobby game since it's been a
minute yeah let's go there because after
all there's been a trade of Rooks and uh
both sides have been placing their
Knights on the king side and
actually take a look at the Knights all
set so nice all together next to their
siblings as are the Bishops you did say
invite everyone to the party so these
nights are you know and Bishops they're
just being cordial they're letting you
know the other pieces know that it's
okay they're they're together they're
supporting one another and uh yeah that
position is one that looks very very
interesting we'll bring it up uh in a
moment so yeah Magnus Carlsen by the way
in the bottom left he brought his Rook
to E8 with check he is putting that King
under some pressure the f file open it's
an end game sure but it's going to be a
hard-fought battle with the position
being open but let's let's go to Fabiano
versus Arjun we've been talking about
that one the knights being together the
Bishops being together
um the question is
who is better and why that's the
question I don't have the answer to so
I'm going to pass that one over to you
I I don't have an answer to this
question either I mean again I'm gonna
actually fall back on the one rule I do
know in these kind of low-pass Italian
positions I mean look at which which
Bishops are working and if I were to
Hazard a guess it's all about the light
squared Bishop White's light Square
Bishop really is not in the game
meanwhile look at the bishop on D7 it is
eyeing up born on age three so there you
go it has something to bite on just the
possibility of a potential sacrifice on
H through H3 and also I do feel that the
knights on G6 does have an anchor on F4
and it's like a minuscule thing
but I do feel that that gives black
like the most microscopic edges of edges
I like what you point out because the H3
Pawn looks well defended
um but because you said that I wasn't
originally thinking about this move I
like the move Queen A8
setting up Bishop takes H3 removing the
guard of the Knight F3 it's a dual
purpose move the Rook now can slide to
the B8 to the open B file attack the
queen and maybe even lift up to a square
like D5 eventually to go after the A5
Pawn so really what you were saying led
me to this move I like Queen A8 and the
question is how is white going to deal
with the threat of Bishop takes H3 it's
actually quite annoying that that is
what black is Amy for not to mention
Bishop C6 lining the queen up in the
bishop uh with the bishop on the longest
diagonal that looks threatening as well
yeah it is threatening actually I hadn't
actually dreamed of the move Queen A8
but now it's on the board it's beautiful
I mean Bishop goes to C60 I mean the
only way to defend the night is to go um
which would be one
and then just just go wow you know ain't
pretty but sometimes that's life you you
are excused yovi I I will forgive you
for retreating this bishop to D1 but
it's one of those moves that you may not
like the look of it but it could be
necessary because Bishop if I make some
random like Queen A1 Bishop takes H3 is
going to happen if you take back down
goes your knight and F3 thank you very
much for a pawn like as a head material
and going to go and try to Checkmate the
white king So Bishop takes H3 is a
threat and maybe you have to bring some
pieces to D1 but still I like the power
of Black's pieces versus the passivity
of white
yeah it's it's uh definitely a position
that has its layers you know you peel it
back you think it's normal but then just
strip a few layers and you actually
realize that black is the one with some
serious pressure better pieces and it's
now Fabby who has to be on the back foot
has to find the necessary defensive
resources and probably will have to curl
itself into a little ball and Bishop C6
the same kind of idea on the board and
the bishop takes nice serious threat and
you don't really want to be dancing
around backwards with the Knight you
don't really want to be going to H2
no you definitely would not be happy to
make that move so he shows us that he's
not going to do it you can't make Fabi
play Knight H2 he plays Knight E4
instead and will we see a swap on e4 uh
that gives the sides I know we don't
like this word a sort of symmetrical
Pawn structure that doesn't mean the
game is a draw though just because uh
the pawn structure may be the same for
both sides this Pawn on A6 maybe that's
the target maybe A5 is weaker it remains
to be seen with this Knight possessive
jumping into F4 at the moment there's
still life left in a position like this
even if the pawn structure looks quite
similar so I think that 94 was a very
good choice and I believe that Arjun is
no worse in this position I think he's
done a great job in this game now it's
going to be about who's fixed Pawn is
worse uh who can actually create threats
the answer might be nobody and then
we'll see a split point but Arjun he's
playing confidently right now
now he certainly is and he does capture
the knight in the middle and I have to
say I like his chances I do feel that
also when you compare dark Square
Bishops I do feel black if he might he
manages to put the bishop on C5 we'll
also have a superior piece and again the
Knight jumps into F4 it just seems that
yes white is ultimately very solid but
it is black the one who has the plan and
as we say in chess it's really better to
have a plan a plan is better than no
plan
for sure and I think right now the plan
for our generic is to stop this losing
streak and he is looking good in this
game and the Press caught up with Arjun
prior to the tournament and asked him
how he feels about going into the master
section these were his thoughts
so it's definitely going to be a lot
stronger than a lot more challenging and
they have a lot of topless and this is
my first tournament playing amongst the
elite In classical so I look forward and
I'm very excited
honestly I don't think it changes
anything
particularly to me but it's nice to have
a Spectators watching chess
I am quite used to playing the happy
place in general even the pandemic I
used to play a lot of Blitz online so so
rapid Blitz I am always used to and
classical is something that's been there
since years since basically when I
started playing chess so at the moment
it's not so difficult to adjust someone
format to another
oh like the fact that there's a so many
Spectators watching and and they achieve
their chefs not just for me but just
they love chess and chess is getting
more attraction that feels great
what a kind humble teenager right you
know he is talking about how the world
of Chess has changed how he's played so
many rapid and Blitz events and that's
where he made his Mark yovi I think
sometimes people see these youngsters
and there's hearts for Arjun in the chat
they see his youngsters think oh they're
rapid and Blitz specialist he's showing
that he can do it over the board in
classical chess and I think he just
loves all the disciplines
yeah I he just loves chess uh let's put
a lot like that and he's young he has
the energy I was actually quite
fascinated to hear how he's going to
make that transition from Blitz rapid
you know with time control is relatively
fast to a tournament like Tata where we
have three time controls it's one of the
longest time controls since going back
in time many many years and it really is
an endurance test this tournament I mean
so a few tournaments have 13 Rounds and
it's a super Grand Master event as well
let's not forget that's it every
opponent you will face will be one
amongst the world's best and of course
Fighting Chess along the way and you
have to think about your nerves your
physical fitness but uh and there we see
Arjun you know you have to remember he
just come off the back of three losses
and now he's handling Fabiano carawanan
in a normal Swiss tournament I mean you
will be playing someone much lower rated
but here nope you got uh someone in the
top five
yeah in a normal tournament here playing
someone like me instead he has to play
Fabiano caruano so it's a tough sledding
out there no matter what your score is
no matter you know what rounds you've
had success in and Arjun has found
himself great success in the last couple
years he just signed it very lucrative
contract that endorsement deal so he is
sponsored you could see it it's small
but you can see it on his jacket there
uh he's I think it's 1.5 million dollars
if I'm not mistaken so uh with Quant box
I mean what a achievement that is for
the young player it gives him the
stability to focus on chess on playing
chess and that way he doesn't worry
about the finances it's an amazing
opportunity for him
yeah and uh people forget that it's very
costly obviously not just to play chess
and to travel the world but uh indeed to
actually have a second maybe even a team
of seconds to help you coordinate the
resources again studying with a super
engine is also quite an expensive
Endeavor because
you have to
well if you're like normal folks like me
you have to actually go online pay for a
super computer and uh would pay to rent
one that's that's the way it works you
rent one for how much is it is it I
don't know I've never done it before
yeah the only time I've used those is
when I'm working with a top player and
that's on their dime so I've never
actually uh really checked but uh yeah
it's you know it can add up very quickly
with seconds with uh all the engine and
then with training you often go to like
a locations kind of like a vacation but
you're focusing on chess it really adds
up but right now I think this position
adding up to a pretty level game for
these two so we're gonna go back zoom
out of this one because the game that we
were looking at for a while earlier two
of them in particular go cash against
prognananda the eval bar Sky High the
attack rages on for good cash but let's
first look at haramaxulu against Magnus
Carlson because whenever I look at a
Magnus game I don't pay any attention to
the eval bar I just look at the position
and say yeah there's some chances for
Magnus to win this game and what's
happening in this one is it says zeros
so completely level according to the
engines white is actually a pawn a head
but there are some problems in White's
Camp there are loose pieces across the
board the G4 Pawn loose this Knight's
under attack so I would move that Knight
first but I just feel like this isn't
just an equal game where they're going
to shake hands soon yovi I I really
believe that there is quite a lot of
life left here
yeah this certainly is some life and uh
talking about decisions I mean Magnus
Carlsen has his first decision in a way
is he going to jump forward with this
knight jump forward to
D4 I just had to do a quick double check
in my mind to see it was an available
square and it is and then the night goes
can go to B4 can go to E5 can actually
step backwards but I'm
you never sound The Retreat uh not
without good reason so the first move
that I would always consider is actually
stepping forward and creating maximum
tension and that would be jumping
forward to D4
um
yeah just offering a trade at nights
because if those come off the board then
E3 will be captured G4 is loose the
position Still Remains balanced but
there's some uh something left to prove
but I would say that if I were playing
for a win and I know in chess we're not
supposed to play with results in our
mind because I tell this to everybody
it's an objective game as soon as you
start thinking about wins and losses in
the middle of a game you're not playing
chess anymore you're playing for a
specific result but if I'm Magnus and he
just did it as I was talking I was going
to say Knight B4 that keeps the position
as messy as possible the A2 Pawn is
loose the B2 Pawn is loose Knight C2
check can be played because this Knight
is pinned and once I take on E3 down
goes G4 B2 this pressure on the f file I
just feel the over the position is more
difficult for white to play it's one of
those positions to say it's equal but if
we didn't have the eval bar off to the
side I believe that most players would
look at the this position and say give
me the black pieces in this game I know
white has an extra on it's a pass Pawn
but I just feel like White's position is
looser and thus it can fall apart at a
moment's notice
yeah definitely I agree with that you
know of course the bishop on F6 is so
strong and questions have to be asked
and okay how
I just was curious to see um how
difficult is uh parham's path to
equality to full equality by quality
actually mean like it's going to be a
draw
you know there's like no denying it
Magnus Carlson can't work his magic and
wriggle out of this type of position so
I'm thinking maybe
if tries to get the pieces to traded off
so you get the double Rook ending I feel
that white can hold their own there so I
mean our moves like King E2 a mistake
it's a really good question and uh
before I answer it with chess moves I
just want to make mention of the clock
if a Parham is down to about 20 minutes
left he has only played 23 moves so he
needs to get to move 40 to gain that 50
minutes on the clock so uh in part
answering your question Yogi he has 17
full moves to make so about a minute per
move
and in this position as you're saying
where is that path to equality how do we
trade off the pieces in a way that
ensures that we have a comfortable Rook
end game I don't see that that is why I
love the move Knight to B4 from Magnus
he is making Parham sweat each and every
turn and
King E2 that looks like a pretty natural
move black has a choice of which Pawn to
take and amazingly it still says level
game that was a a good choice it says
you know black may be slightly better
and I probably would take on B2 here but
the position still is complicated maybe
this Rook will slide to the f file put
maximum pressure here a D5 is a passer
maybe it will start running these are
really really difficult questions to
answer so I just believe the questions
are a little bit more challenging for
Parham than they are for Magnus
yeah I I agree and you're not even we're
not even kind of like sure as like where
you should put your king either because
the first instinct was to put it on E2
but then I'm thinking oh it's kind of
looking at the black Rook all sorts of
discovereds are available of the night
going to taking the pawn on D5
um say if the white Rook gets chased
away it's
it's a tricky conundrum actually for
param and I do feel that he cannot hold
on to his extra Pawn he has to give
something back but the question is how
to give it back in such a way to kind of
clarify the position
it's a fantastic question let's just go
through move candidates because B2 and
A2 are hanging if you play A3 attacking
this Knight over here on B4 I think the
Knight can jump into C2 with check and
take on E3 which also drops G4 but
Bishop takes B2 is available you take my
knight I take yours and what's Happening
Here B4 is loose G4 is still a problem
maybe the Rooks will line up maybe the
bishop will come to take this Knight I
feel like these this position is really
challenging I mean I'm not trying to say
Magnus Carlson as Magnus Carlson that is
part of the equation I'm sure Parham is
taking that into account as well I just
truly believe looking at this position
that it is an easier game for Magnus it
just is a situation where White's pawns
are sticking out a little bit more uh
they don't they're not connected with
other pawns and if you look at black
situation this Pawn this Pawn there are
many pawns are all safe and sound
yeah they are safe and sound and uh well
when it comes to equal positions there's
one thing I have noticed about Magnus he
tends to win them but he also likes to
over protect all his pieces and this is
actually a trend I've noticed in Grand
Masters full stop they rarely play you
know with loose pieces there and if they
do have loose pieces they immediately
Scurry to fix that and if they're in
time trouble you'll see them just
arranging contorting so that everything
is like beautifully protected and it was
something that I have never really
thought about and or bothered with
before but now that I've been observing
these guys I'm like okay I get it now
still don't do it this is a problem
yeah I'm the same way I've commentated
so many matches I'm like wow that looks
great why don't I do that and I never
really work into my own games but we've
seen the chat speak they think this
looks like it has Magnus endgame win
written all over it and
I'm feeling that way too par and look at
Parham he's still thinking here now he's
down under one minute per move and
it's not like his position is going to
be resolved anytime soon there really
are so many challenges posed in this one
where is he going to lose both A2 and B2
that would be a travesty especially
because black has two Pawns of his own
over here even if he just loses one of
the pawns is black going to be able to
push those pawns create a passer is G4 a
little bit too loose for white so I'm
good is that pawn gonna fall off uh is
D6 available like that's another
tempting move we always want to push our
pawn and it turns out it's okay it's not
hating that move but I'm already seeing
Knight C2 I'm seeing Bishop B2 Knight A2
all of these are in the air but we do
need to watch out D7 yeah d8 is not very
far away
and uh chat reminding us that of course
the clock is an important part of the
game and the clock of course he has less
than a minute per move for and this
means that param is actually going to
struggle there you know and when you're
playing with time pressure mistakes that
you make is first of all you can push
pawns you can determine the position you
can be impetuous and also let's not
forget the the best one of all making
blunders
Parham would like to avoid making those
blunders and well we'll leave him to
this defensive task he really has his
work cut out for him he looks like he
understands the weight of this moment it
could fall apart from if he is not
careful and the playing Hall is full of
Spectators of players in all of the
sections we'd love to see that so while
we leave the playing Hall we're not
saying goodbye we'll say see you in a
few we're gonna take a quick break when
return the action continues here round
10 of the Tata still Masters in Vikings
a
do you wish playing a chess game with a
friend was as easy as sending them a
text well good news now it is but
chess.com's new iMessage app you can
start and play a game directly in
iMessage your friend doesn't even need a
chest.com account it's just tap and play
head over to go.chess.com iMessage or
use the command iMessage in chat to
learn more
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
s
for this cozy coastal town the holiday
season isn't over
in fact the most wonderful time of the
year has really just begun come on gotta
make a move no no no no no no no no no
oh my God I'm speechless there
once again Vicon say starts the new year
as the center of the chess Universe this
year as host of the 85th Tata steel
chess tournament
a magnet for the best players in the
game some recognize the Masters field of
2023 as its strongest in recent memory
of course it helps when eight-time Tata
steel chess champion Magnus Carlson is
back
what a game for Magnus and now a huge
chance to make a furious run at first
place the world's number one looks to
further cement his legacy in this event
and the game's history
chasing Magnus will be amongst the best
in chess several have been crowned
Champion here before some have even
shocked the world in doing so
don't leave out those poised to capture
their first Tata title Anish Geary is
just I mean he beat both world number
one and world number two in the same
tournament
although winter Tata steel chess is also
known as the place new stars come to
bloom
Magnus one here is a teenager this
year's event has its fair share of young
players on the rise each hoping to
follow in Carlson's footsteps why
for Notre by
quarterback the Dutch refer to Tata
steel as The Wimbledon of chess for 85
years in running this tournament
continues to be steeped in Prestige and
Legacy and does so again in this
welcoming Little Dutch town by the sea
mine brynden
it's the 85th edition of the Tata steel
chess tournament let's make chess
history together
foreign
round 10 but look at how many people are
still in the playing Hall they're
playing in all of the amateur sections
there's the Challenger section there's a
qualifiers section and the many
different rating category tournaments
it's so great to see this Yogi a couple
years at past you know players weren't
allowed in the other events but it's
great to see everybody back in the
playing Hall and these two Indian
teenagers I'm sure they're thrilled to
be in their Master section now it's a
complicated battle but such a great
experience for them yeah certainly you
know they get just about heads with the
worlds and leads and of course
just to take as many points and many
victories as they can and they're both
players in complete Focus mode and they
have to be because the position that
they're playing is the sharpest one
we've seen in out of the whole round I
mean the position it's nuts it's crazy
we've seen it all the pendulum has been
swinging backwards and forwards and uh
let's go and uh have a look at how
things are going because if Prague wins
this one we have to remind ourselves he
will jump over the 2700 rating mark
would be so huge for him and you know
throughout the tournament we're keeping
track of the player's
Progressive getting 24 and a half rating
points his live rating is
27.37 that's huge and prognanda there
he's getting the third most points but
if he wins as Jovi just stated he will
cross 2700 for the first time it feels
like he's already over 2700 because he's
beaten Magnus a handful of times in the
Champions chess tour but he's having a
monster tournament and on the flip side
look at dukesh out at 12th there he's
lost quite a bunch of a bunch of ready
points and dingley ren he's lost the
most in this event 15 rating points uh
gone down the drain he is under 2 800
and he probably is not very happy with
how his tournament has gone
no and you can kind of see it in his
face you know after he agreed to draw
with abdusitor if he was frowning he was
just a little bit despondent and
thinking about those uh lost rating and
of course no one wants to be invite no
one wants to be playing these 13 round
events and then struggling through them
but uh ding still has three three rounds
left right so is it four three three
yeah
he has time to cut some of those losses
but it's not going to be a pleasant uh
tournament regardless and that's the
thing it's great experience for these
players 13 Rounds against the world's
best but if you're having a bad event it
lasts for a long time and uh on the
other side of things
gaining 25 rating points and he's Geary
gaining half that but still a really
great turn for him and Wesley who drew
against a niche with the white piece is
still having a positive event so all the
way down through Fabiano caruana gaining
a little bit of rating of those three
players from the American Federation
they're bunched together fourth fifth
and six in terms of rating gain and it's
particularly nice to see Levon aronian
with a positive event because
2735 is not his strength that's way too
low for a player of his caliber I think
his Peak rating was 28 30 or 28 35 so
um you know he is maybe having the best
of his career behind him but he still
has so much to offer and he is
underrated right now 27.35 is not Lavon
yeah and uh someone who is losing points
though is Magnus Carlson his two losses
have cost him daily and aha must be
unfortunate to be Magnus at the top now
he's desperate to get to 2900 just break
down that barrier but it's not easy when
everyone is so much lower rated than him
and of course underrated which is
willing to steal his rating points
I think he was a little bit underrated
before this event at 27-13 uh but some
of the other teenagers have struggled we
see towards the bottom cash Arjun losing
rating here it's just how strong this
field is Jordan bunt Force entered as
the lowest rated player he's lost a
couple points not many uh but he is also
a former champion of this event so if he
is the lowest rated player in the field
good luck to you there are no free
points and the game that we have on
screen between gookash and prognanda
this one has been exciting from the
start and you'll be while we're on break
you were telling me that it's a critical
moment for ragnan to have to move H3 his
Knight's under attack but in fact just
retreating with the Knight would be a
step in the wrong direction
yeah absolutely
um in fact he has only one way just to
secure equality and uh it's not by
making moves like Knight F6 if you do
that then you're just being that little
bit careless because the Rook is going
to swing over to E1 and you're going to
be in a lot a lot of trouble and
oh hang on a second prag has just made a
move and he's not found the right path
he's played Bishop E5 and I was gonna
say the only way to equality was
actually to capture the Knight and after
Queen takes night then step back with
the Knight to F6 this was it this was
the only way
wow and I think one of the big reasons
why just to show you know some of the
problems that existed with Knight F6
even if you just take this bishop here
and take this Pawn on B7 the lg7 is
really under threat from all angles the
Queen and King are on the same diagonal
so there might be a pin and win of the
queen uh they can't bring the Rook up
because you lose the second rook in the
corner if you play Queen F7 this is why
the queen and king being the same
diagonal as a problem Bishop C4 it's a
distraction tactic please take my free
Bishop thank you very much that's check
me behind the queen on G7 so the queen
unfortunately can't take as that's mate
and so that would cost black material so
that's why Bishop takes F4 was so
critical let's distract the queen away
from F3 but yovi Bishop E5 played and we
know that you can't take on G4 right
away I don't think because after F takes
G4 then this Knight is loose here but
what happens is you take on E6 well
that's something to move Queen takes
Queen takes e
6 and then after what are you doing
after Pawn takes like is he banking on
Bishop takes Bishop
oh because you can't take with the queen
no yeah exactly
yep that would be oh dear don't want
that one but you can take
but first of all you're not obliged to
take but you can take with the pawn
let's see if you can get away with that
and uh once the queen just swoops down
to B3 and starts sniffing around the
white king
what is the calm defense
I think oh Queen D5 check
I have a hard time Imaging prognito
missing this move but it is important to
point out that if let's just give I know
it's a blunder please everybody just
calm down for a second uh after Queen B3
If instead of going uh Queen to D5 if
this King were on h8 so I'm gonna put
the King on h8 that's my point uh let's
go King h8 first
the king goes to the corner and if I had
a free turn how do I waste a movie with
like Rook G1 then the queen comes into
B3 you see the eval bar suggesting this
is not going to be very easy for white
because the queen is attacking all the
pawns the rook's coming to C8 there is
an attack against the white king but
because the black king is on the
diagonal you just don't have time to
play Queen B3 because Queen D5 is check
forcing the Queens off the board so Yogi
this doesn't seem to pan out for black
at all and maybe there's some hope
chests involved that somewhere here uh
gukash could go wrong and there's some
counter play
but it's yeah I mean he must have
another idea in in mind okay so I I
refuse to believe that Prague calculated
this particular position so let's let's
go back and Knight takes Bishop I think
that one is the killer move as you've
indicated Queen takes
I mean
could could there for instance be
there's a lot of pressure on C3 could
there be some funny Move Like The Rook F
to C8
mmm
okay you're going for this because A3 is
also loose uh but I might even have
Queen D5 here going okay
for your king I actually maybe we can
even put a simple move Knight D4 just
retreating my piece and avoiding all of
the tactics on the C3 square and white
is a piece ahead and G4 is under attack
yeah
okay
don't forget it
I I don't get it either okay what
happens if this bishop takes Bishop
takes Bishop okay let's try this one so
I'm sending a crafty trap that if you
play Knight takes Rook
I am going to play no The Crafty trap
does not exist s
I was waiting for it I was like wait
what what's going on here I'm curious no
it doesn't no for some reason I
hallucinated and put the King on A1 and
I got very excited and I was like hey
this queen takes a A3 but there is
absolutely no chance of that so um okay
I'm doing it for you you know Queen A3
just to show what you were calculating
that if this poem were pinned then this
would result in a Checkmate on B2 that's
actually a really clever tactical
sequence sometimes our mind wanders to a
puzzle Rush yeah it it does because yeah
this Knight takes work and that's the
end of that one
um okay I'm really really like
scratching my head I'm really trying to
find out what he can do so
okay Queen takes Knight only move
the problem is that porn taste night
Bishop takes
I mean that's the only way you're even
gonna get at like by going Bishop takes
Bishop you know what he must have
forgotten about queen to queen to D5
okay unless there is some argument for
just King h8 and threatening Queen B3
but Queen D5 still is a really good move
for white and white is up at peace for
just one Pawn there's no way there's
anything remotely resembling
compensation uh for this piece I know
that King side or the queen side but the
king for white looks a little bit uh
like it's in danger but there's no
attack there's not enough pieces going
after it and the black king isn't safe
either once this G file opens up or
pieces swing to the H file at someone so
you'll be maybe he thought his position
was that bad so he went for this but I
am struggling to come up with a
variation that looks the least bit
promising for pragananda uh you and me
both I mean but there is something to be
said this this whole variation hinges on
cash actually finding Knight takes
Bishop
the problem is that if you do follow the
rules of checks captures threats you'll
get there very quickly
yes so he's going to spend his time but
you know he's looking at Knight takes E6
we'll leave gukesh to it for the moment
uh just because a lot is happening in
the game between para maxulu and Magnus
Carlson and I don't think that people
are going to be too surprised to see
that suddenly the evaluation bar is in
magnus's favorite it's an end game we're
talking about all the pressure he was
exerting and he was down upon and now if
you look at the bottom left of your
screen
and now we're going to bring It full
screen for you he's up upon Jovi how
does he do it time and time again
yeah this is Magnus working his endgame
magic and uh We've noticed one thing he
always starts from a good Pawn structure
all the pieces are protected all the
pawns are great and uh it's just a
question now of neutralizing this
terribly dangerous D6 Pawn if you can do
that then Magnus will just look to the
long term with great happiness because
he does have an outside passport in H5
sorry in H6 H5 and that one's gonna run
down and uh well hurry saying param is
not happy with this definitely no this
is not the ton of events that he was
expecting and uh Kendrick's tongue very
very certain that Magnus is going to win
this
wow and look at flossini with nine
minutes for 12 moves versus Magnus end
game that's not gonna be fun and let's
just bring up analysis board quickly to
show how we got here because the
position did look difficult for Parham
so I I don't think we are surprised that
he is down upon now because if we scroll
back he went at this point D6 you always
think about pushing your past partners
move candid and I came to C2 with check
the king went up night Swap and Rook
takes G4 so there's a problem for Parham
is that B2 is now loose and if you spend
the time to play the move B3 then black
can swing this Rook to D7 and this Rook
will likely come back or the king will
Sprint to E6 and D6 has gone a bit too
far not a pawn you want to lose whereas
black has the outermost pawns that are
passed so it still was apparently within
the realm of keeping some sort of
equality but Rook D5 was played and
after Rook D7 he went Rook F1 he didn't
push his beep on Magnum says thank you
very much and that's where we sit that
just looks like a pawn bishop A3 goes
out for the D6 Pawn in the near future
you just have to watch out for these
night Forks it's the one thing you have
to be very very careful of thankfully
the bishop sits on B2 covering the
square
yeah and I can kind of see a situation
where the Rook is just going to sit
pretty on D7 and the other Rook perhaps
will also keep an eye on this D6 Pawn
but the real action will be happening
with the eight Pawn I mean I kind of
mentioned there one more time but I
think I might mention it again I think
it's just going to walk up the board and
uh
it's very difficult for param to do
anything because there's almost like a
deadlock along the d-line both sides to
funding and attacking the pawn on D6
and I think that this Pawn is already in
big danger Rook G6 Bishop A3 we do have
to look out for that one fork I keep
matching 95 so as long as Max keeps his
eye on that he may be able to even
Corral this pawn and white is unable to
connect his pawns E4 off limits because
the Rooks placement on G4 so this
individual move I mean it's hard to find
moves for power hum there it was Rook D3
back and let's see what happens uh oh
it's getting worse so he swings that
Rook back to D3 and apparently that was
another inaccuracy in what was already
seeming like uh you know Herculean task
it seems that Magnus has the not just
the upper hand but even the chance to
just secure a winning advantage
yeah and if the evaluation bar goes up
that much it probably means that
he's gonna go Pawn hunting or something
with a rook I probably wouldn't even go
for that I would probably be looking at
more of a consolidatory approach but
okay this is the benefit of us analyzing
with the evaluation bar the evaluation
bar can give us a little signpost and
tell us hey you know putting your Rook
on A4 and going after the a pawn you
know how normally in a game you wouldn't
touch it because
smells a little bit could be a bit
dangerous evaluation Bar's like no it's
fine it's fine go ahead do it
um it's also a movie that I think we can
explain right it's like one of those
moves that we have a hint so we find it
out but Rook A4 it keeps The Rook away
from the fork it attacks a pawn and it
protects the A3 Square so your Bishop
can go there and The Rook can slide back
to A6 as well so I feel like it makes
perfect sense I agree with you that I
was looking at Rook A4 I was looking at
this H Pawn especially because the Rook
left the D5 Square I was looking at a
way to go after D6 and Magnus as well
wasn't looking at Rook A4 still makes a
great move
yeah I I like the move Bishop F6 it just
feels great because also at the right
time you can think of the king coming
out to F7 again has to be done at the
right time because obviously if you do
it now then that will come to E5 and
that would be very unfortunate check
um
but if uh Magnus were to get his pieces
coordinated King to E6
and start corralling the pawn it will be
happy days
um para not so much time on the clock
as well I mean what a disparity and time
I have to say Magnus just over 45
minutes and uh Parham six minutes and
they are move 29
um
I wonder at what point he really got
worried like if you could be in his mind
at let's say 10 moves ago or whatever it
was when night before happened that was
six moves ago and it was that the moment
where he's like this is getting out of
hand I'm in trouble now because there is
that Magnus effect all players talk
about it Hikaru has spoken about it on
the Lex Friedman podcast on his own
streams that when you're playing Magnus
and also when people are playing Hikaru
you expect tenacious defense or for them
to be able to grind you down and win
some kind of end game so I wonder for
Parham even when he was up a pawn if he
was thinking like uh oh this looks like
a situation and I've seen Magnus win
I've studied his games like this on
dozens of occasions and as we see Magnus
looking at the camera he's like yep just
another one that goes down in the uh
books here he's just really unbelievable
in the end game yeah he is
um I have to say and there's Magnus just
looking off to the side
fully focused
I think that things went wrong for
Parham
when the Magnus managed to get Queen F6
and trade of Queens
because that kind of position just is
the kind of
end game where Magnus is in his element
He has the better minor pieces he also
has a better Pawn structure he's had
great development with his Rooks and he
could use it as a springboard to get
other small little advantages and now
he's kind of made sure that that's a
material advantage and he has everything
in his favor and param I think is also
suffering from the Magnus effect but I I
for me the Magnus effect is kind of
twofold the first one is when you're
just simply like wow Magnus I just have
to make a result any kind of result and
so you take negative decisions and you
don't challenge Magnus the second one is
like you're like hey I'm playing Magnus
and then you get so into it so
enthusiastic you become slightly forced
uh and uh you just try to force the
matter you try to determine your own
personality onto the game and you just
don't sit back and just let it happen I
kind of liken it to you getting in your
own way
and you mean we see param here under
three and a half minutes to make 11
moves the chat has been commenting on it
Magnus is back baby says super edg3 and
well this Rook just came back he went to
D3 and now it's on the yo-yo string back
to D5 uh so for param he's just trying
to find ideas find moves and for Magnus
who's ahead in the clock and ahead in
the position where do we want this Rook
to go we can bring it to A4 once again
to go after the pawn on A2 we could
bring our King in King F7 King E6 not
out of the question not now don't do
that now don't fall for the Trap
oh
I'm gonna point that out that is that is
awesome 95 check because the bishop is
pinned and if you go King to E6 this
Knight takes on D7 and after King takes
D5 I think it's winning for white
because after Knight takes F6 check you
can't stop this Pawn the king is in the
worst possible place it's after GF D7
the only way to stop it is Rook to G8
but King promotion Square same line
thank you very much Rook D1 is check and
next I promote and I go up a rook if
you're Palm so I blundered it and I have
blundered in magnus games before and he
has made that same mistake I don't think
in classical chess he's gonna do it but
in the famous game against Hikaru
Nakamura in the speeches Championship he
blundered a bishop because I suggested a
move and it simply hung the piece yeah I
in your defense I also suggested the
move but then I kind of caught myself
and I said later on you do it later on
not now
yeah that I appreciate you helping me
escape because I could just play it off
like I meant that that's an idea it's a
concept not the move right now but no I
did completely Overlook a knight to E5
and uh well with that in mind there
could be an argument for Rook E4 which
will allow the king to Dart to the E6
Square I like the look of Rook A4 being
a little bit more direct no subtlety
needed over here and Magnus he's doing
the right thing he has pressure on the
board he's up a pawn he has pressure on
the clock promise under four minutes for
uh to reachable 40 he's only 30th move
made so I feel like he's just trying to
continue posing the challenges because
he knows that even with infinite time
he's probably going to win this game if
he plays it accurately
yeah absolutely I quite kind of like
your rookie for so that the pieces can
come together coordinate make one big
happy family
and chat saying Magnus has got lots of
time enough time to watch the TV show
you know what I can't really argue with
that because it's true
yeah certainly true so uh well we'll be
right back to this game because Magnus
is thinking we have to look at another
game because we were absolutely correct
yovi the game between gukesh and
pragnananda program number is simply
down a piece like he is down a bishop in
that game uh so it just feels like he
went Bishop E5 if we bring that board up
in Desperate mode he just was hoping
that he could get something going when
he made this move Bishop E5 but the very
straightforward sequence Knight takes
politics night we saw this happening and
Rook d8 played to take away the D5
Square so the one thing that Google
should not do is get greedy if you trade
Rooks and say give me this Pawn on F5
thank you very much you already see the
evaluation going in Black's favor
because that Rook was very important on
the first rank now is Queen E1 check and
the bishop will drop so that means that
if the Rooks are traded you have to find
a different move and considering it's
completely winning based on the EVO bar
I think Queen E2 looks best offering the
queen trade you have checks on the
diagonal if the queen leaves it and
white is a piece ahead that's the best
news and it's going to stay that way for
good cash
yeah and uh gwinnie to such a great
defensive move you know whenever your
king is in trouble just move the queen
over she makes a fabulous Defender and
if you can trade her off for its
opposing Queen even better and uh
they go Pawn takes Pawn on the board so
no Rook takes Rook
so it's uh it looks good cash
yeah I saw politics at five and I was
still in my head thinking if the Rooks
were traded politics if I was not
possible but the Rook is still on D1 so
uh my uh oh was for no reason it is
still uh still everything under control
uh for goo cash over here and well the
first question we have to ask is
E3 yeah exactly that's the first thing I
would do with that if I were playing
Black spit the queen there and just go
what you got show me how you're going to
defend and okay Queen takes A3
in the air what is the defense
what is happening here
I mean is he planning some
what
because Queen takes A3 is going to be an
immediate draw
so what is available
oh my gosh Rook G7
King takes Queen G3 I I thought the king
could just slide to h8 but if it does
there's a forced Checkmate Queen E5
King to G8 and what Checkmate you only
have your Queen Bishop comes out to C4
with check bringing your pieces into the
attack because that's a rook G one the
King has only one safe Square F7 and
Rook G7 is Checkmate oh my gosh so that
is what gukesh is cooked up here he has
done his tactics you said he's a
composer of puzzles and positions he
sees that after this sequence no matter
where the King goes it's trouble if you
go up to if you go to F7 let's sit there
Queen comes to C7 with check and if the
King goes to G8 there's Bishop C4
protecting this while the Bishop wins
the queen Yobe I feel like every single
tactic just barely works out for white
but barely is good enough
yeah it is good enough and my goodness
me he had would have to see the whole
Myriad of complications there because
yeah King G8 will lose on the spot but
what about King F6
how do you keep the game
alive there ah you just take it
he's claiming that you have some checks
good for you but even if you keep giving
the checks the king can run away and if
you're gonna run out of checks your
queen to C1 check the king slides to F3
you can't take the bishop because your
Rook is loose and if you take the Rook
here the queen takes back with check
very importantly and white is going to
be up a bishop and just Checkmate the
black king very shortly there's no
defense for that King so this is an
amazing tactical sequence so he solves
his Kings his King's issues on the queen
side over there by finding this
wonderful tactical resource and if you
can't play Queen B3 because if Rook
takes G7 I mean that's just game like
that is a Game ending shot by gukesh wow
what a find
there's an amazing find and
I was just checking to see if there's
anything that prag can do so Queen B3
not possible what about moves like Queen
to E7
small little move threatening same thing
I guess I bring my Bishop out with check
the King goes in the corner and then
even even King B2 my queen defends The
Rook the king defends the pawn
everything is nice and defended
yeah
and uh yeah everyone everyone on chat is
actually complimenting kukash I wasn't
sure about the what a giga Chad is what
is it oh it's just you know uh I don't
even know how to explain it I I will
think about it and get back to you but
it's just like once you it's like
it's like a boss he's a big boss
oh chat I'm a bit old so I need you to
yeah
I need you to be accommodating to me I'm
like I'm not sure is that good of that I
think he's good
yeah I I've made mistakes because of
chat before so I just kind of ignore it
as best I can until I have to deal with
the word and I you know look it up or
someone tells me what it is but uh I've
been told what it is now ah I understand
now Chad
yeah one it's a it's a you know a beast
but right now what a tactical find with
Rook G7 on the horizon uh prognada is in
trouble so we'll leave him to it because
the games across the board are getting
more and more interesting it looks like
Fabiano caruanas in the middle the
bottom row there the eval bar is sliding
an Arjun eragisi's favor just a better
position for him but we should go back
to Magnus and Parham for now just
because Parham he's been getting very
low on the clock it looks like he made
his previous move his latest move with
three seconds because now he has 33
seconds left and is just at move 32 as
uh hey someone with Rob in there
a username has let us know and time is
your worst adversary yeah that is a very
very true oh dear timed off flit and uh
it goes so quickly
33 seconds left for param and his
position is just dire
and the black king is now in it's going
to creep into E6 and you can really
surround that pawn and just gobble it up
I mean how is Hiram gonna even try
to make magnus's life uncomfortable
it feels like mission impossible to be
honest with you what he needs is he
needs to miraculously move that E3 pawn
two squares forward
change of rules I'm afraid Magnus
[Laughter]
and then maybe there's something
but no not even that
truck has been so imposing on the fourth
rank you can't play E4 because of the
rook's positioning the king can go up to
E6 right now if Magnus wants and I don't
think there's any way that this Pawn on
D6 survives and once that pawn drops
black is two full pawns ahead played
King E6 just now yeah H5 H4 and so on
will happen you've been mentioning this
outside pass Pawn Parham just doesn't
have a move Rook B6 is pre-movable and
Rook takes D6 after that
I have what the thing is that you can't
fight on all fronts you know you can
fight against the uh the black sorry the
white porn being captured like for
instance you go in Knight D2 and if the
Rook goes back to B6 then okay then you
string forward to E4 but that's just one
idea okay Knight D2 on the board and
where's that Knight going it's going
nowhere so you can actually just now
start going age five and if the Knight
finds itself on B3 you can say you want
to jump to C5 I don't think you're going
to jump to C5 sorry yeah and then you
just could be six the end
so
everything is under blessing even with
B6 right now being preemptive to control
C5 I don't know what White's response is
going to be so a move Candace Rook A4
going out for the A2 Pawn B6 is
preemptively taking away the C5 Square
uh those look good I want to play H5 but
I guess I can't because the Rook is here
for now so G6 to play H5 next looks
pretty reasonable uh I think I'm out of
move candidates but I don't really need
any more just because all those moves
look good uh
yeah I feel that for white you're hoping
to meet Rook B6 with 94 that's the one
forward jump you have as long as the
Rook stays in the fourth rank you got a
whole lot of nothing
oh absolutely nothing in the tank there
and yeah what do you think Magnus will
play I mean he has 39 minutes
to catch himself on Netflix series
[Laughter]
that was a great callback I was like why
did you just say that and I remembered
that we have a chat message saying it
and I think it might even from Grandpa
Simpson which is equally comical because
uh Magnus was on an episode of The
Simpsons back in the day so we're really
coming full circle uh but for Magnus
here he knows he's winning and that's
why I like that he's spending his time
because there is no need to rush in as
soon as I say that he plays Rook A4 but
he spent some time he goes after the
pawn if A3 is played yeah okay I think
even Bishop B2 to go after that pawn is
available or is also Rook takes A3
in one go
oh my gosh either we just take it
because the Rook is distracted give me
your Rook give me your Pawn okay that
wins enough material that's gonna be
good
yeah and
an A3 plate
and uh so maybe we'll see Rook takes A3
just
if you take back King takes D5 you'll be
finding a really really nice sequence
there to pick off The Rook on D5 and
sure A7 is hanging but so is D6 and once
D6 is removed black is up two healthy
pawns and they're passed everywhere in
fact there are three past black pods
compared to one for white so it's like
blacks just completely winning finally
at long last the H Pawn can go
it probably won't Actually March
will have to be left with the idea of it
marching
yeah
[Music]
yeah 35 seconds left and he needs to get
to move 40. so as when he reaches move
40 he gets that additional 50 minutes on
the clock but yovi I know I'm putting
you on the spot here a little bit will
we even reach the 40. no
I don't think so
I think once the apron Falls Byron will
just say okay that's enough
I I mean how can he keep the game alive
he just cannot because with a downfall
of the a pawn the D Pawn Falls and it's
like the House of Cards and
yeah even someone as uh resourceful as
param
such a fighting spirit is not going to
be able to come back from these type of
uh deficits
I feel like you call this from the start
and I know dania's nickname is the
prophet but you were prophetic in this
one you said From parham's perspective
right uh is he going to kind of pick up
the gauntlet and go after Magnus or
should he be solid and Magnus got the
exact position he was hoping for a
double-edged strike sacrificing a pawn
and then the end game that of course is
desirable for Max he's the best in-game
player probably in history so
everything kind of went right for
magnets it just never felt like we were
in a position that was comfortable for
parm and Rook takes A3 is just played
you're calling the shots today yovi yeah
27 seconds it's going down for param
the position is also sinking
yeah he's maybe going to play this out a
little bit before he if he gets there
but he's dropping a pawn Rook takes Rook
The Rook is distracted from the other
and then D6 Falls next Black is two
pawns ahead very healthy position
we see these moves
and uh you do see the trade of works
and look at Park you know you can see it
on his face right
quasi asking if I'm from Delphi no no no
no no no
Robert's just being very flattering
I'm no Prophet okay Rook takes A7 yeah
but it's not it's not gonna change
anything
King takes Pawn
and yeah
that's that
and one thing we should comment on about
Magnus in general and we talk about how
good it is to end games he recognizes
quite quickly and he's very good
intuition but he's also studied uh the
end games very deeply of what end games
are winning like where he should take a
game he did that against Vincent kymer
when he won that Rook end game earlier
in this tournament so he's just so good
at that and well 94 check you're not you
don't really want to take on F6 anyway
you're just liquidating went down
material and if you don't liquidate the
bishop will just move out the way and
finally yovi I want to see the H Pawn go
or the b-pawn some of these pawns just
have to start moving up the board
sooner rather than later
yeah and uh first of all it's the king
that takes a step forward
oh he takes wow he takes the bishop
I think he's just uh
going through the motions I predict it
will not last longer than two moves when
they've reached move 40 that's it I mean
I'm even surprised it's gotten to move
40.
maybe param's just saying I'm playing
the world champion let me get my moves
in uh it's an experience you don't get
every single day and Parham was a last
second invitee to this tournament as he
brings his Rook back to A5 with check so
he wasn't even supposed to play Magnus
or any of the people in this competition
so credit to Parham for showing up on a
moment's notice just stepping in when
janchi stupa could not compete and to
this point he's had a pretty decent
event he has not had weeks and weeks to
prepare like some of the other
participants and here he is completely
lost King C4 The Rook is perfectly
placed cutting off the white king B5 B4
B3 B2 I don't think I have to say the
rest the king is in a great spot to help
Usher the pawn to the other side so I
just feel like part I'm really just
making moves at this point he knows the
outcome of the game is pretty much
decided but why not you're gonna get a
zero whether you lose in 20 more moves
or you resign now
yeah I agree I love King C4 and I also
wanted to add to that if that's not just
the only problem because the black row
can also go behind the age pawn and
start pushing that one as well just for
fun
and Casey full played
yeah this is uh not going to be a good
time for Parham and if he plays Rook H5
you can defend the pawn directly with
Rook H7 but you might even be able to
run that pawn down quickly you do not
want to hear both these pawns that's one
thing to note and maybe we can show that
because the players are about to reach
move 40 as soon as Parham makes this
move it's move 40. but let's say I go
after your pawns and you say I'm just
going to promote mine uh you already see
the evaluation drop because after Rook
H6 on the B3 the white Rook can slide
behind the black pawn the King goes up
and white can check but even if I don't
check and you eventually go and try to
promote this Pawn I mean I'm going to
keep checking you after that I'm not
letting you get anywhere and once your
king gets all the way down it has to
step in front of the pawn and now white
is free to start moving his own pieces
so uh yeah you just have to time it well
you don't want to make a mistake that
gives your opponent a win all of a
sudden but bringing the king up that way
even when you sacrifice your Rook for
this Pawn you're very Advanced with your
king and passer
playing your move Rook F5 so the moves
that he's hoping for he's hoping that
Rick F7 will be met with uh he's going
to meet that with Rook H5 and hoping
that they do a merry dance but Magnus is
going to say it that's fine you can have
one of those pawns you can take the
energy and use your energy to win that
one and in the meantime I'm just gonna
get on with the job of pushing the B
Pawn
great move Rook D6 because as you were
just indicating he will give up the H
Pawn that takes time and the black pawn
runs forward and none of those end games
will be holdable uh for Parham for
several reasons a rook trade will be
losing King and pawn and game uh the
white doesn't have any time to push this
Pawn because there's an F Pawn for black
so I mean Magnus great technique he is
going to win this game they have reached
move 40 uh so let's head on away from
this one we do trust Magnus uh we'll be
able to score the full point and that
means that he will jump into a tie with
Wesley so for third place a big result
for him and for Parham unfortunately he
just drops in the standings but the
other games that we have going on right
now we still have three others remaining
carwana and Arjun Eric icy that one is
looking symmetrical but still some fight
and good cash against Prague NADA that's
I think is that's been the battle uh
Yogi that's been the one where uh gukesh
played a risky opening it ended up
working wonders for him when prognanda
misstepped and now we're in a position
where he's who catches up a piece
yeah he's up at peace and uh his King is
relatively
safe I would say he after all can use
his extra Bishop to defend it and uh
yeah Prague really struggling there and
uh what about Vincent climber sorry John
Van Forrest against Vincent climber to
me this one
looks like it could be
oh hang on a second I just did a
material count
uh White is a pawn up
and I think we see the body language
that's one of those I like my position
postures from Jordan Von Forest arms
crossed upon up they're only on move 30
and Vincent kymer down to seven minutes
and change so he's in that's like 10
moves in about seven and a half minutes
now and as you were just counting white
is upon ahead
yeah I was gonna say I thought this was
gonna just uh go to gonna be a draw but
no it's not a draw because uh after all
white has something to nibble with an
extra porn and uh and a threat of Queen
taking H6 I hate him to add
at some point that will be hanging for
now the queen doing an important task
however the night with F4 if that's not
a good move I don't know what it is to
push my Pawn to E5
I just feel like Black's position you're
down a pawn and you have other issues to
deal with so let's just take a step back
see how we got here or go back a few
moves I should say uh because Jordan he
steps away from his board we left off a
move 20. so we will analyze event Force
manage the cows about three decisive
games today that's uh like the case
Knight went to D7 Knight C4 and then
Rook B4 so Jordan brings Queen to E2 I
like that move just defending the Knight
and we saw Bishop F6 but rookie oh my
gosh I love moves like this Yogi when
you scroll through a game you don't
think much of it but then you're like
wait why that Rook the A4 Pawn needs
this Rook on a1's defense the E4 Pawn is
ultra well defended so Rook e to D1
played by Jordan and not for the trade
D6 was in big trouble
mm-hmm
that's how it fell and uh is there did
Vincent try to generate some
compensation
you want Queen G5 and the way Jordan
plays this is the best move we see the
eval bar did not change if he took on D6
uh the problem is that the queen jumps
to C5 The Rook is under attack so the
Knight can't move but the knights also
Attack under attack with Rook takes C4
being a threat so too much is hanging in
the position for white to hold
everything together so instead he goes
Rock back to D1 marvelous play from
Jordan and after 95 only then did he
take on D6 when he was good and ready
and that led us to the position we have
on the board after a series of Trades
you had Queen D2 and whoa
G5 played just saying F4 will not be
that easy to play without initiating
some trades
yeah definitely I think it's the best
approach here to say you want to play F4
not on my watch and
okay
now as the ball is in Jordan's Court
okay I think the thing is you don't have
to chill sorry you don't have to stress
is what I wanted to say and try to do
something with that extra Pawn you can
just simply say okay I will just improve
my pieces and
first of all it would be nice to take
the center with the Rook I'm going to
put the Rook on D1 maybe even put the
Rook on B1 so it's an open Line uh
another kind of option that I'll be
thinking of is uh having a look at the
A6 pawn and securing it as a weakness in
the long term now there is one dangerous
threat on the board which I completely
forgot about but suddenly I see and then
his Bishop takes H3
oh it was not a problem beforehand
because F4 was coming but now it is a
problem so you have to deal with those
tactical issues and either move the key
or move the queen
wow I just want to show that tactic real
quickly because if Bishop takes H3 had
been played you don't take on H3 because
as you always pointing out there's a big
fork winning the queen here but you have
this move F4 which covers the F3 square
and you're threading a knight and
threatening Bishop all at once so uh
black is going to lose a piece that's a
really wonderful line now after G5 you
have to look out for Bishop takes H3 and
while we have Jordan sitting and
thinking here uh why don't we take a
moment to look at his profile and see
what a wonderful player he is
for me it's the most important
Tournament of the year been coming here
since I was like 10 years old and now
I'm already 23 and I'm still here so um
you know it's it's a good way to start
the year and I always look forward to it
and I mean I'm just always very happy to
be here like if I kind of feels like
staying at home to me
I have to say I find myself in a bit of
a strange position I mean I don't feel
like I'm old but indeed I'm already in
the middle it's going to be very
interesting to see how the young guys
will fare against the top guys so it's
going to be super interesting I would
expect that the top guys are still a
little bit ahead but I would also expect
to see some of them being beaten by the
by the young and upcoming super talents
um I really hope that classical chess
will remain you know classical chess
really most important is the quality of
the moves while on rep and the blitz
maybe it's different I feel I can play
good chess and bike because I feel
comfortable here I want to win a lot of
games create entertaining games I think
that's what I'm known for and that's
what I'm gonna try to do
[Music]
that was a fun profile on Jordan Von
Forrest who won the title Masters just a
couple years ago he right now is in his
game against Vincent kymer and I also
appreciate his thoughts on the younger
generation because Jordan is only 23
right he's in his Michael Jordan uh year
maybe it's his Michael Jordan year we
should call it but he is Young himself
but he's looking at these teenagers and
saying I expect the experienced players
the veterans to be at the top but some
of the younger players will get those
upsets and he's perfectly correct
because no direct Abdul sitarov may be
at the top of the standings but if you
look at the places after first it's all
of the players that are older than
Jordan right Anish Wesley Levon Magnus
and Magnus is also going to win this
game and jump to six out of ten and
Bobby's still playing but pragananda
he's the next one from that teenage
batch and then all the way down the
bottom as the rest of the teenagers 12
through 14.
yeah I agree with that you know they
have certainly snatched some points away
and of course nordebec abdusator simply
running away with the tournament at
least from the early rounds
and uh it's quite difficult for me to
think of Jordan as a middle-aged
contestant especially in this field you
know because he's so young 23 years old
and of course him and his family they
have a very very good chess pedigree I
think it was their great grandfather was
a great grandfather that was a top-touch
player
yeah for Generations it goes back and
also uh his brother is a Grandmaster his
sister is an up-and-coming talent I
believe in her 2300s at this point
already despite her young years so very
talented family that loves chess through
and through
yeah definitely and uh talking about
love chess through and through and we
have uh Jordan here he has uh one big
danger to spot and uh now that
managed to take a deep breath and
compose myself I can see that there is a
simple solution to like's threat or
Bishop takes H3 you just put the Knight
on F5 where it will Thrive and live
happily ever after
and unless black decides to say uh you
know living is short but I'm glad you
enjoyed your stay and not that this
solves black problems but by no means
this king is going to be open white is
up upon but maybe this is what Vincent
is hoping for uh that yeah it's going to
be worse for him but at least he
controls all the dark squares we keep
talking with the inherent limitations of
a bishop it only controls the color
complex it started on it can't suddenly
move to the B2 Square you wish it could
but it can't
no certainly not still lots of play in
that position and okay shall we go back
to the bird's eye view and see what else
is happening
for sure so we have uh
four games still going on three besides
this one and it looks like gukesh making
all of the good defensive moves you
probably Rook up the G4 the bar is still
all the way up uh we haven't looked at
the game between Fabiano and uh Arjun
eragisi and by the way it looks like
Magnus uh moonless I don't know which
game to go to because the magnets game
is about to end uh but let's start with
fobby game against Arjun Eric garcy uh
just because we have not tuned in to
that one for a long time and yovi it's
move 35 so 34 moves have been made to
this point both players around 10
minutes and what do you make of it we
have even material and the first thing
I'm thinking about is the pieces are on
Awkward squares
yeah for both sides I would say you know
Fabi is just contorting himself to
defend the E4 point
whilst aragosis
doing something with his Rook I don't
know what he's doing with the Rook but
probably just over protecting the queen
on D6
yeah I guess I could slide to F6 at some
moment though that doesn't really
threaten all that much
I just feels like there's a kind of
awkward standoff you know black has this
uncomfortable pressure against the E4
Pawn but Fabi says okay you have your
advantages in the position I'm gonna
have mine and the Queens are just kind
of staring off against each other and
that makes the position awkward and
let's not forget this bishop on E2 is
eyeing down this A6 Pawn so somehow it
is it's a very very tense position I'm
not quite sure either side can really
make progress here
looks like they're stuck and actually a
couple moves ago I just noticed this
this Knight was an F3 and it went back
to D2 because if black took what seems
like a free Knight then the Knight of C5
becomes free so the queen is doing an
important task and this would have been
a trade that Argent clearly didn't want
uh this is a six Pawn is a target C7
Pawn is a bit loose so and the queen is
getting active so instead he brought his
Rook up and then we saw the Knight go to
F3 so it's not impossible based on the
fact that this Knight is going back and
forth that if Arjun wants he can just
sort of repeat moves just like Fabi is
doing
it certainly looks like that kind of
situation where neither side wants to do
anything because you can't break this uh
standoff
um
it's very kind of rare position where
the position just kind of finds itself
locked into this drawer but it happens
and well let me ask you is it we're just
sort of kind of wondering we don't know
with any certainty if you're Argent here
you've had a bunch of losses in a row
three
you don't want to keep that street going
so a draw that sounds good black with
against 500 carwana sounds excellent but
you also probably want to win because
now that you know first place is
impossible and you're on the bottom half
of the standings you just take a risk
what do you do here it's your Argent
no no no no no you uh you study the ship
you play for a draw you take a deep
breath pay for the draw
and just make sure that you're calm
relaxed and ready for the games that
will happen after the free day because
if he goes berserk here and just does
some random stuff I mean quite frankly
he'll be criticized because the position
did not deserve such aggressive action
and secondly he'll have one whole rest
day to even to think about his whole
results and his whole tournament will
feel like it sucks to remember the black
pieces against Fabi is a good result and
objectively is what the position is
crying out for
and he's not a player that we see make
speculative sacrifices he really is a
principal player
um he just looks at the position he
evaluates and he finds the best plan so
I think you're right that he will not uh
take any unnecessary risk because he
doesn't want to lose a fourth game in a
row and the position doesn't call for a
sacrifice what even could you consider
Knight takes E4 that looks bad
because that's a rookie for Bishop takes
E4 Queen takes white has two minor
pieces for a rook
white will have the safer King A6 is a
long-term problem a knight can hop to G5
E5 is a little bit loose so I just feel
like you're asking for trouble if you're
Argent so I don't even see a way to get
adventurous here I do believe you are
correct you should uh just find a way to
maintain the balance
yeah
I think
I think you sometimes have to be
practical
practice and again kind of take a very
objective Viewpoint you know I sometimes
have this expression when I remember it
it's like just do what needs to be done
do what the disposition deserves if the
position deserves a draw then get that
draw don't again impose your ego on the
board on yourself it just forces the
play it just adds that extra element of
pressure and there's no need to do that
you play your best chess when you're
relaxed and okay
so as we're drawing
to the end of the time control
can we pop in on Magnus
for sure let's go back to the bird's eye
view and have a look
yes so Magnus Carlsen in a pure Rook end
game it is rook and pawn versus rook and
we're in instructive territory so we can
put on our coaching hats at the moment
as there's nothing to calculate in the
sense that you know tactics uh it's only
rook and pawn versus Rook but yovi the
key here the white king being cut off if
the white king were on B2 we'd say all
right this one heading towards a draw
for the king cut off along the C file
which means that the black king will
help Usher his past Pawn home
yeah it will and uh it's just a case of
a advancing the pawn and at the right
time
building the bridge I mean you can steer
yourself actually to positions that you
know like for instance the Lucina
position
and uh the Lucy in a position involves
the black king being on B1 if you know
that position go for it use it as a
signpost they go King A3 check
Robert is kindly putting it on the board
and here we go there you go and there
you go and the technique involves step
one driving the white king
off the d-line there you go has to move
over to E2 and uh all you need to do is
create a bridge for your king to hide
behind and The Rook is going to be that
perfect barrier and just as luck would
have it it's on the perfect one right
so the king steps up to C2 Rook gives
check because it has to otherwise the
pawn is going to promote and up the king
comes to B3 and here the magic starts to
happen because once after checking side
steps to C3 A3 doesn't really matter
that's not the point and once again
check is forced nothing for it and this
is the whole point the king steps up to
B4
and uh please note the king the white
king is far away from the action cannot
catch the B2 Pawn at all and so when The
Rook comes to give check on B7
you say aha have a special weapon there
and uh Rook to B5 and there you go zero
one Magnus will win the game
nice explanation there you cannot stop
the pawn for promoting so as soon as the
king leaves that B1 Square white has to
give the checks otherwise the pawn goes
forward so we might see something just
like this we see Rook C5 played Rook
check King B3 I mean we really might
have shown the rest of the game at this
point because uh Parham he brings his
Rook to D6 that doesn't change anything
the king should go up the board
to help this Pawn go forward and King
A2
trying to
push that pawn through
yeah
and
I'm really I'm expecting
a resignation any second now from Para
because this is in everybody's
in-game Survival Guide manual whatever
they know it inside out
yeah this is one of these end games you
don't need div Risky's manual for like
this is uh well ingrained in the
player's uh Minds yeah and a check I
think they're gonna see it
at what point will param go enough's
enough you know the technique
he's gonna play it out and I earlier I
agreed with you I thought it was going
to be a draw in a couple moves now that
we got here why resign until the bridge
is built show the audience the fans
a lesson let's learn with Magnus and
Parham and we're showing you the
technique the king is cut off which is
very very important if the king had been
able to get in front of the pawn it
would have been a drop but it's not
meant to be the Lucina and the fidor are
the two Rook end games every player
needs to have very true because once you
learn the technique you have it for life
and you know that if you get this
position where the king being cut off
the black king with the pawn you're just
gonna escort it up the board and we are
going to get this position where the
King goes to B1 the pawn to B2 and the
only thing that white will be able to do
is to keep the Rook behind the pawn and
black will then be able to check the
king build a bridge and win the game
yeah and uh Harum
thinking hard
but it's beyond salvation and I agree
you definitely need to know these uh
fundamental end game positions in fact
you should have as many as you can
actually collect them like you would
cards or trophies or whatever because
then you can use this as signposts when
you're playing in an end game and it
will just help you just take those Split
Second decision decisions
foreign
good idea for sure you know just work on
this have it for life and with this win
we know Magnus is going to win this game
he is going to jump into a tie with
Wesley so he is going to be one point
behind Notre back Abdus atarov and we've
seen this story before Magnus Carlson
looking out of it losing two games early
that we haven't seen in a long time but
you know not looking like he's competing
for first and then going on a winning
streak so he has gone on a tear in
recent rounds he has beat Richard report
uh that game was one where it looked
like Richard was sacrificing all his
pieces and it wasn't panning out uh he
is going to beat Parham here with the
black pieces he beat Fabiano caruana
with the black pieces
if
Magnus
plays like this the rest of the way
who knows what can happen
yeah exactly and Magnus is exactly like
that and my goodness me they are
literally playing out the Lucina
position
we've actually got a case of deja vu we
just indicated this
just for the benefit of our viewers but
the players are spoiling us and they're
showing us how it's done
if the king actually moves to C3 the
black king will just move to C1 and the
King has shelter and there we have it
param does indeed resigned and Magnus
wins and now joins Wesley so in third
place
and you can see that look on parm's face
some disappointment there but also the
look of what could I do Magnus is gonna
Magnus and when Magnus Carlsen is in
form and they see the players analyzing
the game talking about uh possible
variations here uh Magnus making that
hand gesture that was unclear and look
at poems like you want to look at it and
there is a rest day tomorrow so for para
maksudlu he is somebody who is hungry
for knowledge he really wants to improve
he was here as a last second replacement
being able to analyze with the world
champion that's a treat he's not going
to be happy with the result because when
Parham is playing his best chess with
the white piece against Magnus there's
no reason why he has to lose the game
but this was as we see all the comments
trickling in here the goat is back
Magnus Carlson he's going beast mode
yeah he's going beast mode and someone
else who I think is going to go beast
mode any minute now is gukesh is he is
on the cusp of defeating pregnant under
so his position has been completely won
for a while but now it's completely over
there's almost nothing to be done
and it feels like there's going to be
even a checkmate
yeah sorry I pulled up the old game
between gooketch and Parham so that was
a game from the past but it's looking
kind of like the game we have here where
the king is being hunted and checkmated
this will be gosh the second win of the
tournament where he goes after his
opponent's king and he is a piece ahead
and there is no attack whatsoever from
Prague this is just a clean extra piece
with an attack yeah I mean just look at
what's King's safe as houses and uh also
I'm just taking a look at the fact that
Black's King is cut off by the bishop so
the first move that just Springs to mind
hit the queen on G5
threaten Checkmate on H5
and force resignation because you're
just gonna gang up on that poor pawn and
queen G5 on the board
Prague moves his Queen to F3 still no
checks well there's a check on D1 so you
just need to take slight care about that
but that can be okay resolved I'm
thinking F6 is what I'm thinking
oh
it's even more forceful at the moment
just pushing through because if the
queen takes then the H5 Pawn is dropped
and he goes Facebook H4 no not an issue
Queen D1
Spike check
on the board cash sit back down and play
out the checkmate
yes and when you want is just one check
and King B2 there's no more checks after
that and resignation occurs gukesh wins
and the players immediately start
talking about the game and you can see
that look on their face like well what
would have happened if I made this move
they have so much to go over yovi yeah I
mean I have to say this game was abound
with complications I mean it really went
backwards and forwards like a roller
coaster it to us it looked like
pragnanda was clearly winning out of the
opening but one false step one wrong
step and that was it the cash turned it
around and uh what a battle by these two
young Indians
and kukesh he had a terrible start to
this tournament now he's doing not half
bad right he's losing some rating but he
is cutting into uh that rating loss and
he is having a respectable showing with
a couple wins to his name I believe he
moves to four out of ten so good for him
it's great to see that after his really
rough start uh where it just seemed like
uh in any tournament there was a quote
unquote punching bag right it was the
people will gang up on and try to beat
kukash is saying I am not that person I
am not that player and I'm gonna take
down a couple big names so he wins that
leaves us with two games remaining games
between Jordan Von Forrest against
Vincent kymer and Kevin carwana against
argentinaire geisi so Fabi and Arjun by
the way I think that one
they're still maneuvering I don't think
any progress has been made they're
simply shuffling the pieces backwards
and forwards there is a standoff there's
lockdown in the position and neither
side can make any progress
I I suspect the bishop was simply
Retreat back to where it came from and
look at that
yeah they've been a MasterCard shuffling
you know if you need to learn how to
ensure the draw is made this is a good
example Fabi putting his Knight back on
D2 if the Queen ever took it C5 was
loose and he goes right back to F3 and
the bishop back to C6 The Rook back and
forth so you were right
Arjun takes no risk he says why should I
and it looks like he is solidly oh draw
offer draw greed this game has a split
point and that's a very fair result
absolutely I mean it is what it is both
sides just played exceptionally well and
uh there you can see the players
analyzing sharing their thoughts
this is so nice to see I have to have to
say how Fabi is also willing to give his
information and uh Arjun also
just suggesting some moves
yeah just you're talking about maybe a
position with more life to it some
chances but these players they've
actually competed against each other
quite a bit online uh they've also
played in quicker time controls and now
getting that classical experience is our
generic I see he had that big big
sponsorship you could see it on his
blazer from Quant box 1.5 million
dollars I believe over the course of
five years so you know he is somebody
who you'll be seeing for a long long
time he can focus on his chest and
anyway for Fabiano he's still at a plus
score I feel like he kind of needs this
after the tough turbulent 2022 he had he
finished with a silver excuse me a
bronze medal I should say in the world
rapid Championship that was a nice end
to his year but he
gave away many rating points in
classical chess
yeah and when you have such a
cataclysmic year you do want to recover
the points and you do want to kind of
stabilize steady the ship and so that
you can restore some of your lost
confidence because I don't care you know
you could be as cheerful as you like
your confidence will still take a
battering and there's the Arbiter
stepping in telling the players
no you have to leave
you have to let the other players
continue with their games and once again
we can see the hustle and bustle of
everyone playing chess at the Tata steel
chess Festival
four hours and change into this round
still so many people in the playing Hall
are great to see that and all be great
to see is just three days from now you
should mark your calendars because we
have special event coming your way the
bullet brawl Arenas are coming back to
your screen starting January 28th title
players will compete in a two hour arena
with twenty five hundred dollars on the
line watch as your favorite streamers
battle out in monthly bullet brawl
Arenas starting Saturday use the command
brawl in the chat for all the details
well there's only one match remaining
here in the 10th round of Italian
Masters it is Jordan van Forest against
Vincent kymar we'll see if the 2021 top
still Champion is able to secure the
full point on the other side of this
short break we'll be right back
interested in becoming a chess streamer
like your favorite creators such as
Hikaru Gotham chess and the botan
sisters come on
come is excited to announce the
community streamer program
whether you're just getting started with
streaming or already established and
looking to expand your audience you can
now connect your account to chess.com
and have your stream promoted on the
game's largest platform
simply link your account at chess.com
settings slash connected accounts set
your category to chess on Twitch and
start streaming you'll get an ad free
experience on chess.com you will pop up
on our list of live streamers your
trust.com profile will feature your
Twitch stream
and your stream will be linked to your
games on our play server type command
Community streamer in chat and start
growing your stream today
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
Hall in Vikings a some people have never
left that includes Jordan Von forest and
Vincent kymer they are the two players
in the masters section that are still
playing their game because we've had
four draws some of them were actually
quite a melee but down on the bottom you
see
Gucci with white and Magnus Carlson Yobe
that was another spectacular a very
magnus-esque display
yeah I have to say it was an exemplary
game from Magnus the very instructive
and uh poor Parham you know he didn't
seem to have a chance especially when
the queens were traded
and uh yeah this leaves just one game
left you between Jordan and Vincent and
shall we have a look at the new
leaderboard
for sure well some things never change
and that's already recorded in first
place Anish Gary's still a half Point
behind but Magnus Carlson I mean he is
chasing down the players ahead of him he
is now a six out of ten he won with the
black pieces which means after the rest
day he'll get the white pieces and he
can continue his climb his Ascent Wesley
so tie with Magnus and then the game
that we have left is between players who
are sort of towards the bottom of the
standings Jordan run Forrest Vincent
kymer three and a half and three points
respectively out of their first nine but
something has changed in this game which
was shocking as we went to break we
looked and Jordan was up a pawn when we
left now he's down upon so yovi we were
talking about dealing with Bishop takes
H3 way back when he took care of it with
F4 and at this moment he played King H2
and Bishop takes H3 still happened that
is a beautiful tactical shot
yeah it is beautiful it's also very
unfortunate for young Jordan and I I'm
sure he must have been kicking himself
because he's getting ready in grinding
out this game and now suddenly his
position just falls about just look how
Black's forces all spring out into the
open and unfortunately King takes Bishop
does not help one bit because of Queen
d8 and yeah pin and win
exactly just to show everybody that pawn
takes each other is out of the question
because Knight F3 check is such a nasty
move you have to take now you can
Checkmate if you don't and after Rook
takes the queen takes the enemy Queen on
D2 with check to boot you're winning
more pieces uh so instead he took with
the King after Rook d8 you just want
Queen G6 back and won this Knight on the
spot and after this you'll be he's up
upon like how did this happen he went
Rook F5 did Jordan he could have traded
Queens on his own but look at this
Knight and compare it to this bishop
good night bad Bishop uh probably not a
desirable end game from Jordan's
perspective
no
and uh you can actually just see that in
the camera you can see Jordan's body
language he is so annoyed with himself
and earlier on I was talking about how
it didn't seem like it was Vincent's
tournament you know he had promising
position against ding didn't manage to
convert it also yesterday he had this
long and brutal ending against nordibeck
what I was thinking I kid you not the
most complicated Rick and pawn ending
I've ever seen in my life and uh talking
about rook and pawn endings uh we see
there's one on the board as you've
highlighted and uh Vincent once again is
one porn up and he will be trying to
massage that Victory I mean how feasible
is this one
great question I mean let's think about
how you can possibly win this game a
rook trade would be very bad for white
because black is upon a head and you'd
be able to trade off this G Pawn for
either your H or epon use your remaining
Pawn as a decoy and Sprint your king
over towards the other side of the board
so what would that look like let's just
say if uh King F6 and you move King back
and just to sort of show what that is
this king is very close to this pawn and
the white king is going to come up and
grab the H Pawn but here
I actually think that you might have to
go back first surprisingly if you're F5
let's see yep that's a mistake because
after F5 and King here
the white king is actually in time to
make contact with the F5 Fawn as the
black king goes after G3 so uh a long
and short of it is the King goes back
only to go forward in a moment you play
F6 the king drops back you play King G6
you trade off one of your pass pawns or
sorry not the pawn is passed but you
trade off this Pawn you're left with
this one and eventually your king will
Dart over to the other side while the
white king deals with the F pod it's a
bit far away it's down the line but it's
instructive to note that as long as
you're up that one Pawn the white king
will be tied down and the black king
will take advantage of the other side of
the board yeah just to piggyback on this
particular position I just wanted to
mention that the technique to win this
is actually to keep the F Pawn as far
back as it possibly can and the reason
why is because it will be a distraction
for the white king it's something to
handle meanwhile the black king will
Dash over to the a pawn and uh gobble
that one up for lunch
yes because if the white king could take
a pawn over here all you need to do and
this is very very far down the line and
quite instructive I would say for our
audience who's not so familiar with end
games let's say this black king gets the
pawn uh we're gonna just go for that
variation and go this way and go for the
pawn directly in this position
the white king happens to be too far
away yes you're in the square of the
pawn that's the good news the bad news
is the black king has just shouldered
your king out you are not getting in
here if you go this way I'm not pushing
my Pawn I'm moving my king up because as
long as I keep your king out of these
squares I'm gonna win the game one more
still going up and now the a pawn is
free to run down the board sprinting the
other side and becoming a queen the
white king not quite in time because
once it's A3 it's protected and there we
go so it's you know we're Deep In The
Weeds of an end game that's not going to
happen but the point is these top
players they know what trades are
permissible what trades are losing and
so they are going to if you're Vincent
maximize the potential trade pressure
your opponent and if you're Jordan you
know what to avoid
yeah exactly and uh golden rule number
one is do not trade into a king and pawn
ending
and uh okay but in light of that and
then lies of the fact that Vincent is
probably gonna bully Jordan with that
trade he's gonna keep offering it at
every opportunity
um
is it possible for the black king to
take a step up
and uh try to get to the golden fifth
rank
I think yeah you can bring King up and I
guess so we know that we want to trade
Rook so if we could somehow play rookie
to somewhere here that'd be great but if
our King is on the sixth rank I feel
like that is not what we're either
because as soon as this Rook leaves if
the king's in the sixth rank there will
be a check along the sixth rank as well
so we need to time it perfectly in a way
and for Jordan you need to keep that
idea in your pocket of how do I give
some checks so all right let's just make
something let's say we went G4 he didn't
even allow me to move the king if you're
King G6
what's our next plan Rook
somewhere
do we stay where do we go
yeah that's the big question well well
now the pawn has moved to G
five yeah I guess you just wait if
you're what if you're
if you're white just root D let's say
root D5 and we actually have a few moves
he didn't choose to go King G6 instead
put his Rook on G6
mm-hmm
okay
so what is the idea are you stopping any
pawn pushes with G5 that's clearly the
trade into that Rook end game that I was
like King and Pawn in the game that we
said was going to be a win for black and
he would love to get Rook G5 on his own
if you release with your Rook
immediately Rook G5 happens you see the
eval bar goes all the way down black
wins a second pawn and then we'll win
the game with that pass Pawn so it's
clear that Jordan has to keep his Rook
on this fifth Rank and unfortunately
there's no Rook G5 check because once we
swap the white king wins that pawn there
so Yogi just feels like black is just a
teeny bit too slow
yeah it does feel like that and
and there we see the Rook moving to D6
why not
um
and the big question is do you trade
phones would you go G4 G5
or would you just kind of continue with
the equilibrium and just move the Rook
to E5 keep waiting
it's a really good question and I think
the answer is Maybe not immediately
apparent on what to do because G5 it
liquidates and oftentimes rook and pawn
versus Rook just those pieces will be a
draw so if the a pawns are off the board
and we trade G and H pawns then it's
just immediately a draw and both players
know that but the downside of trading
the g-pawn so quickly is that then black
doesn't have as many targets of his own
to worry about so in the current Dynamic
the H6 Pawn needs defending the F Pawn
is also isolated so we'll need some help
and that means that the black king can't
just run over to the other side of the
board because then white will start
targeting Black's pawns on the king side
so G5 liquidates in a way that I think
means there are fewer targets but also
gets you that one step closer to rook
and pawn versus Rook if you're able to
find that as your solution
and uh oh you're done in fact does go
for the g45 I I think it was a very
tempting decision especially in light of
the game's history where Jordan did
blunder he did have the advantage
beforehand and now
I'm guessing if especially if I were in
his shoes I would just be eager to get
this game over with I want it done
dusted I just want to enjoy the free day
and yeah talk this one up to a learning
experience
and for Vincent on the flip side of this
right he's was worse throughout this
game he was the one who was down upon
and now he's savoring the moment and
saying let's not just make a draw yet uh
let's try and by let's let me he's
talking to himself in this uh equation
let me try to win a game that looked
unwinnable but now I'm upon ahead and
I'm sure part of it is that he fumbled
away what was a difficult but findable
win yesterday very deep into the end
game when he was exhausted and had
already been calculating for many many
hours but you I think that plays a part
where if he didn't have that game
yesterday he might be more likely to
just ah let's just call it a day but
there's no reason to he's up a pawn he
has a free hand here why not
yeah he has to remind he has to ride the
momentum when he can
oh and uh Vincent he's taking his time
he's well known for taking time when he
gets to the end game he wants to work
out absolutely everything perfectly and
just make sure he's playing precise
chess which is very very important in
the end game you must hurry but never
rush
I love that that's saying that's really
good uh Vincent 46 minutes on his clock
and well some people may not be familiar
with Vincent kymer he is a teenager from
Germany he is one of the strongest
Junior players in the world he's won the
very prestigious grandkid open that's
where he kind of came onto the scene
where he was finished in first place as
an I am ahead of many many Grand Masters
that field was loaded and so before the
event there was an interview with
Vincent kymer a profile of him so we'd
like to show you that before we get back
to the chess
it was very nice seeing that at least in
Rapid I could also beat world class
players but I don't think that this has
to do too much with classical just
simply because in classical chess is
much much harder to win games and here
also I think everyone is a bit more
solid most chess players train more or
less only for the classical just so
that's like what you do most for of
course if I see that like in two weeks I
will have the world dropping templates I
will also try to focus on that but in
general classical chess is still the
main part I don't know for me I really
liked chess 960 always in the sense that
it's basically chess without too much
opening preparation but it's still the
normal chest I would say if your chess
player quite used to having many people
in the room maybe not that many
Spectators but still many people in the
room and normally at the start of the
game you kind of maybe realize what's
going on around you but during the game
you're I would say at least for me quite
focused and don't realize too much
what's going on around you
[Music]
Vincent Carmer a fan of Chess 960. so he
likes to fish a random chest that takes
preparation away from the game yovi do
you like Fisher random and what's your
experience like in that variant
I I have I have to say I'm very limited
in my experience I've only played it
twice I think um I first played it in
mines there was a big chess 960 festival
and that was very interesting to say the
least because it's the first time I saw
all the chess players just pile into the
playing Hall in order to get there early
you know as soon as the board is up
everyone was getting to their pieces to
their board and just sitting there
trying to work out what happened and I
remember the very first time I looked at
it I was like whoa isn't white just like
winning here and it's
yeah but you know I did very well in
this tournament I came first in the
women's so I thought okay hang on a
second I could be quite good at this and
then afterwards um I played it a few
years ago and I I followed Wesley's
advice you know he gave some certain
advices like for instance lengthen your
Bishops uh try to take as much space as
possible and once you kind of follow
those two rules the game actually
becomes
a little bit easier to navigate but it
is a lot of fun I have to say
I've always loved 960. fisherm chess is
you know so fun for me because I don't
like opening Theory I have never liked
opening Theory so to hear Vincent kymer
express the same Wesley actually has
been very vocal about this he loves
Fisher random because I think a lot of
these players they get tired of playing
the Berlin defense over and over again
and that's their choice they can play
different openings but I do think that
it just is refreshing for them so I
believe if they played let's say
classical tournaments a grueling one
like Vikings a but then got to play
Fisher random a little bit after that I
feel like more Fisher random is a good
thing I do believe the chess public
wants that I'm not saying to replace uh
the standard position of Chess but I do
think the top player is they would feel
a little bit more relaxed refreshed and
ready to go for classical chess if it
went back and forth versus always seeing
classical and traditional chess I should
say I do think that there's room in the
market for all the different type of
variants and uh speaking about Chess
variants I recently in December I went
to London and I went to see the chess
boxing for the very first time in my
life and I have to say you know I've
seen many many situations where chess
has been like available to the public
but I have never seen anything quite
like that I've never been in a little
Arena where people are just chanting
chess chess chess
and you could kind of feel the air
pulsate with this energy and the
weirdest thing happened was that the
crowd began to sense when the chess
boxer had made a mistake even though I
have to say most of the crowd were not
chess players at all they instinctively
knew you know they were like no it's a
mistake you blundered I was like you
don't know how to play no like I don't
know what's happening
that's so
it's an incredible experience I don't
know have you have you been to a chess
boxing event oh I went to the huge one
in Los Angeles uh one that Ludwig put on
uh that was there in Andrea botes she
fought against Dina uh it was phenomenal
to be there I mean the atmosphere was
just wild just so many fans some of them
like you're saying they didn't really
know chess but they could sense by the
help of the um commentators and just to
the eval bar always helps but yeah the
environment was so different than your
traditional hushed chess event where
everyone has to remain silent because
you want to allow people to think and as
a chess player myself and I think I'll
speak for you as well we like silence
when we play chess right like we want to
be able to think clearly uh but I do
believe that that fun atmosphere gets
more and more people into the game so
chess boxing there will be more events
I've heard that there are plenty to come
and it's uh exciting to see more and
more interest in the game
yeah definitely and anything that gets
people into chess
is is a bonus for me and uh
and
there we see Vincent doing very smart
things with this King he's maneuvering
it to get it into the center get it into
the middle of the battle and put Jordan
you know his his King is cut off
I I feel like Vincent has already made
some small gains
yeah small gains but the problem is he
can't keep the king cut off because if
he releases from the sixth rank then
Jordan will go ahead and win the A6 Pawn
so he is going to have to budge or his
Rook over it then the king can continue
sliding and it just feels like a
position where unfortunately for Vincent
he needs to keep an eye on his pawns so
he can't just do whatever he wants and
Jordan run Forrest he's been here before
we heard his profile he's been coming to
Vikings agency he was 10 years old he
won the event in 2021 and this is the
85th Anniversary it's commonly referred
to as the Wimbledon of Chess even though
the Australian Open is the Grand Slam
underway but it's been the home of a top
level tournament since 1968 has Vikings
a and I just love the list of Champions
we have on screen here many more
including Jordan Von Forest but some
people they get their start because
they're the teenagers playing against
the veterans others you know find their
breakout tournament uh here as veterans
finally winning this event for Anish
Geary you would like to be the second
Dutchman over the last few years to win
that title but
he wants to add his name to that list so
so badly
yeah he does and uh gosh I mean that is
one history history behind an event
1938 and and as far as I know it's kind
of started off like a local tournament
and from from there it just completely
just built up into something different
where every player who's going through
the ranks who's wants to be in the
history books has to play in this event
and uh there you see the who's who of
tournament victories evictus and Magnus
Carlsen he's he's eight time winner
and I think they've told him that if he
wins 10 times he'll get the tour the the
trophy
gold-plated or something like that I uh
something special will happen if he wins
10 times at least I thought I thought
you were gonna say if he wins 10 times
he's not invited back anymore you know
you stop winning this event Magnus give
other people a chance go away uh but a
gold-plated trophy that's pretty cool
too
yeah it is pretty cool and uh I have
brought up my table base
yesterday there was no table base but
today there is a seven piece table base
it's how's your polish
Roberts it's polish it's non-existent
yeah it's a 60 uh table base which you
can find on chess.com actually and uh
it's the beauty of this is actually that
you can just follow the game live and
then when it there's a table base up for
grabs you can just click on it but of
course there can only be seven pieces
left on the board for the computers to
have worked it all out and guess what
the table base is saying
yeah
it's a draw okay so certain moves loose
but basically they're kind of
self-explanatory so the moves that we'll
lose is basically if the Rook moves
itself from the fifth row and other
losing moves I quite like it with a
table base just suggests it like Rook B5
and you're like I don't think that I
don't think that's ever gonna happen
because a pawn takes rig
um everything else destroys
yes and it's losing moves as you said
self-explanatory because if the Rook
leads the fifth rank then Black's Rook
goes up to D5 with check and wins the A5
pawn two split pass pawns this isn't
bowling where I went bowling last night
you know you got to split and it's the
end of the world split pass pawns are
actually a good thing in chess because
the white pieces the forces they're
going to be dragged in different
directions and it's gonna be too much to
handle so uh black would love to win
this on A5 over here not going to happen
so for Jordan he does need to be careful
he can't take the situation for granted
he needs to calculate and make sure that
he's everything under his control uh but
if he just move his King backside to the
E4 Square keeping the fifth rank uh
available to this Rook over here I feel
like he has everything handled at the
moment
yeah I agree and uh
you you my mind is occupied now with
bowling thanks Robert and the splits
because I have seen it done before where
they they twist the ball and they
managed to get one and then the other
one it's uh a thing of beauty when you
see the pros sit there and do bowling I
don't know do you play bowling do you
what do you do you you're a bowler ball
yeah
yeah but it's a good question because
you're not
you don't play bowling this is just you
both I don't know it has its own verb so
I I do like bowling I think it's a very
fun activity I think that you're in
front Forest would love to be bowling
right now anything but sitting at this
chessboard defending uh because he knows
that if visit convert wants to keep this
game going
is going to have to sit and wait for the
game to conclude and he still needs to
be a bit careful because if black is
able to get this Rook up to the fifth
rank let's just show a losing potential
variation for uh White like if the king
hops back and the black king goes up and
we start moving like this we're not
losing yet but we're getting into
territory that's looking shaky um and
actually I'm gonna put a different move
on just because I'm curious now if I
give this check
and you move your king somewhere like up
to E5 and I go before I okay I was
correct Rook B5 is a deadly threat I'm
not only threatened to exchange the
Rooks into a winning King opponent game
but I'm trying to just win this Pawn
directly over here on A5 so if you bring
your king up to F6 I have Rook B5 and
you see the evaluation bar saying that's
not good that is a win for black because
once I win this Pawn on A5 and you take
on F7 the black Rook can even cut this
king off uh with Rook on the fifth rank
but I can also just put my Rook probably
anywhere honestly yeah I'm right and
then the a pawn will go up and the king
is totally cut off yeah and when it
comes to the a pawn I mean they're the
worst type of passports and so you have
to remember the rule of five
uh if you can cut the King five square
five rows away from the pawn it is a win
a good thing to store in your in-game
Technique manual uh you want to be able
to cut that King off many rows and here
that King is way way way too far and
just to show you what that looks like
King F6 uh your King's not getting any
closer let's push for our a pawn okay
let's get a rook in front of the pawn
but now that your Rook has left the C
file that gives black room to start
running I wouldn't go King C6 just yet
because it does allow the king to get
closer I would start with King D6 The
Rook goes up to A2 we're sitting and
waiting
um maybe I made a mistake maybe he
actually has to go to C6 anyway so I got
like I thought I'd go King C5 I just
lose the pawn so I'll go King over the
King goes here and very importantly is
you keep this King cut off on the fifth
rank usually the king is cut off in a
file here is cut off on the rank so the
king cannot go where it needs to back
towards the pawn and this king is gonna
go to B5 and play A4 so the black king
just helps escort the pawn of the board
and there's no way for white to deal
with it
oh and uh Jordan stepping back with the
King
so there is danger lurking under the
surface and uh that's basically the oh
the plan that Robert showed and it's the
only plan for Vincent to progress
needs to get that Rook to B5 The Rook
could just get there right now it would
be a good situation although if you went
there immediately it would backfire so
just to
uh make that happen just because it's
always fun to show bad variations The
Rook B5 now you're going to see how you
lose the game because the Rook trade is
available since white promotes and the
black king is not in the Square after A6
the king would have to be
over here inside the square but the king
is too far away so White's Pawn gets the
other side
very instructive and uh sometimes when
it comes to well basically when it comes
to kingponents it's just a question of
counting you really are going there with
your fingers this was this move goes
here and it's just to get back to those
Basics I'll highlight it there
laughs
don't be ashamed of making that gesture
even sit there like this
okay and we see a rick come give a check
on E6 and Jordan very crucially keeps
the King on F4 and he definitely needs
the king to guard against the F7 Pawn
right because I think a lot of people
will be tempted to bring the king up to
a square like D5 but once that King is
here the F Pawn is free you may not want
to push it immediately but you have that
opportunity and you can also bring your
king over and this Rook does cut off the
king the A6 Pawn seems better defended
and if you make a careless move let's
say Rook somewhere back on the C file
Here Comes F6 with Rook E5 check
scooping up this Pawn on A5 and if your
King has to try to defend it you can't
even do that because you can't touch the
C file without losing your Rook so
essentially you're setting yourself up
for a losing situation where your king
is cut off from the f-pawn there's also
the threat of rookie five check winning
that a pawn two different past pawns
that's too much to handle so uh still
some care and Jordan
it feels like he knows exactly what he's
doing what's neat of him here you'll be
he's just playing simple moves quickly
and I think that he just really is like
come on please let me make this draw but
there's just no reason why Vincent
should do that he should bring his King
over I think bringing his King over to
uh D7 looks good because then the A6
Pawn is Untouchable so he wants at some
point to be able to get his Rook to the
fifth rank it's a bit of a journey but
that is what he's looking for
yeah I mean this is the beauty of his
position Vincent will be moving at
snail's pace but it's good enough you
know he will try you know I agree put
the King on D7 the pawn on F6 move the
Rook to C6 try to slowly inch forward
into the position and try to squeeze
Jordan and
you're done definitely on the back foot
he has to play accurately
but again according to the database this
is still very much a draw
and it's hard to go wrong for the most
part unless you allow the black king to
sort of venture towards the queen side
and then you get this Rook to the fifth
rank that you see exactly what Black's
plan is and if you go King D6 running
towards the rook and The Rook slides
away somewhere the question is where
because I believe if you go Rook F5
yeah I was gonna say I think that might
be the wrong so it was F6 and Rook E5
won't be available right away but your
plans are King E7 and then bring your
Rook over and white is frozen if you go
King to F3
King E7 now rookie five is a winning
threat so King F4 and after rookie two
we go to the other plan of bringing our
Rook this way so if you go Rook to H5 I
think that you can bring your Rook on
over this way or maybe Actually I don't
even need to bring my Rook I'll bring my
king up first and then bring my roof to
E5 and I'm winning the A5 Pawn so there
actually is more teeth to the position
that I initially realized yo but I
thought it was going to be simple but
that's why Vincent's playing it out like
there's plenty of room for Jordan to go
wrong yeah definitely and the key seems
to be in keeping the white Rook active
like you don't want to put it on F5
where it's not that great you want to
maximize its use
and again we see Vincent making some
moves Rook F5 actually on the board
still okay
he can get away with it for now I think
because the king is not on D6 when the
King was on D6 that's what we were
analyzing that Rook F5 F6 now it's a
problem seriously what is the difference
it's the same exact position right why
is one winning one isn't the difference
is the King's placement after King D7 if
you play F6 The Rook can give a check on
D5 it came with a D6 before there would
have been no check and once this King
runs through a square like C6 then The
Rook can Venture up the board to d8 this
is actually very tricky I'm getting
flashback to yesterday's game which you
commentated with Dania where there's let
me just look for a second I'm gonna pick
up the table base because it's if you go
to chess.com events look on the right
side of this game it's right there
oh my gosh Rook Disney oh I made that
move just like to make it Rook date was
the only move that draws
wow every other move loses for white
okay
that's that's not an easy one
to kind of spot because you could also
think well you know I'm going to put the
Rook on H5
maximize it along the
the fifth row
but why does this lose I guess because
you go Rook E5
all right took us out of the uh now
that's okay H5 over here uh well rookie
five I guess we trade because the king
is gonna be close to get to the corner
but maybe we just release again we go
down here and you can't play Rook F5
because I check you in trade Brooks
there and that seems to be winning just
because the king now is one square
farther away and the black king goes and
we've seen this before with the King
ushers the pawn
okay
okay so it's all to do with this ability
to give the black king a check
seems like that is to be able to cut
yeah that's that is the that's why you
need to go to Rook d8 so you can go to
Rook B8 and cut the king off
that's
so instructive once again Vincent
climber he's uh teaching us some in-game
knowledge
just like look at how close this is Rook
D5 a king goes up this already looks
problematic uh for white and let me
bring up the tail base one second
oh my gosh only one move draws here for
what this is why the evaluation bar if
you're sitting at home and even us
sometimes as commentators we just rely
on the evil or oh it's equal but I'm
looking at the table base which all of
you can use yourselves on chess.com
events the right side of the screen
there
um and Rook F5 is the only move that
draws it keeps the black Rook Frozen and
so that holds oh all right well this is
honestly so much to work through if you
are Jordan Von Forest he is on screen
there is going to be working through
these complications
yeah actually right now you know how
before it was like any move drawers
right now yeah only one move will draw
according to the table base
thank you
The Rook on D5
oh my goodness so so Rook D5 King C6 and
Rook d8 it's a series of only moves
getting your Rook up here and this is
not intuitive in the slightest right I
mean The Rook is away and you're
allowing the king to approach the pawn
this is the type of territory where
players lose positions that they should
be able to hold otherwise
yeah
unbelievable stuff
and uh
again you need to maintain that
connection The Rook must be able to cut
the king off
I I couldn't have uh ever predicted this
and uh Rook D5 only drawing move
anything else if you for instance put
your Rook on H5 it's just basically the
same reason that you highlighted The
Rook goes down to E1 and or E2 it's
irrelevant there which one
and then after that it's just a case of
The Rook defending the F6 pawn and the
King running over the King has been
allowed to approach this Pawn on a five
wow
yeah because it looks like you're
getting this Pawn on F6 but if you give
a rook H6 the king can even start going
to B5 you take this Pawn we have seen
this before a trade into a winning end
game for black so trade the Rooks and
just to show the end of the variation
because I think that's instructive for
everyone watching is we saw how the king
keeps the other king away you could play
A5 and if the King goes to D3 do not I
repeat do not just push your Pawn you
need to keep the enemy King out of these
squares over here so you may think that
A4 is winning but it's not King goes to
C1 and after A3 if this were any other
Pawn this would be winning uh in in many
positions but not here because it's
going to be stalemate and this would be
the case even here of course but in many
of these positions the problem is that
you don't have more room for your king
to jump in so you would be able to go
here and then if there was one more file
your king would go to over here bring it
off the board you push your Pawn but
because it's an a pawn you're you're
there's a boundary there and you have to
stay in Bound so just remember you need
to keep the enemy King away from your
pawn and then there it goes
yeah oh so tense right now
you wouldn't buy for us only one move to
save the game incredible stuff
well if you know he finds it he is well
on his way to holding this draw but it's
not going to be easy for him we've just
shown several variations that actually
lead to a winning position for black so
only a few rounds ago this is a
different note but only a few rounds ago
Magnus was saying he thought it was
unlike he would win and he now has won a
few games so here's what he had to say
when he was asked if uh the win was
still in reach
no I'm realizing that there's
um
possibilities for for that of course but
most of all I'm taking a further step to
playing a decent tournament and I've
sort of
um
turned turned it around in a good way so
I'm I'm happy with um
with that and obviously it's uh far from
in my hands still but um yeah this was
important and uh I'll keep on trying
okay you heard it from Magnus he's gonna
keep on trying and well don't try just
do what does Yoda say something like
that and he is succeeding and he is now
at six out of ten he is in a tie for
third and fourth place with Wesley so
he's been impressive
since the start when he was shaky ever
since those losses he's been really
impressive
yeah I agree and uh there we saw the
standings
um Magnus Carlson just working his way
up to third place ah
big go away
yeah he's gone for the very natural Rook
H5 and that oh my gosh is a losing move
oh the drama
okay
but it's it's a big moment now for
Vincent here okay so one of the things I
find with table bases and computer
engines in general is that does take
away some of the mystery of the players
and also the fact
that these players are working so hard
at the board they're pouring their heart
and soul into this and
these kind of mistakes I think that they
are inevitable I mean after how many
hours of play it's been an intense game
I just want to drum at home that these
people are these players are human and
also at the same time you know how does
the saying go
something is divine
and to are as human
and uh just to remember that and I I
think it's very good off very good
actually to look at this type of
position without the table base and then
afterwards come back and have a look at
how things are going and whether you
calculated well
um but yeah big big moment and it's not
easy I'm gonna stress it again it's not
easy but Vincent now has one winning try
based on the route coming to either E1
E2 and basically just releasing the king
so they can go hunting the a pawn
yes that's the key here is the king
needs to be able to run away to C6 and
it's a big moment for Vincent kymer so
you know he is going to dig deep sea if
he can find a winning plan I mean we are
helped by the evaluation bar by the
table base we can see that there is a
wind he doesn't know that so while he
works on figuring this out we are going
to head on towards a break but before we
do just want to give a shout out to an
event that is happening very soon
because the wait is over after a
two-year Hiatus the protest league is
back the 2023 season begins with a
qualifier week starting February 1st
with 16 teams advancing into the main
season pass protestly participants
include Magnus ningly red Beyond the
Palm sheet Fabiano caruana Hikaru
Nakamura and Maxine versus well as a
second place uh participant in this
field anishagiri so we could not not be
more excited for the League's return and
with over one hundred thousand dollars
on the line it's looking like the 2023
season will be one for the history books
use the command PCL in chat to learn all
about it we'll be right back for the
finish of this matchup between Vincy
kymer and Jordan Von Forest
what's the best way to follow any chess
event from the World Chess Championship
to the candidates the speed chess
championship title Tuesday and so much
more chess.com events has all of the top
chess tournaments played both over the
board and online
analyze and review games from the
world's greatest players with live
commentary cloud analysis opening
Explorer and table bases find all the
key event information including
schedules prizes results news reports
player bios tie breaks and more
you can compete by voting for your
predicted results
explorechess.com events today on web or
with our IOS and Android apps and
experience chess like never before
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
s
for this cozy coastal town the holiday
season isn't over
in fact the most wonderful time of the
year has really just begun come on gotta
make a move no no no no no no no no no
oh my God I'm speechless there
once again vikon Zay starts the new year
as the center of the chess Universe this
year as host of the 85th taught to steal
chess tournament
a magnet for the best players in the
game some recognize the Masters field of
2023 as its strongest in recent memory
of course it helps when eight-time Tata
steel chess champion Magnus Carlson is
back what a game for Magnus and now a
huge chance to make a furious run at
first place the world's number one looks
to further cement his legacy in this
event and the game's history
chasing Magnus will be amongst the best
in chess several have been crowned
Champion here before some have even
shocked the world in doing so
don't leave out those poised to capture
their first Tata title Anish Geary is
just I mean he beat both world number
one and world number two in the same
tournament
although winter Tata steel chess is also
known as the place new stars come to
bloom
Magnus one here is a teenager this
year's event has its fair share of young
players on the rise each hoping to
follow in Carlson's footsteps why
what the Dutch refer to Tata steel as
The Wimbledon of chess for 85 years in
running this tournament continues to be
steeped in Prestige and Legacy and does
so again in this welcoming Little Dutch
town by the sea
mine brynden it's the 85th edition of
the Tata steel chess tournament let's
make chess history together
[Music]
it's never over till it's over and
Jordan Von Forest still trying to defend
this Pawn down end game which before he
went to break you know if he had turned
into a winning position according to the
tail bases for Vincent kymer and a
winning position it remains objectively
speaking if the optimal moves are played
vintage Commerce will score a big
victory with the black pieces because
what he has just done I bring his King
first over to the C6 square and now back
over here is his Pawn on F6 is defended
so if black had a free turn rookie 5
would be winning going after the A5 Pawn
when a rook trade is unacceptable for
white to be a losing King and pawn end
game so Rook H5 is always meant by
rookie five takes that out of the
equation Rook F4 still met by rookie 5
winning the pawn that leaves one and
only one move King F4 but then we get to
the position we looked at before with
Rook to E1 The Rook releases defends the
f-pawn from uh in front of it and then
the black king is free to move up the
board and it looks like Jordan has
played King F4 so now the big question
Jovi is Will Vincent find Rook up to E2
or the E1 rookie one is much more
natural
yeah uh it is a big question and it's
not an easy one actually
I I don't think necessarily that rookie
won is that natural it's not that easy
to find
because primarily you know when you're
playing these type of endings first of
all you kind of want to just
test things out here there everywhere
and then when you're pushed to your last
limit then you kind of make a move like
Rook E1
I think it's more natural for the king
to come forward but uh
of course Vincent is very very capable
of finding rookie one and uh seeing the
idea of just coming forward with the
King
and then back with the Rook to E5 so The
Rook is really just making space for the
king and very importantly in these
variations the black king is shielded
from Chucks because if White had a free
turn Rook H7 check would be a problem
because after Rook H7 The Rook swings
around to the A7 square and A6 is
dropped so by playing King E6 Rook H7 is
met by the immediate Rook E5 thank you
very much for this pawn and rookie five
is pre-movable right this move can be
played next to go and win this Pawn over
on A5 unless you bring your Rook to a
defensive posture trying to defend
Heroes of Rook E5 there is the move Rook
A2 this should still be winning uh for
black because now it's very defensive
The Rook is perfectly placed and then
the black king and then go Venture on
over to the queen side likely Help win
this spawn over here so I think Vince is
doing everything right yeah rookie one
is an important move here but it also
makes sense with his game plan bringing
the Rook back to E5
yeah definitely it makes a lot of sense
and Vincent thinking hard
is
it's very logical
and uh it's this is one of the things
about Chess is that even though you
might not play the move you do tend to
sense when the moment is critical and
there we saw a change in body language
from Vincent
he kind of leaned forward into the
position
and uh once again he finds himself
again very complicated Pawn ending
yeah he I hope he loves end games
because he's been seated at engines for
hours and hours and hours determined he
lost one to Magnus Carlson early in the
event he drew that game yesterday
against Abu sitarov when he did have the
upper hand and now he can score a
victory at long last against Jordan van
forest and something I just noticed is
there's there are other players in the
playing Hall not in the master section
but the challengers we see vaishali uh
probably not a sister a very very strong
player International Master she is
playing right behind Vincent kymer on
the screen and she's been doing quite
well in the challengers tournament uh so
good luck to her and her game
um you know she's playing it looks like
abimaju Mishra the youngest Grandmaster
in history so that's a
a big matchup in the Challenger section
but we will remain focused here in the
Masters in this game between Jordan and
Vincent and Vincent
he is trying to find the correct path
for it he does not want to let his
Advantage slip my big question Jovi is
do you think he believes he's winning
here that's the question I'm always
curious about when I see a player with
an advantage is
do they think oh it should be a draw or
do you think that at this point he's
like I should be able to win this game
my
variance with talking to some of the
world's best players is that they rarely
think in black and white terms they
really think okay I'm winning here I'm
losing here I'm much much better they
just look a few moves ahead they're
actually thinking about their objectives
so right now I suspect that kaimer is
thinking actually I want to release my
king I want my king to go somewhere and
this actually takes a lot of the
emotional pressure from the position
because if you say I'm winning then you
have this big expectation that you're
winning and this of course causes one to
perhaps take longer on the moves feel
something if things go wrong meanwhile
if you just okay let me just talk about
the mini plans for step one activate the
rook and then mobilize my king then
make small steps towards the big goal of
capturing on A5 then they uh you know
then you can think about winning the
game but
I just think it's very very helpful not
to attach any value onto positions as
such
I think it's well said and we've stated
this numerous times when you start
thinking about the result it's
subjective thinking that seeps into your
brain you need to be as objective as
possible you need to see your opponent's
resources as well as your plans so uh
for a visit kymer if he wins this game
he jumps ahead of Jordan Von force in
the standings he would move to four out
of ten which would put him in a tie with
gukesh and Parham in 10th place so
while we look at the leaderboard we know
that Abdul satar heads into the rest day
the final rest day with a lead over the
field but Anish giri is right there
behind him and Magnus Carlson and Wesley
so are also looking for Notre back to
stumble because then they can catch up
yeah
everybody is looking at playing catch up
and of course last three rounds gonna be
remaining and I have to say that the
stakes are getting higher here because
you know I've talked a lot about
emotional expectations and being able to
relax and just have the freedom to play
good chess well round 10 it's not that
far away from round 13 and you start to
see The Horizon and this is the time
when players get nervous let's not also
forget about the issue of fatigue this
is a marathon event players are giving
their 100 on the board and also off the
board let's not forget that they are
also preparing for every single game and
this will start to take its toll
it does for sure I mean the players get
exhausted sometimes when you see quick
draws in some rounds no they're back
against taking the rent today Richard
report against LeBron aronian and
looking ahead to Friday's matchups
because tomorrow is a rest day the
players will be back on Friday these are
great Magnus Carlson with the white
pieces against Wesley so pragananda and
Parham uh two players who lost today
they'll have a chance to rebound our
generic geissi he drew kukesh and won
his game so good guys actually ahead of
origin in the standings and then we just
see Levon and Fabi Vincent and Richard
Ding and Jordan and then last but
certainly not least because it's really
first the niche giri against noribbeck
abdusa tariff so
Ivanka when we look at these pairings
Magnus against Wesley the people tie for
third and fourth place Lavon against
Fabiano the people tied right behind
them and then the people in first and
second Anish Geary in second place with
the white piece against Nordic abusitara
you couldn't have scripted this better
I was gonna say that this is the the
dream pairing you know if someone's
gonna play catch-up if someone's gonna
snatch away the lead it's gonna be here
in this critical round and uh I I do
feel that this is where the class is
going to start to show
it's just like it is in a race you know
where you have your pacemaker sets the
sets the whole Pace maybe can go too
fast but uh
we will see uh it's in the player's
hands and I think it was very very smart
on motorbeck just to play
uh you know a very simple game today you
know just uh where he could can kind of
where he could he forced the draw
against ding
simple chess is good chess he has no
chance to relax recuperate and get ready
for those final three matchups
and both initi security and their back
wsatar defeated Magnus Carlson in this
event initiated with white already Rick
did it with black and usually there's a
first move advantage that is true in
chess especially at the highest levels
but Notre back has proven in several
games this tournament round one against
original report again against Magnus
Carlson against Arjun aragaisy Notre has
done very well with the black pieces so
while he's an underdog and it's going to
be tough sledding he is ahead so Anish
that's the big question with the white
pieces can he do it because after the
rest day the number two ranked player
and the leaderboard and each Gary will
take matters in his own hands to take
the number one spot when he faces off
against Norbeck here's what he had to
say about the upcoming match
yeah another box is really impressing so
far and particularly today showing uh
great experience by not playing very
ambitiously after yesterday I think this
was very wise wise decision probably
he's a very wise trainer has also
recommended him that so
yeah big challenge for me to overcome
this team of very wise people but I'll
try
okay so we heard from Anish giri and he
is going to try to take down dirty back
and as we see it's just Jordan Von
forest in the playing Hall and waiting
for visit camera to return to the board
but things are getting out of hand for
Jordan Von Force he's put up a stubborn
defense ever since he dropped the pawn
but unfortunately for him he is in a
position that objectively with the best
moves played will be winning for black
and
I feel like the plan is relatively
straightforward at this point I don't
say that lightly I don't like to make
the players tasks seem trivial because
every move does require thought but here
the plan as you were saying it's not
about am I winning it's not about is my
opponent gonna hold what is the plan
King E6 rookie five and I think Jordan's
realizing that if he goes Rook C5 now
the place King D6 and rookie five you
get a Tempo against this rook and you
don't allow it up to C6 so uh
Black's plan very straightforward right
now after rookie one
yeah and certainly it looks that way and
uh say
Jordan does lose the age the a pawn
sorry
how easy is this particular Pawn ending
or componenting I I think it's actually
quite easy because you have two separate
pawns like we were talking about earlier
white pieces they're forces will be
split across the board the king will
have to stay in front of one Pawn The
Rook can will try to deal with the other
and black has a rook and a king to help
Usher one of the pawns forward so it
just seems like a situation where you
know we can show it on the board again
if this Rook comes to H5 King E6 you're
going to drop this uh Pawn over here on
A5 if you play a little bit of Hope
Chest no I'm not going to go rookie five
and walk into a check I'll bring my king
back over here can't go Rook F5
because of the Rook trade and if you go
elsewhere with Rook H5 or say Rook C8 it
doesn't really matter because the Rook
comes to square like A1 takes this pawn
and
can't even go after this Pawn right King
F5
I take King F6 and we talked about this
before the king is cut off so I can play
Rook C5 A5 bring my king forward and go
over to my Pawn to help it promote it's
just the king is in the worst possible
position
yes I I totally agree the king should
never be cut off along the horizontal
lines like this I mean if it's stuck way
out there in no man's land it is very
rarely salvageable and I agree it does
seem straightforward
this would be kind of the easiest at
least thing for him to Envision doesn't
mean that he sees it all the way through
that he assesses it as a victory for him
because sometimes you look at a position
especially with a rook Pawn we showed
earlier in King and pawn versus King end
game there can be a draw even if the
pawn advances far uh and in Brooke and
games you're like oh that Rook Pawn
doesn't give me the best chances but
then you think the king being cut off
you always want to cut off your
opponent's king in the end game here it
is cut off along the fifth Rank and it's
now on the f file very far away so if
you try to go for this Pawn over here
and after A5 the king cannot approach if
you have this check the King goes back
it goes to B7 it forces your Rook away
from being behind this pawn and then the
Rook will slide to A5 this just
it's very clear I think I I don't really
believe this is a struggle for Vincent
after he's able to win the day five Pawn
yeah I certainly it looks that way and
Vincent looking very comfortable Jordan
struggling I think the truth is Dawning
on him and so
yeah now these these two
um the roundabout at the bottom of the
table so it's not going to affect the
leaderboard too much but well tomorrow
on the day after tomorrow it's going to
be very exciting with a niche facing off
against Abdul sitarov I mean what do you
think about each other's chances here
it's one of those matchups where
for a niche do you go all in is strong
you don't want to lose that game but do
take a risk in the opening to try to
catch your opponent off guard and win
the game obviously Niche is playing for
a win he doesn't want to allow
nordierbeck to still remain a half Point
ahead of him and he doesn't want to see
Magnus Carlson continue winning and then
catch up or even get ahead of him so
it's a situation where if he is going to
win the tournament he may need to come
up with an opening that has serious bite
to it that gives his opponent room to go
wrong we saw it needs to do that against
um uh who was it against gukesh when he
won that really wonderful game with a
vicious attack on the king side and so
anisha's victories over Magnus over cash
uh the one over ding diren was shaky
because he got caught off guard when he
had the black pieces but his victories
with the white pieces were quite nice
and he demonstrated excellent
preparation
yeah I was gonna say Anish with the
white pieces has been ferocious I mean
he's come on to the teeth with great
preparation you kind of called it his
game against kukash was fabulous you
know they were really one for the
Tactical books for the Miniatures it was
just a fantastic game his game also
against eragisi you know he caught Eric
Garcia unawares in this samislav Moran
variation I mean that one or should have
also been a victory for a niche and he
just seems Unstoppable and effortless I
have to say with the white pieces and I
forgot it forgetting the most important
one of all where he came with some
fantastic preparations some fantastic
ideas of how to handle Magnus Carlson
with the white pieces as well that was a
great game
yeah he seems to be in great form and an
East Gary brings his best to Viking Zay
it's not a far Journey for him he is the
Dutch number one uh he lives in the
Netherlands with his family so he just
gets to waltz on over to the venue he
doesn't have to take a long flight
nothing of the sort and he's an
ambassador for the event and he's been a
great Ambassador for it he does a lot of
promo you've mentioned earlier that all
of Norway kind of freezes and watches
this event and it's in the newspapers so
you know he is the spokesperson and he
lets his play do the talking we're used
to him trading barbs with Magnus on
social media and getting involved in the
latest controversies and Twitter storms
but in Vikings a it is all about his
play and another year another great
performance of anishkiri yeah I was
gonna to see
when was the last time that Anish
tweeted January 17th
that was it
oh so he's been very quiet in social
media and uh we actually see that quite
often when
Anish really wants to focus he really
wants to do well he will just go off
social media and he will just completely
immerse himself in the Chess World and
of course he's here with a different
second uh he's here with Jan Gustafson
and this combination seems to be working
very very well
has worked with magnets Carlson of
course young being a prominent
commentator an extremely strong
Grandmaster in his own right
um and well John Goodson has relevance
to this game too because John was the
captain coaching the German Olympia team
at this past Olympiad in Chennai in
2022. so Vincent and Jan undoubtedly
talked about Chess uh we went over lines
as it was needed but of course Vincent's
primary coach is Peter leco so in the
Olympiad it's sort of a territory where
if you want to work on certain lines
with a coach you need to be very
trusting of them because
when Jan comes with a niche giridor
tournament this is like wait a second I
shouldn't have talked to him about my
prep in the slav I'm just giving random
examples and just using them as a
convenient
um Duo but the point is that there is a
lot of trust in working with somebody at
the highest level and Anish Geary he's
changed seconds over time he works at
Erwin Lami who's playing in the
challengers group probably a little bit
too busy to help him on his game uh he's
worked with the other top Dutch players
in the past he's worked with
chuchulov a very famous
legendary Grandmaster
who trained Fabiana karwada as well and
also um Timor rajabov so there's
familiar faces
as a team of seconds as Trainers for the
top players and sometimes they share a
Trader which can be uncomfortable in
some moments
yes certainly can and I was kind of
curious about your experience of working
with the Olympiad team the olympiad's
open Team the US and uh you kind of
talked about how the you know you're
coaching someone but how do you coach
someone for instance or advise someone
who actually has their own regular coach
say like Vincent he works with lekka all
the time I mean what cat Yan do apart
from just provide some
uh chocolates during the game
or moral support of course
yeah it is a really good question
because uh I think there is confusion or
just lack of knowledge about what top
players do sometimes people think they
just are at their computer with the
engine on the whole time and from my
experience that's not actually what's
happening we use a physical board and
pieces because part of working on
openings is figure out how difficult is
it for my opponent to find the best
moves what would you do in this position
and so sometimes you have a clock you
sit down you press the clock and you may
put 20 minutes on it depends on how long
you have and play through positions
other times it is going deep in the
weeds of openings and if they have their
own team of seconds sometimes they just
don't work with you at all and that's
okay your job as a coach is through
what's ever in the best interest of the
player so you don't need to be fussy
when they say I actually am good on my
own great do your thing but you know
oftentimes as a coach when the players
are so strong it's not like they need uh
to learn how to do certain tactics it's
not steering them in a direction being a
shoulder uh an ear for advice where I'm
thinking about these three different
openings from the white side which
should I choose and saying okay I've
seen uh your opponent against the
English they sometimes struggle because
they don't like this transposition to
another opening or if it's a sicilian
they like that it's really combative it
suits their style so it is about
steering the game towards certain
territory and you know it's definitely a
lot of work and I don't pretend to be a
particularly an expert in that field but
it is uh really a lot of work when you
sit down with these top players because
they play Everything Under the Sun
you're not looking at one opening and
saying okay play your London system this
is not a criticism of the London system
Eric Rosen I know you're watching this
somewhere it's okay still love the
London respect for it
not a fan uh but the point is that they
place they're so versatile they play so
many different things it's never just
looking at one opening it's looking at a
handful
yeah I I can imagine I can remember in
the few times that I've played against
these super Grand Masters I have been
unable to prepare I'm like okay you guys
play everything I mean it can be E4 D4
C4 Knight F3 G3 you take your pick and
yeah that has been something that is
quite difficult to navigate and I've
just navigated it by going okay fine I
expect this and I'm gonna gamble that
this is gonna occur usually doesn't I
have to say I have been very
unsuccessful here but then there is a
freedom because you're just like okay
fine okay let's get my preparation in no
biggie let's just play the game
well this game right now it's being
played is the one where Jordan from
forest Brothers Rook to H5 King E6 Rook
E5 I feel like at this point Vincent is
quadruple checking that's the territory
he's in because he made all these moves
to get his Rook to E5 so I'm wondering
what he sees as the potential drawback
to King E6 it seems like it allows him
to execute the plan he's been going for
yeah uh I I think he's just uh making
sure you know yesterday it was a
particularly grueling round and he came
so close to snatching the point from
Nordy back and it was according to the
table bases one but I think he's just
simply
again following good old advice I mean
why do you need to rush with making the
move well after all you can just check
recheck look for the better move as we
are taught
and he could also be deciding between
King D6 and King E6
true I actually didn't think about that
King V6 looks very reasonable and in
fact let's see the table base we're
using yep King D6 is winning as well so
very good point uh that when there are
two options that look similar and try to
get the same job done of putting the
Rook on E5 it is important to be
accurate so I know I've been kind of
harping on like what's going on what's
he thinking about Rook E5 is what he
wants but there are two different ways
to go about it and both of them look
appealing the King on D6 is a bit closer
to the queen side so when you win this a
pawn you're faster to help the pawn on
A6 and King E6 keeps the F6 Pawn
defended so you don't have to worry
about it being attacked so both options
look good
oh very instructive and I agree take
your time I mean their own move 58
so
it's uh two moves away from the time
control
and he has 24 minutes
on the clock why not
use that time the only thing I would say
is that I wouldn't burn all the time in
making such a decision because he has to
leave himself something for the
remainder of the game because say for
instance he missteps here
you do want to leave yourself some time
just to find the solution should you
stumble upon it again
and we are on the 58th move for black
and a reminder that when they reach move
60 they get an additional 15 minutes on
the clock so even if Vincent spends 24
minutes on this move as long as he gets
to move 60 you'll get that 15 minutes
going into the last time control with
the 30 second increment the bonus time
from the first move of the game which
means this game is going to last a long
time if is the only one remaining here
in the Masters you can see he's really
trying to be perfect and he brought us
King to D6 so good call by you yeah I
wasn't thinking about that I was so
fixated on King E6 that I didn't even
consider this as an option initially and
it's a good one it is still winning
according to base he's playing
accurately allowing himself to play
rookie five and bring his King closer to
the a file where he is going to get a
new pass Pawn I like it
thought for Jordan
I I have to say my heart does really
just really cry for him because he had a
great opening he had a great middle game
one terrible move and then suddenly he's
defunding an unpleasant end game and now
he has to suffer here where
he kind of you can kind of feel that if
Vincent is going to take his time and
make the effort to be precise you feel
like okay I don't have any hope and uh
it's just an exercise in suffering for
the Dutchman it's a really good way of
putting it and I know that feeling very
well when you're have an advantage out
of the opening into the middle game like
nothing can go wrong here I'm just
better no risk and then you blunder
something and mistakes often come in
pair so let's actually go back to the
moment where that blunder occurred
because we were talking about this very
position with G5 to stop F4 and Jordan
plays F4 anyway he could have played
Knight F5
that was an option but he goes for F4
and after this move Queen G5 the threat
is already Knight F3 check because the G
Pawn is pinned let's put it on the board
after Knight F3 check the g-pawn is
pinned you can't take and you take with
the Rook you lose the queen on D2 that
Rook was in the way of those Queens
eyeing each other so that would just be
a winning idea for black it's on the
king one here and the bishop takes H3
happens and here's where I would say the
mistakes
or in pairs because at this moment here
he went Rook F5 he could have kept
material equal if he traded and put his
Bishop on B3 maybe up to D5
of course black is better in the sense
that the dark Square control looks nice
but material remains level so I'm
wondering if at this moment Yogi he made
a good move uh right here to Rook F5 is
engine approved it's still equal
according to the eval bar but giving up
a pawn and going into this end game down
one
maybe just gave Vincent all the chances
with zero risk and the path to draw was
more difficult than initially met the
eye yeah and also I think he made a
third inaccuracy and actually in pushing
this G Pawn forward I feel that this one
is understandable
but at the same time
suddenly blacks
a task got off so much easier
you know it became very clear you know
he had the freedom to move the king
towards the center
Black's plan became a whole lot easier
and I I don't want to criticize it too
much because I do feel that G4 G5 just
relinquishing the tension exchanging
Bitcoins
is very very tempting
yeah it does seem to make your test
easier not harder but then there were no
targets that one could go after if we
think about it from what happened in the
game where the black king went over here
and The Rook eventually released that
wouldn't be possible with the H6 Pawn
under threat so the king for white could
be checkmated if the black Rook gets on
over there but it also keeps black
honest tied down to this H Pawn so what
we saw in the game it still was even
Rook F6 cutting off The King The King
went back to f8 look at this I mean Rook
F6 move
um he cuts the king off and then he goes
to this his King he removes his King
gained some time the white king came to
the center and then went back to the f
file so maybe King D4 but that's such a
difficult decision you have another one
where do you really want to be cut off
from the passer he said no but then he
was cut off from the queen side which
the eval bar does not tell the full
story it's a draw with optimal play but
the optimal moves are very difficult to
find
yeah I agree and there were really tough
choices along the way and uh we see a
move from Jordan he moves his Rook from
the golden fifth Rank and he moves it to
Rook H2 and uh Vincent just sat up
immediately because of course this
allows black several moves first one
is to put the Rook himself on E5 and
then just simply start coming over with
his King that would be something I would
look at immediately
and
the other option for Vincent is actually
to put his Rook behind the a pawn
yeah I'm not very attracted to you
so you just got rookie five the time I
would just go rookie five tie him down
put Force the road to go passive and
then you know end games are all about
using the team and the king is itching
to get into the fight and so I would
stop moving it up the board as quickly
as I could
oh well I made a mistake oh King C5
that's a mistake
oh my gosh because
Rook B2 and you're gonna go Rook B6 and
the A5 Pawn is not loose this is how
tricky end games are where if you play
King C4 oh the Pawn's under attack again
but after this trade this is a draw
because the white king is not cut off
like it was in many variations the king
is running towards E3 and if you cut the
king off here it's too close it's not
cut off on enough files this Rook will
come with check the king will continue
to slide over and white will be able to
stop this Pawn before it gets the other
side so I was just making a careless
move instead of King C5 King C6 you have
to take the slow path towards B4 you
would think King C5 King B4 I win the
pawn but no because of Rook B2 after
King C6 there is no Rook B2 you take the
pawn A5 and well you can't cross the
fifth Rank and black doesn't play King
B5 King B4 and then win this Pawn wow
you have to be precise the very last
second
yeah uh incredible end game once again
and uh you wouldn't defending his own
undoubtedly
and now the moment of truth
do not play King C5 we just learned that
King C5 watch the eval bar
back towards the center because of Rook
B2 and Rook B6 so it's so tempting to
play King C5 sorry the wrong button
there is changing the settings for the
uh evaluation of our mayor to just turn
it off next time but no Rook D2 check do
not play King C5 which is the most
tempting move this is a bullet game I
think we'd see it
yeah I I must admit you know I thought
King C5 King C4 my king was going on the
expressway to the B4 square and no no no
again you have to proceed with caution
but having watched Vincent play
yesterday's real componenting I do feel
that Rooks sorry King C6 is something
that he will find
he was the expert on making all these
little subtle moves and putting
abusotoff in that game under pressure
King C6 just being extra technical about
it King C5 spoils the win that would be
a real shame we don't root for players
as commentators but for Vincent kymer if
he were to draw two games in a row where
he had a winning rook and pawn end game
that would be some soul-crushing stuff
so
um for him King C6 is the move not King
C5 which is something a king C6 show
some restraint bring the king up to B5
then to B4 win the A5 pawn and then go
on to win the game
yeah
King C6
oh what do you think will he make it I'm
gonna vote Yes I think you will play
King C6
yeah I think you will but by the fact
that he's pausing as well
credit to Jordan though because Rook D2
check you throw in this move and then
Vince like what is he thinking Rook D5
is another move that comes to mind but
they need to calculate Rook D5 and if
Rook 65 King takes we've seen this show
before the white king is just one turn
too slow once again you shoulder the
king out you keep doing that your Pawn
gets the other side so you're just gonna
keep following the enemy King and then
when there's no more room for the king
to go the a pawn rumbles down the board
so Jordan after Rook D5 can't even take
it so maybe this is still a good move
but King C6 is the one we have been
liking
yeah I have to say that if you do spot
that kick after King C5
it's a terrible mistake because of Rook
B2 maybe it would have been better to go
Rook A2
and um sneakiness because here it looks
like hang on a second why are you asking
my king to move towards its destination
and
you know if you kind of just quickly
play Rook 82 and act as though the
game's over I've spotted you know the
amateur Dramatics that you see at
Children's tournaments
and then here it's very likely that
black not thinking
you know just making a snap decision
we'll just go King survive and you're
like okay
on a practical level you know because if
you go Rook D2 I just feel that Rook D2
you kind of get a little bit alert and
you're thinking why are they playing
such a move why are they encouraging the
king to
go to where it actively wants to go
and so you're like awesome smell around
also the big difference is King C6 still
leaves the pawn under attack right
whereas King C5 you're walking into your
own rook's path so I I'm with you I feel
like Rook A2 just a little bit more
challenging psychologically speaking uh
but Vincent he is deliberating here he
does not want to spoil this opportunity
I'm guessing he could even play King E6
and The Rook still has to go to A2 and
with a passive Rook it should be good
enough for black to press forward and go
for the win we will leave Vincent to it
uh you know he is still deep in thought
he's trying to
take this one home to the Finish Line
here's a rest day tomorrow he doesn't
need to rest right now and well let's
see what he does but we are going to go
to break when return It's the final
stretch of this game between Jordan Von
forest and Vincent kymer
[Music]
let's duck trash you guys this is a new
variant it's called duck chess
quack quack how to play duck chess the
duck is a brick pieces cannot move
through the square occupied by the duck
click on a square to place the dog
oh he put the deck to prevent moves of
opponent not yourself
Yeah so basically you do this and this
cannot move I'm gonna go Knight F6 and
I'm gonna put the duck in the most
inconvenient place for my opponent to
move no Bishop no Queen so no londons
can permanently stop the London capture
the pawns King to win oh wow oh there's
no stalemate but still wait there is
still meat but the still made the player
wins ooh if only that was real chess I
think I'm getting the hang of this game
I think I think I actually am getting
the hang of it
I think this works oh that's a horrible
blunder oh my God I just blundered I
have to move something else first then
dark and Knight will take my king this
is the best way to lose the dog chest
[Music]
there are some real bullet skills right
there boys this is a fast time winning
duck chest That's so exciting
oh no no no no no no slip no no no no no
no
one
ah duck chess champion give me those
points baby
[Music]
all right
foreign
[Music]
s
for this cozy coastal town the holiday
season isn't over
in fact the most wonderful time of the
year has really just begun come on gotta
make a move no no no no no no no no no
oh my God I'm speechless there
once again vikon Zay starts the new year
as the center of the chess Universe this
year as host of the 85th taught to steal
chess tournament
a magnet for the best players in the
game some recognize the Masters field of
2023 as its strongest in recent memory
of course it helps when eight-time Tata
steel chess champion Magnus Carlson is
back
what a game for Magnus and now a huge
chance to make a furious run at first
place the world's number one looks to
further cement his legacy in this event
and the game's history
chasing Magnus will be amongst the best
in chess several have been Crown
championed here before some have even
shocked the world in doing so
and Joe leave out those poised to
capture their first Tata title Anish
Gary is just I mean he beat both world
number one and world number two in the
same tournament
although winter Tata steel chess is also
known as the place new stars come to
bloom
Magnus one here as a teenager this
year's event has its fair share of young
players on the rise each hoping to
follow in Carlson's footsteps what a
defensive effort notrebec is obviously
having a breakout event the Dutch refer
to Tata steel as The Wimbledon of chess
for 85 years in running this tournament
continues to be steeped in Prestige and
Legacy and does so again in this
welcoming Little Dutch town by the sea
mine brynden it's the 85th edition of
the Tata steel chess tournament let's
make chess history together
[Music]
the playing Hall has cleared out for the
most part just a few faces remaining we
see Arbiters talking organizers staff
members being communicate with one
another and there are so helpful to make
an event like this possible so I see
that other players are still going at it
we have Jordan Von forest and
visakheimer in the Masters Tournament
but throughout the playing Hall the
festival is ongoing so yovi our final
match of the day is in Jordan and
Vincent we've had two decisive results
thus far Vincent looking to make it a
third
yeah and it's uh certainly looking that
way
although like all Recon porn Adventures
the players are going on detours and
Adventures and I think this is a very
natural course of in-games you know they
cannot be played perfectly and it's just
simply most of the time players just
trying to find the right way to proceed
and more often than not
the players just simply stumble on the
right course of action and it's
certainly been an exciting day of Chess
I have to say you know we've had some
amazing results and also amazing games
good cash beating pregnant in what was
must have been the wildest game of a
tournament it just looked absolutely
crazy I don't think anyone could have
predicted what could have happened and
uh and other news Magnus was back in
business the show was on for him as he
just outclassed a Para maxulu
Magnus you know he's looking really
powerful ever since losing those couple
games to Notre back and to Anish Geary
uh so he's back he's found his form and
maybe he'll find his lost rating points
because uh before this round he was down
about nine ten points and now he should
be cutting into that and well some of
the players finish earlier than others
they're likely long done with dinner
relaxing maybe putting on some TV some
Netflix because tomorrow's the rest day
and tournament Ambassador Nish Geary he
caught up with the Press earlier and
told what you can find in Vikings what
restaurants he recommends new players
and all of that so let's hear what Anish
has to say
so there are only a few restaurants that
at this point understand the needs of
the players and uh yeah I think the
small Switzerland is called is a big
restaurant in the center of the the town
also the Italian uh is a big one and the
sonafank I think is um
the quickest and the most available
usually and okay weather most available
is uh you know is the plus or minus I
don't know but it's uh always there for
for you in in need and I've tried and
doubled the various other
places but I have to say
um more often than not the risk you know
is not
it's not it's not been rewarded for for
the risk
more often than not there so uh you know
they're not expecting so many players
and uh I think these three are the ones
that you know they've been there done
that and they know uh the the January is
tough month and they're ready and other
places are usually a little understaffed
and uh taking away too long and yeah I
think that's not ideal when you have to
prepare
okay well I've been to those restaurants
uh Tarantella the most popular one by
far everyone's trying to get a seat at
the Italian restaurant tables and some
delicious pizza I remember actually last
time I was there I had a meal with Fiona
I think I'm the last night and it was
it's always delicious coming you go
there every single day if you can uh yo
have you spent much time in Vikings have
you ever been there
I've never been there but uh obviously
it's a small place and actually a niche
kind of being real and talking about the
dilemmas that chess players face
actually when they're playing chess and
the preparing like how much time and how
much energy do you devote to eating I
mean do you go to a fancy restaurant
where it takes time for the dish to
prepare I mean are you going for
proteins carbs I mean what nutrition are
you taking this is uh certainly
something to think about I know Magnus
he he's kind of made this he consulted a
nutritionist and he made some radical
changes because I remember he used to
always turn up to the board with orange
juice and raisins and then the
nutritionists were like no no no no
that's going to give you a sugar Spike
and uh he's not allowed to drink half
coffee because again you have this big
just a spike of energy and then a huge
crash and that's not very good for when
you're playing chess and I I think this
is the conversations that us normal
players we want to have you know we want
to know what is the best food to eat I
remember having this debate when it came
to my German chess team there were some
people going oh you've got to have a
steak and other people are you going are
you crazy you can't have a steak that'll
make you tired have some pasta instead
so I don't know everyone has their own
personal experience their own personal
recommendation do you have any thoughts
on this
I have somebody who prioritizes his food
I get hungry I like to eat I don't like
to prepare so my choice is pretty simple
get me the good food you know that's uh
always going to be my choice but it is a
tough call because you don't want to be
exhausted you don't want to get back to
your hotel too late after what's
undoubtedly was a tough round so I get
it I just want good food and I'm I'm
maybe saying that because I'm really
hungry right now that could be part
but what about before the game so after
the game you're like just get me to the
restaurant ASAP
uh in fact I'll tell you once I think I
once had someone resign a game against
me just because they were hungry
that's only happened once
I'm guessing you were not complaining
no I wasn't complaining I mean I was I
was like Vincent I was like getting
ready for the long haul you know it was
double Rick ending I was one porn up and
that was it and then suddenly hand came
out because I had enough and thank you
very much about the game and off off
they off they went and I was like oh
okay either he had to go somewhere or he
was hungry
I told the story earlier uh in this
tournament when I was commenting with
Tanya that I played against Jerusalem
palomario in the Isle of Man the grand
Swiss back in 2019 and he had broken
bishop and I had rook and I was you know
defending I knew how to do it and he
just offers me a draw and I thought he
would play 50 moves for sure but he was
getting really hungry and the
restaurants I think were closing soon so
he uh he's I gotta get out of here I
gotta get some food in me and but but to
your question before the games I don't
actually love eating a lot before the
game I just always felt like things
could go wrong what if it doesn't agree
with your stomach what if you just feel
too full so I would I generally enjoyed
a light lunch I would say and then bring
maybe some chocolate or what have you to
the round but big meals definitely not
happening before a game
okay
and uh
well I was actually curious do you think
that the players are hungry themselves
van forest and climber they've been
playing for since 2 P.M
yes that's uh six hours of Chess they've
just been
thinking hard and there we have a move
from kaima moving The Rook
to the edge of the board
foreign
still a difficult task for Jordan
because kaima's plan is so clear-cut you
know he's just going to step forward
with a king and uh March the F Pawn this
time we've been obsessed with the apron
but perhaps it's the F Pawn that is also
a winner
and as soon as this Rook leaves the a
file the black Rook can slide over to
win the pawn here in particular to be
rookie five check but it feels like
white is frozen you can bring the king
back to G4 that looks like a reasonable
move but after king of G4 black can
bring the king up to E5 and if the white
king gets back to F3 well it's finally
realizing I think there could be a
horizon effect with the engine or
something because it's been winning the
whole time but now it's saying I'm open
to tail base you can do this yourself on
chess.com events they're one two three
four five six seven winning moves the
most likely being F5 and after King two
F2 to kick the Rook Now The Rook can go
up to E4 it can go over to H1 all of
these moves still are winning now it's
not just about what move is winning it's
about what is the actual plan like where
should my Rook go and part of it can be
bring your Rook to the fifth Rank and
then finally getting your king over here
because a rook on the fifth rank defends
this Pawn in F5 so I just think that
it's all about going after the A5 Pawn
eventually Vince is just trying to time
it correctly
I agree I think that makes perfect sense
and it doesn't seem like Jordan has any
good defenses because to be honest his
Rook is just too passive you know he
would love his Rook to be out there on
the beeline wandering away eyeing up the
weak A6 Pawn
but I can't do that and you know I've
always been told if you have a choice
between an active king or an active rook
in a component ending always go for the
active Rook active Rook can be a real
nuisance
and nobody likes to defend passively
right so Jordan sitting with his Rook
behind the A5 Pawn he had to do it but
there's not a single player in the world
who would choose to put a rook behind
upon just to defend it you'd hope to get
some activity give some checks there's
just no way to do it because black is
timing everything perfectly the white
king is offside over here and it is just
about time to run your king back but a
rook on the fifth rank with opponent F5
that's going to be good enough rookie
won I I wonder why he didn't play F5
immediately I'm guessing and I was about
to say it the answer is Rook B2 look how
interesting this is Rook B6 check is the
threat and Rook E5 no longer is check
that's the critical difference is that
it's not check so if you go rookie five
you simply drop this Pawn on A6 and that
allows white to hold this game so
Vincent is showing restraint not moving
the F Pawn immediately Lee leaving the
check open if the Rook were to leave the
a file for white
very very instructive stuff from the
German teenager and we have to remind
ourselves he is just a teenager 17 years
old recently left school so that he can
just focus fully on chess
and he's already a magnificent chess
player and
what he can do when he is fully focused
on the game that will be interesting but
kind of a
I don't know if what you call it but I
wonder sometimes if you take somebody
out of their sort of like standard
environment he always is going to school
and playing chess he was thriving in
both and now he's full-time in chess
sometimes it doesn't always work the way
you want at least initially because it
get takes getting used to like devoting
yourself full time to something that you
were doing well I don't want to call it
a hobby because he's 2700 so he'd be a
pretty uh star hobbyist but you know you
know I mean you'll be like when you're
doing it full time it's a lot different
it feels emotionally different
psychologically it maybe feels less like
the fun he was having as a kid and as a
teenager and then like work so I do
wonder sometimes how that adjustment
period works
yeah I mean you're totally right because
suddenly you know when you're a kid
you're just having fun you know results
don't matter but somehow when you turn
professional you have to justify every
single thing you know if he's doing
badly the question there's going to be
questions like why why are you doing
badly after all did you not say that you
were studying eight hours a day or
whatever number it is and
yeah you're gonna have to scrutinize
every single detail you're going to have
to justify this and that can take its
toll
um this is I I would always recommend
that if you're gonna turn pro at
anything that you surround yourself with
a good Network a very supportive Network
and definitely arm yourself with a
second I don't believe in Lone wolves I
think chess it's it's a bit boring if
you study it by yourself it's much
better to surround yourself with friends
with colleagues with whoever you can
whoever loves the game and you kind of
feed off each other feed off that energy
and then I think you have the right
frame of mind and the right focus and
also it's fun and you will want to
continue studying
yeah because the when you play chess
like we're watching these two players do
right now it can be a bit isolating you
are sitting in silence it's only you
against your opponent all the
responsibilities on your shoulders so if
you can work with a team or within
another individual I think that provides
a good social network so you're not just
sitting alone and doing it uh in a game
that you play in silence but also you
get that camaraderie and you get all
sorts of ideas right Peter leco is
Vincent kymer's coach couldn't really
ask for a better Coach than somebody who
played a world championship match
against Vladimir crumbling and played
him to a tie I might add so uh you know
you want to surround yourself with
people that support you that make you
feel confident and preventing camera you
know I've always seen him happy at
tournaments and with his family and with
his coach it seems like he is going in
the right direction I just was trying to
make uh note of the fact that it is not
always the easiest adjustment doesn't
mean that he's making a bad decision
doesn't mean that he's going to struggle
necessarily but it is an adjustment
period when you commit yourself full
time it just takes on a whole new
attitude and it just becomes something
different than what it used to be
yeah and uh you reminded me of a very
interesting point actually that my my
sisters made because I came from a chess
playing family all of my siblings play
chess
and it was to do with your silence point
because you know when we go to
tournaments we play in silence we spend
a lot of time by ourselves
and do you think that the silence
is perhaps a deterrent for a lot of
people
I think yes but I think one of the major
deterrents is the individual
responsibility that happens in chess
right you can't blame anybody but
yourself when you lose a game and I
think for some people that's
overwhelming and something they just
don't enjoy whereas team sports not only
do you get like the friendships that
come along with it but if you lose a
basketball game the whole team lost
right it wasn't just you and so I do
think that that kind of Burden can be
really a lot to bear for people and so I
understand uh if that is not something
that people want but the silent element
yeah it's difficult to sit in silence
for six hours and more than that that's
what Vincent and Jordan are doing but
chess is a beautiful game like I reflect
very fondly over tournaments I played in
over games that I've lost where I was
just that feeling of calculating for me
that is incredibly fulfilling and
stimulating when I'm looking at a
position and trying to find the answer
the best moves I love that and I think
you look at any player they finish their
game they immediately want to analyze
because that experience for them uh it's
a rush and it's something that they
greatly enjoy and that we can talk about
some of the cons and we mentioned those
but I do think you know while we take
those into account the pros are just
immense and I think chess is just an
unbelievable game it's Rich uh there's
all sorts of pattern recognition and
challenges that are new every single
game you play
yeah absolutely I mean that's the great
thing about Chess every single game is
different
and
uh yeah interesting interesting kind of
conversation I think there's uh my my
personal opinion is that I think we
should focus on chess and different
levels and in different ways you know I
like the whole aspect of the tournament
where you have the silence the
competitive nature but I do think that
we should encourage more of the social
stuff because there's nothing more fun
in life like when you get your your
mates together and you're you're just
doing these board games and you're
discussing you're laughing you're
sharing thoughts you're sharing sharing
strategies and I feel sometimes we lose
that we lose that kind of connection
that discussion with other people and
it's it's like the best thing in the
world just sit there and also again work
with young minds and just see how it's
all ticking down and okay Vincent he's
distracting me because uh he's pushed
the F Pawn forward
to F5 and I feel that these are two
players have maneuvered so long that
I've become very very excited at this
Pawn push yeah we get one Part push with
check we might add we're pushing that
pawn for it is a good choice from
Vincent Comer he's just trying to play
rookie five next because Pawn on F5 will
be defended and his Rook can slide over
to the queen side and then his King can
join the party so if he continues with
his plan it should lead to a victory uh
but Jordan is not going to make his life
easy
now he's uh certainly not going to make
life easy
I mean
Jordan he's a great chess player and he
will be looking at any opportunity to
activate his a to Rook that's his only
chance for salvation here
so let's see what Jordan does I feel
like bringing the king back makes a lot
of sense if you bring the king up the
board to G5 you already see it it's
getting out of hand because black steps
forward now in addition to weak a pawn
Rook G1 check is a problem I'm gonna
kick your king to the last file and then
it's the F Pawn that's going to promote
we were so focused on the a pawn earlier
that we didn't give the F credit
it deserves I mean that is a past pawn
and with the king's help and The Rook
checking away the enemy King it will go
to the other side
Jordan stepping the king down I think
this is a good defensive technique I
agree
don't go up with the King however
tempting it looks you usually will get
cut off and a good
idea by Jordan and okay
there is a big threat on the board if
Vincent is not careful then uh Eurozone
will just simply Slide the route to B2
and then the Rook is free it's out and
it can start harassing the B Pawn
okay so King E5 looks viable and
you know this this position is really
teetering here
um it looks like by the way I pulled up
the table base
King E5
that appears to be
the move that does the job
because uh all other moves seem to allow
white to survive
yeah I was gonna ask I mean King E5 King
D5 kind of looks like it's
apples and pears to me so I mean why
does King D5 let the wind slip the king
E5 holds on tight
sorry King D5 going away I wonder maybe
it's this rugby two thing again because
while the black Rook can come over the
A5 Pawn the white king approaches the F
Pawn and we've seen positions like this
before where the white king is cut off
but in this particular variation once
you take and if you let's say move your
Rook to A1 white is ready to check the
king and bring this King I guess you
can't go to E4 because it's E1 check
maybe I moved a little bit quickly there
haste makes waste as they say uh but
there clearly is a way for white to
bring the king back and maybe it's
through this move and if you check me I
go up the board rather than back but I
am going to try to bring my king closer
and closer to this a pawn
yeah
um you
is the fun the funny thing about Rick
and pawn sorry The Rook porn endings is
that the white king doesn't actually
have to be that close so maybe the king
can just also snake its way down anyhow
yeah you're saying maybe here the king
can just yeah just just go down to F4
and just go to E3 and
I mean it's just a ridiculous end game
because it really has to be cut off by
five rows for The Rook Pawn to win
sure so uh the live position is not the
one we've just been analyzing where
white would be able to escape uh it's
important for Vincent after King F3 to
make this move King to E5 so
yeah King up the board that's the way to
go and from there it's still not trivial
it still will take some work because
white is probably just going to go back
and forth
has to leave behind the pawn and then
black needs to figure out when is the
right moment to push F4 and then maybe
Rook E3 check and he goes rookie five
instead and does that give away the win
that's the big question
well that is the big question Rook E5
I think on a practical level probably
not
but
it appears I don't see why it would give
away the win
it just is not a it's not a kind of
aggressive mood it probably will delay
the win
yeah I'm trying to figure this out as
well
sorry you're saying which move I was
just thinking okay save you pass I don't
know you move a rook any anywhere A4 A3
I mean maybe A4 because the maximum
distance or whatever and
aha
oh
hang on this King and pawn ending so if
you go King D5 and I step forward with
the King can you step forward with the
King to F and after Rook
check I think this king and pawn ending
might be actually draw
oh because the pawn is dragged to a
closer file to the A4 that is
unbelievable so just to kind of show
that let's say the king runs away
because if we keep making progress we're
just gonna make a draw these pawns don't
matter at the moment because it's going
to be a stalemate as you're taught in
King and pawn aims you initiate the
opposition and after check King E3 is
stalemate King going this way loses the
pawn and would allow white to hold so
what we're saying is that if the King
goes over here unlike in previous
positions where the king reached D4 and
the black king shouldered it away the
King goes to D3 and darts for the corner
wow
oh my gosh okay but that then that means
that Rook A4 is the only
saving try
and he played it because you need
already able to get into this ending
oh my gosh Jordan played it
and the good news for the for the
players in particularly for Vincent he
doesn't know if he was one he doesn't
know that this is a draw so maybe he
won't experience all those emotions just
yet but he wants to get his King over
but with King F4 going to the drawn King
and pawn end game that eliminates one of
Black's best tries
yeah and uh okay well Vincent has to go
back to the drawing board I mean it's
still not an easy end game to draw at
all for
uh Jordan because okay yes King D5
doesn't work but let's not forget that
there is the opportunity to improve the
Rook maybe put it on C5 and then March
the king to E5 that's one plan and the
other plan is a bit more long-winded but
to put it onto G5
um but yeah I like your yeah also this
one as well
we have our options so if King F4 what's
happening here so King over
how is this exactly
supposed to hold
oh excuse me I've been commenting so
long a little bit but tickling the
throat but after Rook A5 check
but wait the king can go up to C5 my
appointment's gonna be if the king had
to go back now black can't make progress
whites continues to pass
yeah
because this Pawn on F5 will be captured
if the Rook were to move uh along the
a file if the Rook moved along the fifth
rank the A6 Pawn drops somehow it's like
this weird Fortress configuration
yeah and I think we saw this type of
Defense before or maybe it was a
possibility for some of the players to
do
um that if we go back
because black wasn't obliged to go back
to the king with the King
okay
and we do the whole process again
because the king Went to went running to
see six
so difficult
so we said King F yeah four and then and
then they came King D6
let's get going
the king could go to c5s
yeah the King goes to C5 and is this a
draw
oh my gosh and this is why the eval bar
is so misleading because the players
don't know this is a drill this looks
losing right two extra pawns but
apparently and I'm using all the help I
can get I turn on the lines to see what
the moves are the point here is that no
you do not take this pawn and lose the
king opponent game that it seems that
you can just bring your king back and
again this Rook is stuck it needs to
stay on the fifth rank to defend the F5
pawn it needs to stay on the a file to
defend the A6 pawn and if all you're
doing is moving your King around you're
not gonna make progress if you move your
Rook day three with check the king comes
up to D4 and it Rook moves to F3 to
defend this you lose A6
if you uh don't defend the F5 font I'm
going to take it oh my gosh
Ivanka this is actually again one of the
most complicated rook and pawn endings
I know I was thinking about that and how
do you think Vincent is gonna feel right
if they get into this end game
Vincent is two pawns up again
and he's still a draw he's just gonna
feel jinxed he's going to be like man I
cannot catch a break
oh
that's incredible
this can you just like run through that
one more time because I'm just trying to
process this whole thing that Jordan can
get into this position he can lose his a
pawn
allow Vincent to be two pawns up
and because Vincent's Rook is so badly
placed
it doesn't matter
so Rook comes to F6
and then if you're a king B4 you just
maybe there are other moves but just
King E3 is what looking at and you're
stuck you're overloaded this Rook is
doing too much oh my goodness this looks
so winning the fact of this isn't
winning is a travesty
yeah it is and just to kind of clarify
the point this particular game in this
specific position
where does the white king have to wait
because presumably The Rook cannot be
touched because it's in the ideal uh
Square connecting with the F Pawn and
the a pawn so this is for white so the
so white will have to pass with the King
it would just follow its counterpart
around the board right so if the King
goes to B3 you just go to
D D3 let's say what wait we didn't
realize this check okay so okay so you
have to go King D4 then you've got to
have some care but it moves like F4
yes
look at this look how tricky this is
King D3 now because at the Rook D5 check
I have King E4 and I'm going to win your
Pawn
so and this Pawn's under attack so you
have to go Rook A5 to keep any winning
chances and then I just simply take your
pawn it looks like with the king or go
back that is just wild because King D3
Rook D5 check the king doesn't have E4
so The Rook is Untouchable and after the
king lose then A5 and the pawn is going
to become a queen so
you're up two pawns and yet you can't
make progress because your Rook is
overloaded the white king and Rook are
doing enough
work to hold everything together it is
really a situation that is shocking and
just to note something for everybody the
players
you see two minutes on their clock they
actually have not received their 15
final minutes so when their clock hits
zero that's 15 minutes that they get for
having reached move 60 will be added to
their clock so we will be here for a
while but we are going to take a short
break maybe stretch our legs grab some
water you stay right where you are
because when we return it is this final
game of the 10th round of the tallest
steel Chess Masters you will not want to
miss its conclusion
[Music]
just played an exciting game and want to
see if you got a brilliancy or maybe
where you could have improved
chess.com's game review is just a click
away game review is a fast fun and
instructive guided review of your games
see your accuracy and your opponent's
accuracy check out the eval graph for an
instant overview and scroll down to see
how many great moves best moves blunders
and yes brilliancies you have played
learn from chess.com's coach who gives
move explanations opening statistics and
shows you the best lines of play
with retry mistakes you can get another
shot at finding missed opportunities
try game review today on web iOS or
Android
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
all right
thank you
[Music]
foreign
thank you
[Music]
foreign
s
for this cozy coastal town the holiday
season isn't over
in fact the most wonderful time of the
year has really just begun come on gotta
make a move no no no no no no no no no
oh my God I'm speechless that
once again Vicon say starts the new year
as the center of the chess Universe this
year as host of the 85th taught to steal
chess tournament
a magnet for the best players in the
game some recognize the Masters field of
2023 as its strongest in recent memory
of course it helps when eight-time Tata
steel chess champion Magnus Carlson is
back
what a game for Magnus and now a huge
chance to make a furious run at first
place the world's number one looks to
further cement his legacy in this event
and the game's history
chasing Magnus will be amongst the best
in chess several have been crowned
Champion here before some have even
shocked the world in doing so
and don't leave out those poised to
capture their first Tata title Anish
Geary is just I mean he beat both world
number one and world number two in the
same tournament
although winter Tata steel chess is also
known as the place new stars come to
bloom
Magnus one here is a teenager this
year's event has its fair share of young
players on the rise each hoping to
follow in Carlson's footsteps what
noterbeck is
the Dutch refer to Tata steel as The
Wimbledon of chess for 85 years in
running this tournament continues to be
steeped in Prestige and Legacy and does
so again in this welcoming Little Dutch
town by the sea
mine brynden
it's the 85th edition of the Tata steel
chess tournament let's make chess
history together
foreign
to the action in the playing Hall in
Viking Zay as you can see almost no one
remains but one matchup continues it is
the game between Jordan Von forest and
Vincent kymer these two players giving
it their all uh Jordan he's down upon
defending tenaciously visit trying to
squeeze out a victory he wasn't able to
do that yesterday against Abdus atarov
today he hopes is a different story but
it's kind of the same story since his
two losses Magnus Carlson with another
Victory this time of apartment
it's been an impressive display for
Magnus ever since it looked like he was
down and out he has roared back
yeah it seems to have relished the
challenge right just when the whole
world has written him off he's like no
no no no no I'm still the world champion
for a reason and uh Magnus just seems to
level up especially during the end of
these tournaments he just seems to keep
finishing stronger and stronger and uh
someone else who had a good finish today
was gukesh who defeated ragnananda in
one of the most fiery games I've ever
seen before and overall it was a
relatively solid day with a few players
not taking any risks whatsoever Wesley
so and ichigiri are finished very calmly
very quickly and as did Abdul sotorov
and ding Loren I mean both these kind of
games never really got going and it's to
be expected actually that the players
will start to conserve their energy
because you have to remember this event
is grueling
it is and there's no denying it the
players will admit it but right now
abutator of he'll handle all that
grueling because he is in first place
ahead of anishkiri he is Half Point
Clear of him Magnus Carlson and Wesley
so in a tie for third place one full
point behind a bizitarov and well let's
look at notorious path ahead because we
see his current result we see that he is
a half Point ahead of Anish giri he
still has a niche to play with black
Wesley to play Black and White against
Jordan
yomi that is an incredibly difficult
slate there are no easy customers here
but black two games in a row against
Anisha and Wesley
oh gosh that is a challenge
and it's certainly a challenge and we've
also seen a niche be so powerful with
the white pieces he's come prepared he's
come on to the teeth with all sorts of
opening ideas and it's been very very
effective and when it comes to Wesley so
Wesley is just unbeatable with the white
pieces I mean
if Wesley wants a draw Wesley will get
the draw and if Wesley wants to make you
suffer for seven hours he will do that
and of course he will finish on a white
against Jordan van for East so
definitely still not out of the woods
yet if Abdul sitarov is can think that
he can just simply sit there and just
rest on his laurels
going to be a challenging final stretch
it is for every single player because as
you said cannot rest on your laurels and
for Anish giri who is a half Point
behind visitor and gets white against
him in the next round uh we can check
his remaining pairings because Anish he
gets white against Notre back he gets
black against Jordan and white against
Richard reports so thinking about the
difference in those twos a final three
games
Anish gets two whites and it's black
against Jordan no tearback gets two
blacks and then white against Jordan so
Jordan but Forest not having his best
showing here but will play a major role
in determining who wins this year's
Edition
suddenly everything to play for and I
have to say white against Richard
Rapport is not necessarily
such an easy pairing because we have
seen Richard play some fabulous chess is
one of the most creative flamboyant
players that is around and I don't know
I have a feeling that last round nerves
are going to start jangling for a niche
what see he gets a rest day before he
needs to put his chest pieces back on
the board so he will get abdusitarov
he'll get vomforest and he'll get rich
report and as you're saying that final
game against report who knows what's
going to happen we saw Richard beat our
generic geiste with this I just kind of
mind-boggling G5 move and it led to a
very nice victory for the new Romanian
player he hails from Hungary but now
plays under the Romanian Federation and
well this end game that we have between
Jordan and Vincent we
we're talking about this exact position
and now we are here so just to rewind
because black is currently two pawns
ahead that white had to release the rook
and went Rook to B1 and the reason why
you do that is let's say you make
another way to move with Rook to A2 you
see the eval bar drop because black
isn't time to play King C6 and if you
try to do the same thing with Rook B2
now the pawn is gone you don't have this
check on the sixth rank which is Black's
Rook moves the a pawn goes up and both
pawns are defended so that's what
um visit was aiming for Jordan had this
all mapped out he gives the check brings
The Rook over and this is where we sit
you know we were talking about this
exact variation credit to your invent
Forest he's playing amazingly well being
down now two Pawns in this Rook ending
yeah
find this tremendous resource it's just
unbelievable stuff I mean it's just so
fantastic because it looked at some
point like he was down and out but now
he finds this when needed to and now
it's just all about keeping that Rook on
F6 and letting the white king follow the
black king and at the same time
not allow the wreck on A5 to escape from
its prison
I think this is one of these ideas that
is not too difficult at least I feel to
explain once you see it but to come up
with it by yourself that is the hard
part so Jordan Von Forest I mean he
really has put together a dazzling
display of defensive technique it just
looked like he should be lost and the
table bases were saying that it was with
best play in objective win for Vincent
it was never straightforward it was
never easy they thought he was going to
go after the a pawn he didn't do that
early enough it would appear and now his
Rook is tied down the most annoying
situation so he brings his King up
defending the pawn a rook trade would be
a loss for white and he just needs to be
able to push his a pawn they can't do
that with his Rook on A5
yeah and uh now I was wondering about
the path for the white king for instance
I can see according to the table base
that if you put your King on E3
it's a draw
if you but if you put your King on F3
that's like no no no no no bad news
because your king is far away from the
action
that's a very difficult point to
understand
so what is the point that is the the
black king going to B3 doesn't seem to
help because we just get back to what
we're looking at so probably the
blacking slides closer and if King F4 is
there some kind of Rook A1 is that the
point oh my goodness that is it
it's whatever you take me with I'm gonna
go Rook a rook F1 excuse me and trade
Rooks and then push this a pawn up the
board so that allows The Rook to release
and when that happens the eight Pawn is
free and now white cannot attack both
pawns if you give a check the king can
slide back to C5 and now if you over F6
trying to keep both pawns threatened
simply Rook up one check then A5 and
blacks pawns move forward
yeah
yes uh that is uh definitely not
something that white wants to do
um King E3 Rook C6 check maintains the
balance I mean really Jordan has to be
in a real zen-like mode because he has
to just keep finding the balance between
ying and yang here
The Rook must stay on F6 must keep an
eye on Asics and F5 at all time and the
white King has to stay on certain
squares and not allow The Rook the black
Rook to get active
very very complicated end game and I
agree with you I feel that this kind of
end game you see with the benefit of
hindsight you see it when you're there
but when you're thinking ahead you would
just be like oh my goodness me I cannot
lose the pawn because that's just an
automatic loss
and as we find out
yes yeah I was just gonna say oh you go
ahead yeah yeah I know you go
ahead no you it's all you
yeah no I was just gonna commiserate
with Paul Vincent because he wants to
get yeah he's he's kind of coming to the
conclusion that
all work endings are drawn
[Laughter]
oh gosh that Mantra rears its ugly head
and for Vincent he needs to be able to
push his pawns you mentioned how King E3
and Rook C6 check are the two options
that allow white to
keep the draw in hand so if this Rook
comes to C6 check I understand why King
D5 doesn't get it done because the Rook
just goes back to F6 if you give this
Rook A1 now Rook takes F5 is check and
that's the big problem is the king is in
check which means the pawn can be
captured and then after king of D4 I
know you want to go over to F1 so do I
move my Rook somewhere wait how do you
actually oh oh it's one of these
positions you'll be worth it's the
checks come from the side
this is why Rook end games are so
difficult because
we're so used to bringing our Rook
behind a pass Pawn but in this
particular end game because the black
king cannot hide the Rook is assumed
upon is on The Rook file that if I push
the pawn and I give a check and let's
say the king runs if this Pawn were on
B5
after a check here the king could then
run to the A5 square if the Palm run B5
but because the pawn is here there is
nowhere for The Rook King the high from
the rook's checks and so you just keep
checking all the way until eventually
the king runs this way and only then you
can bring your Rook behind the passer
once the king is away from it it is
really tricky stuff it takes a lot of
study it takes uh quite a lot of
perseverance because these players
they've been going at it for nearly
seven hours now so I will not be
surprised if more mistakes happen this
has been an exhausting game for these
players
and uh we have a move
what did
Jordan play he gave a check to the king
oh
I I agree with you I mean
there's so many twists and turns in this
and then to utilize the whole idea of
checking by the side that was just
insanely good
I mean to have the dexterity to kind of
pivot from checking from behind to
checking from the side to putting your
king all the way on the G2 Square just
to break all the fundamental rules that
we've been taught I mean that's just
incredible and you can get there though
if you memorize certain signposts so to
speak if you memorize certain techniques
and certain positions and you like okay
this one I know is uh winning this one I
know is completely lost like for
instance the checking from the side it's
called The Vancouver position right
yes so if you memorize the technique
there you're like okay this I I've got
it and you can use that to assist you in
those quick decision making moments
yeah this is what you need to do you
need to rely on previous study and
experience uh coming up with this kind
of stuff at the board is really
difficult and if Jordan has done that I
mean he really deserves uh the
proverbial tip of the cap so yeah it's a
really impressive defense right now from
him we talk about King D5 there's Rook
F6 I think Vincent can try King B5
because it's still not clear that the
draw is in the bag let's say you bring
your Rook to F6 go after this Pawn but
if you release with Rook A1 you still
need to find
I would think to move maybe okay E3 key
E3 right close enough
yeah I thought we were gonna have to
find King G3 again and do these checks
but King E3 the king is just very close
to the Past Pawn Yeah
so tense so complicated and the path to
the draw on all the victory of that
matter is so narrow
okay but here
um where would you go with your king I
think I probably would be tempted to
to put the King on
D4 I guess
yeah King B4 I guess there's Rook B6
check just
ask that King where it's going because
if it keeps going the C file you give
more checks if the king ever goes back
to the fifth rank The Rook quickly
slides to F6 yeah goes after the pawn I
I have an idea what about if you just uh
Park the King on a two a one whatever
and then start
yeah it's a king A2
and you just abandon the F Pawn
you're saying some kind of yeah
something like this
but put the Rook on A3
take it A5
oh my work is so badly placed okay I I
actually need to move my king I need to
be a bit more subtle than this and
actually put my king all the way to A1
it's not pretty but who knows what
happens there okay and now Rook A2 so
that I get maximum checking distance and
now the big Journey
and then you still you're close
[Laughter]
you can only legally move your rook and
then the Rook takes the Palm with check
which is very important because if that
were not checked you'd be able to skewer
on the third ring but that is check and
then the Rook moves away we have Rook
and King versus rook and king that of
course is a draw
yeah
oh
better
I do suspect that we're gonna see
the line that you showed where white is
forced to give checks
with his Rook from the side
that's the most uh complicated path to
equality
I feel for Vincent I really do
he played that
seven hour game yesterday you swing
another seven hour game he's showing
fighting spirit that should get him
invited to every tournament going
forward but he is trying giving it his
all and unfortunately yesterday it
wasn't quite enough escaped and today it
looks like Jordan
he is going to escape he's weaseling his
way out of this
I mean it just goes to show first of all
you have this classical time control
which
it means that the standard of play is
just ridiculously high and uh secondly
you know we have to talk about the
endurance the fatigue and thirdly chess
is a difficult game
and also I really do think that Vincent
is just being unlucky in this tournament
I'm waiting for him to like at least
betray
his emotions right seeing his face
betray his emotions because he's just
calculating he's working on it but I'm
wondering if he realizes that this
position is a draw or if he feels like
he sells hope I don't like to read too
much into body language I say that and I
do it and I ask people about it uh but I
feel like he knows that
that this win is a thing of a pass if it
ever existed
yeah I
I suspect
he doesn't yet hundred percent know
but probably there'll come a time when
he can't make further progress
that we will see the frustration because
it is frustrating right I mean
he's
these last two games have all handed in
real component endings he's been much
better he's been winning at moments in
both of these end games at uh in both of
these end games he's been virtually two
pawns up
and they've been technically drawn I
mean what are the chances of that
someone is saying to Vincent
hey Vincent it's time you started
recomponent endings
he's gonna have to work on it for sure
and for Jordan he's going to need to
work on avoiding handing us upon
material because throughout this
tournament he's actually given his
opponents pawns against uh five of
carwana he just wandered his G4 pawn and
then lost the game against Wesley so in
the first round he missed the Knight F4
tactic lost a pawn uh he actually and
gives Rich report he was down upon an
end game at some moment or he was that
one early and then managed to hold the
draw so he actually has really struggled
keeping his material so both of these
players just like every chess player
they have things to work on and for
vidson it's clear that it's the rook and
pawn endings right now uh but maybe it's
a stamina thing maybe it's not just the
positions that are unfolding it's like
you get to the seventh hour and all you
want to do is eat some food and take a
nap so
it's hard to say he has a great coach he
you know is an exceptional player he'll
continue honing his craft
and he'll he'll improve but it is a big
question because this is the second rook
and pawn and end game in a row that is
slipping through his hands
yeah
but In fairness to Vincent they've been
incredibly complicated for componentings
it hasn't I mean these wins haven't been
kind of carelessly lost I would say I
think that they've been a product of
seven sorry six hours hard work of uh
and like you say I would uh think about
endurance fatigue
and maybe just refreshing my mind about
these uh particular particularly uh
difficult ones you know certain
fortresses etc etc
um and uh there we have a check from
Jordan no sorry from Vincent so the
first question is can you just capture
that pawn
and he doesn't
I was going to say I feel like the
answer might be no because if your king
takes F5 now the king is cut off and
Rook C4 this king is very far away the a
pawn starts going and the king is cut
off on the C file as well is on the
fourth rank so the a pawn is going to
make it to the other side it would
appear
and the good news as well is that let's
say you move your Rook here back to f8
A5 you give this check the black king
can hide on A4 and once the king gets
closer you play Rook B4
and that's the move necessary to get
this Rook off the B file so you can move
your king and push the pawn so Rook A8
that looks good you're keeping the king
stuck you want to go to uh the B3 square
and then here
I guess
yeah you can make room or you can step
back with your king and no no don't step
back with the King because King D5 so
and instead make room
make way for the monarch
and if Rook B8 then there's the problem
is this Rook is overloaded The Rook
needs to stop the king from escaping and
The Rook also needs to stay in contact
with the pawn because Rook B8 is King A3
now the pawn gets up a square this King
cannot approach The Rook on the fourth
rank keeps it away so King D5 A4 King C5
good for you
I'm gonna keep pushing and because your
king is so far I'm just going to
actually put this at its conclusion that
once you're here check into the corner
let's say look here and if you make the
move A2 after Rook B7 it looks like the
king can never get out but black has the
move to bring the Rook down you want to
bring this Rook down to go get your Ting
out so you make the move Rook to H2 the
next move is Rook B2 followed by King B1
and finally your Pawn will be able to
grow it's a really long story rook and
pawning games are tricky uh needs to
study them you need to work on them but
as long as the king gets out it would be
good
yeah uh definitely I agree with that and
uh in talking about the tricky
for the compound endings we see some
more checks on the board
there's just no way
for Vincent to hold on to this Pawn F5
and as you can see the white king is
inching towards the defense of the
a pawn and look at that King goes to E1
not allowed controlling ft
exactly
and uh
now it's totally totally drawn nothing
to be done here and uh Vincent realizes
yeah and you can see Jordan he's just
trying to remain focused because he
knows it's a draw he's worked hard for
this half point and for Vincent there
were a couple moves where the table base
said it was a win he didn't find only
options so he we thought he was going to
bring his King forward and then go on
over to help first Usher IS F Pawn then
go after the a pawn he didn't do that it
was a tricky tricky position he is
exhausted this is the second day in a
row of playing until the very end he
undoubtedly has played the most moves he
must have the longest games he is giving
it his all and he just simply must be
what just a 13-round tournament no
opponent is easy and well for Vincent it
just sadly for him not meant to be at
the moment
and not meant to be
feels very appropriate no way to defend
the f porn
so the only thing you can do is just go
all in with your a pawn and get running
and hope you wouldn't makes a mistake
but a bad news the King on E1 is just
too close
yeah once the F5 Pawn is captured the
king will just run over towards the
queen side in that pond so you
main thing about playing King to D2 but
then this F Pawn remains after Rook to
F1 and maybe it's still a draw in that
position but I don't think I would test
the waters I would just put King E2 keep
the F1 Square under control because
white is going to take this Pawn on F5
next
yeah I agree I wouldn't necessarily test
the waters because you know that's just
too flashy for your own good you know
the root can come to F1 and then maybe
it can park itself on F4 and then use
some protective squares to give check to
the white king no Simplicity is the best
King goes to E2 Jordan
you'd been doing a Herculean task so far
you've got to continue maintain Focus
don't get distracted now that the draw
is within grasp
and he is really focused he is just
taking in the position is making sure
that his King goes to the correct Square
because the worst thing that can happen
to you is you work for seven hours you
manage to survive the game and then you
make a careless blunder
after all that hard work so for him
he does not want to waste it he would
like to get this draw move up to 4 out
of 10. a respectable showing for him not
the standard he set for himself when he
won he taught himself Masters back in
2021 but
it's such a tough field that you may win
one year and then have a big minus score
the next and that's true whether you're
Jordan from forest or Fabiano caruana
who I think went minus four one year so
he scored I think it was it was a four
and a half out of 13 maybe it was five
out of 13. either way it was well before
is well below excuse me his expected
performance yeah and he's not the only
one I I remember Magnus Carlson in 2021
had a terrible uh Tata steel I think he
ended up I say terrible but terrible in
comparison to his usual standards
because I think he finished six or
sevens
and
yeah it's just that's the way life goes
right but somehow I kind of
I feel that this field has been so
perfect we've seen the right combination
between youth experience Fighting Chess
everyone has played their heart and soul
and as fonsillion points out Arbiter
about to make a move yeah
now that would be a first if the Arbiter
came in and said hang on a second I
think
you should play this I've actually had
that not during the game but after the
game The Arbiter came and told me hey
you missed a win and in fact you missed
several wins and I was so shell-shocked
because it was such an emotional you
know game full of time travel that I was
just like
I just looked at them like I don't know
what life you're talking about and then
afterwards when I got back to the
computer I was like yeah she was totally
right
several wins
was the Arbiter sitting with an engine
to help you know no no it was just uh it
was just one of those situations where
the Arbiter was a very strong player and
actually I do think Arbiters in general
should be strong players I think they
should understand the game they should
be able to understand deep Concepts such
as triangulation or
easily be able to spot the threefold
repetition although having said that
computers these day these days do the
job for them there
and there is one I guess the Arbiters
don't have access to engines but I was
going to say anytime there's an Arbiter
with a computer and things like that
like if they know chess and their their
look May betray them or they look at a
position they see some move was played
and if they're a strong player they're
like wait why what just happened there
so you always have to be stone-faced and
just uh not give away any details but
the Arbiter did go over there bring the
players a new score sheet because
they're that far along in this game uh
this last move was move 81 for black I
don't remember how many moves Vincent's
game was yesterday but it seems like
he's trying to break the all-time record
in pots of Steel
yeah I don't remember either and I can
pull it up I can find out
it was
we're now at 82. so we're gonna
have more moves in this game than
yesterday but it's just so many moves
for Vincent and they unfortunately are
not leading to victories
no no in terms of getting that past born
Through The Rook Pawn I've said it time
and time again and I cannot say enough
it's the worst kind of Pawn it's so
complicated to get that one through to
its destination and it needs a lot of
assistance such as the white king being
cut off I mean that's just the irony of
it all because if that were a B Pawn
instead of a newborn the game probably
would have been over a long long time
ago and uh there we see Jordan he puts
his king sorry he puts his Rook all the
way to the edge of the board getting
ready to check the black king from
behind
and the players making their moves
relatively quickly
so but why King is cut off but it's too
close because uh if people remember we
were talking about how this Rook needed
to go all the way around and go to B2
black doesn't have time for that just to
quickly just go through that variation
we get something like this
we push the pawn so just to
go uh forward with this again in the
other position the white King was all
the way up here too far away but in this
position once the black Rook releases
then the white king goes to C2 so even
if you give this check the King goes up
you're not getting your Rook to B2 to uh
give your king the file and if you go
down here trying to
get the B file there's nowhere to run to
once this Rook moves away
you give a check the white king can go
back and the King cannot Escape that is
the problem you need the king to be able
to run away but the white king is
keeping it trapped in the corner yeah
you you cannot basically Drive the king
and Rook to the ideal destinations just
using a rook it's just not physically
possible two pieces
cannot sorry one piece cannot dominate
Two Pieces Just
maths and uh look
goes to the edge I'm expecting the white
king
just to create forward to the C line
doesn't really matter where I think
Jordan can be as complacent as possible
the only thing he mustn't do is he
mustn't go on a big adventure put the
king up to the fourth rank or something
just a simple chess
this is the finishing straight for
Jordan
and a little bit of care will be
sufficient
he did all the hard work so if he
somehow stumbles over here that would be
rather rather inexplicable he really uh
at this stage can just continue
shuffling and as soon as this Pawn goes
to A3 and Rook goes to B2 you release
your rook and go elsewhere but and for a
player like Jordan Von Forrest a former
champion in Viking Zay uh yeah he's not
going to blunder away this half point no
no way I agree with you this is in game
101 and it's the kind of thing that most
players I'm gonna say actually memorize
and use Justice to secure a very easy
draw
the formula is so simple it's very
straightforward to keep the black king
cut off and uh just uh wait with a rook
if need be
you move the king up to C2 it was
checked away
and uh Jordan playing very precisely
Here Comes The Rook Vincent trying he's
trying to say get off the B line and uh
Jordan just says not a problem I will
vacate
but you're not going anywhere
do not take this Rook on B2 that would
be a big mistake he
understands that removes his Rook
way to C7 and he's just gonna go back
and forth so one other thing
is that if we get a position with a king
going to A1 the move Rook C2 if you take
it it's a because the king cannot get
out of the corner that's the problem
with the Ripon is the boundary so we are
seeing moves we're seeing Rook to B6
blade I wonder what
um you know what I think I know how this
game is going to end yeah me too and
we're I think black is gonna give up a
rook for stalemate
exactly
it's uh the king is going to go to A1
the pawn is going to go to A2 and the
frick is just gonna plant itself from B2
and game over players smile and they
rush off to the restaurants
that are probably all close
you know it's like uh that time of the
night where it's a weekday it's super
late maybe somebody saved them a
sandwich from somewhere uh but yeah
they're missing dinner time
yeah
and
is it coming
look at Jordan he knows the draws there
but just does not want to spoil it
so I think we're gonna see that
A2
Rook here yeah
would not be surprised of Rook B2 I
actually no no he can't do that
yeah well there's a big threat on the
board actually so
[Laughter]
and that's why he plays King 80.
Rick CT check
ing goes back my friend
oh he's gonna play King B1 and then Rook
B2 and then Pawn takes B2 stalemate
that's what's gonna happen this Rook is
gonna slide over and then Rook B2 and
pawn take stomach goodness
yeah
it looks like Jordan van Forest he is
going to officially secure there it is
Rook B2 check
a little cheeky move if that Rook is
captured when that Rook is captured the
game is a draw by stalemate so for
Vincent kymer second straight day of
disappointment the handshake is agreed
upon just because the result is not in
question and for Vincent
great chats from him these last two days
he deserves a lot of credit uh his play
is better than his score that's how I
would frame it and that's not much in
the moment when you're kicking yourself
with your missed opportunities but he is
a very strong player he is hyper
talented and just right now these little
moments are getting away from him and
he's not converting his advantages
yeah and uh there we can see Vincent
analyzing with you with a smile on their
face and both of them just laughing and
that's really nice to see because
they have
just run us through a big roller coaster
you know first of all Jordan was much
much better than this big tactical
blunder from the Dutchman and suddenly
we had this incredible instructor
incredibly instructive rook and pawn
ending
and I'm asking me I learned loads
and I I realized that it wasn't as easy
as I thought it was and the players
smiling laughing about it and
it's just a great moment of Happiness to
see
yeah it is nice to see after that long
battle the players are still talking
about moves that happened who knows six
hours ago but the result is in the books
Jordan van Forest draws the game against
Vincent kymer we had five draws at the
top there gukesh wins with white against
his compatriots his fellow teenager from
India pravananda and then paramaksuda
lost with the white pieces Magnus
Carlson he looked very strong in today's
action it was a position where the eval
bar is saying yeah it's equal and
magnets like not so fast if you were
gonna make this draw you're gonna have
to prove it each and every move or could
not do that especially with his low time
so heading into tomorrow's rest day uh
the results are clear the leaderboard is
set we know that nordia Abdul sitarov is
in first and
well Joey we have four players including
abusitarov who have a shot at first
place Anish
Magnus Wesley and these four players are
all about to play one another it is kind
of anyone's tournament
it certainly is and uh that sets us sets
us up very very nicely for the last
three rounds and all the drama it's
gonna happen in round 11. I mean I
wouldn't miss it for the world
[Music]
well round 11 happens on Friday so if
you tune in tomorrow Looking For Tons of
Steel action that's on you this tomorrow
is a rest day but when we return we see
some great matchups in store Magnus
Carlsen takes on the person who shares
is standing Wesley so Magnus the white
pieces we see down at the bottom Anish
Kiri versus no direct Abdul sitarov that
is the matchup for first place and Levon
aronian in the middle against fabina
caruana those players are tied for the
fifth place and if there is a winner
maybe they also have an outside chance
at first but it has been a really long
day
you'll be what would you say is the
summary of today's action and what are
you looking forward to in the next round
yeah I mean it's absolutely been
brilliant uh what can I say there's been
so much fireworks and and so many
instructive moments I have loved every
second of it and I'll have to thank our
producers and the chat also for giving
us some nice comments from chat thank
you very much to everyone who watched
you it's just watched us it's been a
real pleasure I
wouldn't have missed it for the world
and it's been an honor commenting
alongside you Robert and also alongside
Dania in the previous days oh my God
it's been brilliant and what a fantastic
tournament it's been so far the chess
games have been absolutely intense so so
good
the games have been Stellar the players
are giving it their all we saw this one
Go the Distance it only just finished
after seven hours and more seven hours
ten minutes of play so I had a look at
my computer's clock to see that Vincent
kymer Jordan fun for us they might not
even know what time it is but that was a
great defensive effort from Jordan we
saw Magnus Carlsen with black we saw goo
guess one with white two games done
early with the draw but Yogi I have to
thank you because how long this
broadcast went it was really fun to
commentate alongside you you made it
that much smoother that much easier when
the clock kept going and going going and
vincentimer determined as he was
unfortunately he couldn't make it so I
do want to thank you I want to thank our
producer and I want to thank everybody
who tuned in for this action it's been
fun it was round 10 here in Vikings day
the top Masters continues on Friday
around 11. we'll be back same time same
place see you then
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]